VERY GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE HEARING.
THIS OF COURSE IS THE
COMMITTEE'S FIRST HEARING ON.
AUDIT REQUESTS THAT WE'RE HAVING
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
I WANT TO WELCOME ALL THE
MEMBERS BACK.
WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE MORE
JOINING US VERY SHORTLY.
.
IN PARTICULAR.
I.
WOULD LIKE TO ASK VICE CHAIR
SENATOR ROTH TO.
.
JOIN US AS THERE IS SOME
QUESTION THE SENATE IS GOING TO
BE CONVENING THEIR FLOOR SESSION
AT TEN A. M. AND SO.
I NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH HIM ABOUT.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO?
?
JUGGLE OUR SCHEDULES HERE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A QUICK AND
KNOWLEDGE AND TO SOME CHANGES TO
THE MEMBERSHIP OR OF OUR
COMMITTEE. A SENATOR ALLEN BEEN
ALLEN IS GOING TO BE REPLACING
CENTER ATKINS.
ON THE.
COMMITTEE.
AS WE ALL KNOW CENTER ATKINS
WILL BE.
OUR NEXT PRESS SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM AND SO THAT IS THE
REASON FOR THAT REPLACEMENT.
BY AND FOURTH TODAY ALTHOUGH I
DON'T SEE HIM YET.
SOME BE MEMBER SANTIAGO WILL BE.
REPLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
HIS AREA AND.
JUST FOR THE PURPOSES OF TODAY'S
HEARING.
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO MAY BE LISTENING.
AND WATCHING.
THEY TV TO REPORT TO ROOM FOUR
FOUR FOUR SO WE CAN.
STATUS CORPSMAN TAKE CARE
TODAY'S BUSINESS.
ALRIGHT.
WHY DON'T WE?
STRONG FUN A.
WELCOMING.
.
OUR STATE AUDITOR MS.
ELAINE HOW AND FIRST OF ALL MS
HOW BEFORE YOU GO PROCEED I
WOULD LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
MYSELF ON HER RECENT
REAPPOINTMENT. AYE AS OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR I
BELIEVE YOU ARE NOW THE LONGEST
SERVING STATE AUDITOR AND
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP THIS LAST YEAR
AND TRYING TO GET THE. THE RE
APPOINTMENT PROCESS
PUSHED THROUGH I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR OF MAKING HIS DECISION
RECENTLY TO REAPPOINT NAM HONOR
TO. TO SERVE IN THIS POSITION I
WANT TO THANK THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY SUPPORTIVE. OF ME
AND MY OFFICE SO I I DO
APPRECIATE THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO PUT A SHOUT OUT
TO MY STAFF MY EXECUTIVE TEAM
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUSLY SUPPORTIVE
OF ME IN THE LAST.
SEVERAL YEARS BUT CERTAINLY IN
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
OUR WHERE WE FUND THROUGH A
DIFFICULT TIME.
BUT CERTAINLY.
AYE I LEAN ON THEM AS I KNOW
YOU DO ON YOUR STAFF AND THEY
HAVE BEEN WITH ME EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY AND I I CAN'T THANK THEM
ENOUGH. AND THEN FINALLY
THANKING ALL OF MY STAFF
MANY OF WHOM I'M SURE WATCHING
THIS HEARING AS THEY DO.
EVERY TIME J. LACK MEETS AND
THANK ALL OF THEM FOR THEIR
TREMENDOUS EFFORTS OF OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS I'M REALLY
PROUD OF WHAT OUR ORGANIZATION
ACCOMPLISHES AND. AND CERTAINLY
THRILLED AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
SERVING THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS SO. THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH
I'M TRULY HONORED. TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE IN THIS
POSITION.
I WRITE A THANK YOU THE US
STATUS REPORT MEMBERS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FOURTEEN
AUDITS IN PROGRESS TWO OF THOSE
ARE STATUTORY AUDITS IT'S OUR
ANNUAL AUDIT OF THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS ARE WE HAVE
A PRESENCE AT MANY STATE
AGENCIES. AND CERTAINLY WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IN AUDITING
THE STATEMENTS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CLEARLY THAT
INFORMATION IS IMPORTANT AND OUR
OPINION. IS USED BY BOND FOR
BOND RATINGS AT CETERA SO THAT
WORK WILL BE COMPLETED IN MARCH
AS IT IS EVERY EVERY YEAR.
WHEN WE ISSUE AN OPINION ON THE
STATEMENTS WE HAVE TWELVE JAIL
LACK AUDIT SO THERE ARE NO
AUDITS.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
APPROVED THERE AWAITING STAFF WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THE COMMISSION ON
JUDICIAL PERFORMANCE.
SITUATION WHERE WE WHERE WE ARE
STILL.
IN LITIGATION.
AS I'M SURE YOU ARE AWARE THE
QUICKLY THERE WAS A DECISION
MADE WE ARE DECIDED TO APPEAL
THAT DECISION. ARE AND CONTINUE
TO PURSUE OUR ABILITY TO AUDIT
THE COMMISSION ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE MEMBERS WHO REQUESTED THE
ART AND CERTAINLY THAT THE
COMMITTEE'S DECISION TO DIRECT
US TO CONDUCT THAT WORK.
OTHER WORK IN PROGRESS WE HAVE
AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT WE PUT OUT
THAT WE HOPE IS BENEFICIAL TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND AS
PARTICULAR LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
IT'S OUR ANNUAL SUBCOMMITTEE
REPORT SO IT IS A COMPILATION OF
AUDITS THAT WE'VE CONDUCTED IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND
REALLY THE STATUS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. ALSO IN THAT
REPORT WE PUT OUT ON AN ANALYSIS
OF THE MONETARY BENEFITS THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED BASED ON THE
AUDIT WORK THAT WE'VE DONE.
BOMBING WE WE YOU KNOW VALUE THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND
CERTAINLY THE WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ASKS US TO DO.
UP TO BEFORE YOU TODAY THERE ARE
SIX AUDIT REQUESTS THAT WE WILL
BE DISCUSSING. ON AS FAR AS
RESOURCES FROM MY OFFICE WE HAVE
STAFF WHO ARE READY TO HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING. I HAVE ABOUT TEN
TEAMS AVAILABLE BETWEEN NOW AND
APRIL FOR THOSE TEAMS CAN START
IN FEBRUARY SO WE CAN
IMMEDIATELY START FOR AUDITS.
AND THEN WE CAN PICK UP ANOTHER.
THERE'S ONLY SIX ON THE AGENDA
ANOTHER TWO BUT WE HAVE STAFF TO
START THREE MORE OUT ITS IN
MARCH THREE MORONS IN APRIL SO
WE HAVE PLENTY OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE.
LAST COMMENT IS THERE HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONS FROM SOME MEMBERS IN
THE PAST
WHAT'S YOUR CAPACITY OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR SO EVEN IF
YOU APPROVE ALL SIX AUDITS
TODAY.
WE TYPICALLY HAVE RESOURCES THIS
COMMITTEE TYPICALLY APPROVES
BETWEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY FIVE
ON A TWO YEAR SO WE CERTAINLY
HAVE CAPACITY FOR FUTURE
HEARINGS. OUGHT TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL WORK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VACUUM AS HELL
AND DEATH THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK. THAT IS ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME.
SO BAKER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND.
MADAM AUDITOR ON THE JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE AUDIT CAN YOU OF
JUST GIVE A SUMMARY OF WHAT THE
ANTICIPATED TIMELINES ARE IN
TERMS OF WHEN. AN APPEAL WOULD
BE DO AND MAYBE WHAT THAT THE
CONSTRAINTS WE HAVE ONE OF THE.
REQUEST WAS OF THAT AUDIT AND I
AM A EAGER TO FIND OUT WHAT TIME
FRAME WERE LOOKING AT THANK YOU
AND I'M GONNA ASK MY CHIEF
COUNSEL STEPHANIE ROMERO'S
RIDGEWAY TO COME UP IN A SHE'S
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR OUTSIDE
COUNSEL GROUP WITH RESPECT TO
THIS.
GOOD MORNING.
SO WE ARE SEEKING AND AN APPEAL
WE HAVE UP FILED A NOTICE OF
APPEAL WERE WAITING FOR THE
SUPERIOR COURT TO ACTUALLY
CERTIFY ITS DECISION APPARENTLY
THEY ARE. TWO MONTHS BEHIND IN
IN THAT REGARD. AND WE ARE ALSO
CONTEMPLATING SEEKING A
REQUESTING AN EXPEDITED APPEAL I
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE COURT
OF APPEAL WILL ACCEPT THAT
REQUEST FOR EXPEDITION BUT.
I THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE DISCUSSED WITH OUR COUNSEL
AND IF THE MEMBERS ARE EAGER FOR
US TO PURSUE THAT. ON THAT IS
INFORMATION THAT WILL TAKE UNDER
ADVISEMENT AS A MAKE THAT
DECISION IS THERE A DEADLINE BY
WHICH THE COURT HAS TO THE
SPIRIT PROTESTERS CERTIFY ITS
OPINION.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF.
AND OPENING THEM I BELIEVE
THERE'S A BACKLOG WITHIN THEIR
SYSTEM THE LAST THAT I HEARD
THEY WERE CAUGHT UP THROUGH THE
END OF NOVEMBER. OUR DECISION
CAME OUT ABOUT A TWELVE TWENTY
TO TWELVE TWENTY THREE. SO A
COUPLE OF WEEKS I HOPE GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
WE WILL NOW MOVE INTO THE SECOND
PORTION OF THE AGENDA TO
CONSIDER THE AUDIT REQUESTS.
OF FOR APPROVAL OF BEFORE I GO
ANY FURTHER I'D LIKE TO.
POINT OUT.
SOME CHANGES TO THE AGENDA.
AS I BELIEVE THE PUBLIC COPY I
SHOWS THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL. PRODDED REQUESTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PULLED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON'S
AUDIT TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OH ONE HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN'S.
AUDIT REQUEST AUDIT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE OH THREE HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA.
AND ADDITIONALLY I WANTED TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS NO ONE
IN THE AUDIENCE. RELATED TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S.
HIGH RISK LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AUDIT REQUESTS.
I WANTED TO.
KNOW THAT THE COMMITTEE
RECEIVED.
LETTER FROM THE STATE AUDITOR
PROVIDING HER PROPOSAL TO AUDIT
THREE CITIES.
AS THIS IS A RELATIVELY NEW
PROGRAM WE ARE.
AND CONSULTATION WITH THE THE
LESSON OF COUNSEL ON SOME LEGAL
AND PROCEDURAL ISSUES RELATED TO
THE LOCAL HIGH RISK PROGRAM.
ONCE WE.
ADDRESS THESE QUESTIONS WITH
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WE WILL NOW
PROCEED AT A LATER HEARING ON.
THE LOCAL HIGH SPEED.
HIGH RISK AUDIT REQUESTS.
I THINK THAT IS IT.
HAS TO THE AGENDA WE HAVE.
SIX REQUESTS
I HERE TODAY A TWO ON THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THAT LEAVES FOR AUDITS FOR
PRESENTATION TODAY WILL TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I DO NOT CO
QUORUM YET TO.
CENTER ROTH IF YOU CAN.
GET YOUR A HERE CENTERS HERE
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD VIA. AND.
.
I UNDERSTAND CENTER.
BUT.
YES AND ONE OTHER ITEM.
THAT WAS PULLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON HAS PULLED HIS AUDIT
REQUEST AUDIT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE OH NINE.
SO WITH THAT.
I BELIEVE THE FIRST IN LINE IS.
MS GARCIA AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COME FOR.
ALRIGHT SO THIS IS.
.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR ON THE REGULAR
CALENDAR.
AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE OH SEVEN DEPARTMENT
OF RESOURCES RECYCLING RECOVERY.
QUESTION OVERSIGHT OF THE
MATTRESS RECYCLING COUNCIL. FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CRISTINA
GARCIA.
LET'S SEE BEFORE WE.
YES.
MS GARCIA BLOCKING.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. RECONSIDERATION AT THE
REQUEST BY THE AUDIT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MATTRESS RECYCLING
PROGRAM.
THE SPERM WITH ESTABLISHED BY
SENATOR HANCOCK IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN TO DEAL WITH THE HUGE
NUMBERS OF BB ILLEGALLY DUMP
MASTER SERVE AND HER DISTRICT.
BY REFLECT LEADER. THEY'LL
CONTINUE.
I'M SORRY CONTRIBUTE TO BLOOD IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
LAST MONTH I LEARNED THAT A
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESS IN MY
DISTRICT HAD ITS CONTRACT
CANCELED AND WOULD BE CLOSELY
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
PUTTING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY OUT OF
WORK.
EVERY SOUTH MRC TO ASK THEM TO
CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS TO SEE IF
A COMPROMISE COULD BE REACHED ON
THEIR CONTRACT.
I CONTINUE TO BE FULL HOPEFUL
THAT AN AGREEMENT CAN BE
REACHED.
AS THE CHAIR OF NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE MY STAFF AND
I BEGAN LOOKING INTO HOW THE
STATE'S MATCHES RECYCLING
PROGRAM WAS GOING.
IT IS AMONG THE FIRST OF THE
STATE'S PRODUCTS. OF STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAMS AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THE PROGRAM IS
ACCOMPLISHING ITS GOLD.
I WAS APPOINTED BY THAT WHILE
MRC SEEMS TO BE MEETING AT
COLLECTION GOAL OF AROUND TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT.
IT DOES NOT SEEM TO BE MEETING
THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY IT DOES NOT SEEM TO
BE ADDRESSING THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF SB TWO FIFTY FOUR TO
REDUCE ILLEGAL DUMPING AND CLEAN
UP MATTRESSES THAT ARE DUMPED.
THE PROGRAM IS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO
FIND THE COLLECTION OF ILLEGALLY
THIS BOTH MATTRESS IF.
PROVIDE A MECHANISM FOR THE
RECOVERY OF THE MATTRESSES AT NO
ADDITIONAL COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND PROVIDE COLLECTION SERVICES
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE
THAT MRCS FULFILLING THESE
REQUIREMENTS.
IN SPITE OF THESE CONCERNS AND
MARCIE WAS ABLE TO REDUCE THE
FEE ON MATTRESS SALES FROM
ELEVEN DOLLARS TO TEN FIFTY ON
THE BIRTH OF THE YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
APPROVE THIS AUDIT TODAY SO THAT
WE CAN ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE GETTING THE FULL
BENEFIT OF THE PROGRAM THEY ARE
PAYING FOR.
THANK YOU.
AS HELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
INDICATED THIS WOULD BE AN AUDIT
OF THE MATTRESS RECYCLING
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA WE WOULD.
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
OUR RESOURCES.
I RECYCLING IN RECOVERY CAL
RECYCLE CALMLY REFER TO SO WE
WOULD LOOK AT CAL RECYCLES
OVERSIGHT OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
ENSURING THAT THE COUNCIL AYE IS
FALLING LAWS RULES REGULATIONS
THERE WERE REGULATIONS THAT WERE
PROMULGATED RELATED TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM SO. SO
STARTING AT CAL RECYCLING
LOOKING AT WHAT TYPE OF
OVERSIGHT THERE PROVIDING THEIR
REQUIRED TO APPROVE AN ANNUAL
PLAN THEY'RE REQUIRED TO LOOK AT
THE BUDGET FOR THE COUNCIL
ETCETERA SO. LOOKING AT THEIR
OVERSIGHT THEN FOCUSING ON THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION RELATED TO
THE PROGRAM THE REVENUE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE FUND
BALANCE IT APPEARS FUND BALANCE
RELATIVELY HIGH. UP BUT ALSO
SHE'S ASKING US TO LOOK AT
EXPENDITURE REPORTS IDENTIFYING
MAJOR CATEGORIES OF EXPENDITURES
ARM AND DETERMINING WHETHER OR
NOT THE PROGRAM HAS RESOURCES
SUFFICIENT. TO ENSURE THAT THIS
PROGRAM MEETS ITS GOALS FOR
CALIFORNIA ON AS I INDICATED SHE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE FUND BALANCE DETERMINE
WHETHER IT'S REASONABLE. AND
THEN THE LAST COUPLE OF
OBJECTIVES REALLY ABOUT ARE WE
ACHIEVING OUR AS A STATE.
THROUGH CALORIE CYCLE IS THIS
PROGRAM ACHIEVING THE EXPECTED
INTENT ARE THEY INVESTING ENOUGH
MONEY IN PUBLIC OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION OUGHT NEW TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGY CONTRACTING WITH
PARTICULAR. OF VENDORS IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROCESS MATTRESSES
TO REFURBISH REUSE IT CETERA SO
THE LAST COUPLE OF OBJECTIVES
ARE RELATED TO THAT AS FAR AS
HOW WELL THIS PROGRAM IS
FUNCTIONING IN CALIFORNIA. THE
BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT IS A
LITTLE LESSON TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
HOURS IT'S ABOUT A FIVE MONTHS
FIVE MONTHS AMOUNT OF TIME.
OF STAFF TIME TO CONDUCT THE
WORK.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
MS GORE SHOULD YOU HAVE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTIVE REQUEST
IDEA. ELEVEN TO DO THEMSELVES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MELISSA AND
MULLIN AND WHICH I YOU ORDER AND
TO BE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL OR CPSC AS WELL AS THE
NATIONAL SEARCH ACTION COUNCIL.
AND ALSO BEEN US TO CONVEY
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF STOP WASTE
AS THEY WERE UNABLE TO MAKE IT
TODAY.
CPSC ADVOCATES FOR EXTENDED
PRODUCE RESPONSIBILITY AT WHICH
IS A POLICY THAT REQUIRES
PRODUCERS TO SHARE AND THE END
OF LIFE MANAGEMENT OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY SELL. WHICH
ULTIMATELY END UP IN
CALIFORNIA'S WE STREAM.
THIS POLICY APPROACH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AND
EFFECTIVE FOR PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT AND OF LIFE IMPACTS
SUCH AS MATTRESSES.
CPSU SUPPORTS I REQUEST TO
ENSURE THAT THE MATTRESS
RECYCLING COUNCIL IS FULFILLING
THE GOALS OF CALIFORNIA'S
MATCHES RECYCLING LA.
THIS IS A TARGETED AUDIT THAT
ADDRESSES SOME KEY ISSUES TO
ASSESS THE SUCCESSES AND
FAILURES OF THE EMBASSIES
EXPERIENCES THUS FAR.
BUT ALSO WORKING WITH MRC
ENCOUNTER CYCLE TO ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT DON'T FALL WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
BUT THE PROGRAM IS OFF TO A
FAIRLY GOOD START AND WE HAVE
SEEN SOME POSITIVE DEVELOPMENTS
WE'VE ALSO SEEN INDICATIONS OF A
NEED TO ASSESS THEM MARCY'S
PROGRESS.
A KEY REASON THAT THIS PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED WAS TO REDUCE
ILLEGAL DUMPING OF MATTRESSES
AND ALTHOUGH SOME PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE.
ILLEGAL DUMPING IS STILL A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE BURDENED WITH RELATED COSTS.
IT SEEMS THAT THE MRC COULD BE
DOING MORE TO FULLY REALIZE THE
GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE GEORGIA PROGRAMS ARE
NIGHT APR EPR PRODUCER PAY MODEL
NOR A GOVERNMENT COMMAND AND
CONTROL APPROACH WE'VE SEEN SOME
OF THE STATE'S PROGRAMS FACE
CHALLENGES.
THIS AUDIT WILL HAVE IT'S GET
AHEAD OF POTENTIAL PROBLEMS IN
THE MATCHES PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
THEM EARLY ON WITH EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT AND NOT WAY AS WE DID
ON CARPET FOR EXAMPLE.
WE NO THE INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE OPERATIONS OF THE
MATTRESS RECYCLING PROGRAM WILL
HOPE IS COLLECTIVELY MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE WAY. TO
AVOID FAILURE DOWN THE LINE.
AS CALIFORNIA'S GOING BACKWARDS
ON A RECYCLING RATE WHILE TRYING
TO REACH THE STATE SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT WASTE RECYCLING GOAL WE
ENCOURAGE A REVIEW OF THIS
PROGRAM SO WE CAN ENSURETHAT
THE MRC IS DOING WHAT IT CAN TO
PROVIDE MAXIMUM BENEFIT FOR ALL
FEE PAYING CALIFORNIANS.
GIVE IT A THREE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
MURRAY WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIA'S GAS WASTE NOW
IF THIS WAS ONE OF THE.
TRADITIONAL WASTE REDUCTION
RECYCLING PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE STATE OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. THE WAY THAT
WE WOULD. THIS THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD PROVIDE OVERSIGHT IN TERMS
OF WHETHER OR NOT THE OBJECTIVES
OF THE PROGRAM RIPPING MATT
WOULD BE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND WE WOULD BASICALLY
LEVERAGE THE DEPARTMENT THAT'S
IN CHARGE OF IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM THIS POLICY USES A
DIFFERENT MODEL WHERE THE
INDUSTRY IS ACTUALLY RUNNING THE
PROGRAM IN THE INDUSTRY IS
COLLECTING THE FUNDS FROM
CONSUMER SO HE GOT BY A
MATTRESS.
THE BILL BILL TELL YOU THAT THE
STATE MAKES US CHARGE THIS TEN
FIFTY OR THIS.
ON THE MATTRESS BUT IN FACT
THAT'S GOING TO THE MATTRESS
INDUSTRY.
WE THOUGHT IN THIS LEGISLATION
WE FOUGHT WE HAD BUILT OVERSIGHT
INTO THIS PROGRAM OVERSIGHT BY
CAL RECYCLE. AND OVERSIGHT BY AN
APPOINTED MATTRESS ADVISORY
COUNCIL
BUT THE THE EVIDENCE OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS IS THAT THOSE
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS ARE WORKING.
ARE THE MATTRESS INDUSTRY WE'RE
NOT SATISFIED WITH TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT RECOVERY RATE WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THREE AND A
HALF MILLION MATTRESSES BEING
GENERATED POTENTIALLY DISCARDED.
WE KNOW THAT PRIVATE SECTOR AND
PUBLIC SECTOR UP OPERATORS LIKE
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES ARE
COLLECTING USED MATTRESSES AND
THEY CAN'T GET THOSE MATTRESSES
INTO THE RECYCLING STREAM
BECAUSE THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE
NOT BEING PAID ENOUGH.
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A
SURPLUS THAT IS GOING TO
APPROACH THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A PROGRAM. THAT IS HAS OF A
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL.
INCOME REVENUE STREAM THAT SEEMS
LIKE AN AWFULLY LARGE BUDGET
SURPLUS TO HAVE WHEN YOU'RE NOT
COMING ANYWHERE CLOSE TO MEETING
YOUR PROGRAM OBJECTIVES.
SO WE THINK THAT THIS OVERSIGHT
BY BY THE. J. LACK MAY BE THE
ONLY GAME IN TOWN IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT THAT WE MAY
HAVE TO. THE LEGISLATURE MAY
HAVE TO RE EXAMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THIS KIND OF POLICY EVEN
MAKE SENSE TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
ONCE REMOVED HAVE THE INDUSTRY
OPERATING A PROGRAM TAKING
CONSUMER FUNDS.
BUT AT THIS POINT IN TIME THE
ONLY MECHANISM WE HAVE TO KIND
OF TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING
ON.
IS THIS KIND OF ODD WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE REQUEST.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE RESPONDING AGENCY IS IS
ERUPTION FROM CAL RECYCLE HERE
.
YEAH. AT MINKA.
THIS GOES AS TO ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES BUT WE LIKE TO ASK.
WITNESSES TO TRY TO KEEP THE
COMMENTS LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES.
HI. I'M CYNTHIA DON IMUS
SUPERVISING THE SENIOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST
WITH COVERAGE OF MICHAEL AND.
I OVERSEE THAT THE PA EPR UNIT
WHICH HOUSES THE. PUB MATTRESS
PROGRAM.
WITH REGARD TO THE DEPARTMENTS
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
THE MATTRESS RECYCLING
ORGANIZATION IN THIS CASE AND
MERCY.
EXECUTES ITS RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER THE LAW.
AND WE DO THIS THROUGH.
AS WAS MENTIONED THE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL OF USE MATTRESS
RECYCLING.
AND RECOVERY PLANS. THE REVIEW
AND APPROVAL OF ANNUAL BUDGETS
WHICH INCLUDES THE CHARGE.
AND THROUGH THE.
REVIEW AND COMPLIANCE REVIEW AT
THE ANNUAL REPORTS.
THE AND REPORTS IN PARTICULAR.
ARE CEMENTED EACH YEAR JULY
FIRST AND THE DEPARTMENT.
EVALUATES THESE PER COMPLIANCE
WITH STATUTES AND RAGS.
THE DEPARTMENT APPROVED IN
MERCIES TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH IS
THEIR FIRST PER PROGRAM YOU'RE
ANNUAL REPORT. AND REQUESTED
THAT THE MRC CONSIDER SPECIFIC
ISSUES RAISED BY STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN PARTICULAR WITH
REGARD TO RESEARCH THE CONSUMER
INCENTIVE PROGRAM CONVENIENCE.
ILLEGAL DUMPING AND MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AND THEN TO REPORT
BACK IN ITS TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
AIRPORT. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO MENTION THAT.
A LOT OF THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
DISCUSSED IN THE LETTER AND.
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THAT DEPARTMENT
CHAIRS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS ME
TO CONVEY THAT THROUGH.
TO THE MRC THROUGH OUR REGULAR
MEETINGS AND ALSO THROUGH OUR
APPROVAL AT THE ANNUAL REPORT.
WITH REGARD TO THAT THE APPROVAL
OF THE FEE REDUCTION.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DEPARTMENT
REVIEWED THAT REQUEST WITH ITS
ANNUAL BUDGET AND DETERMINED
THAT IT MATT IT'S.
ALL THE STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
NECESSARY FOR APPROVAL.
DEPARTMENTS REQUIRED TO APPROVE
AB MATCHES RECYCLING CHARGE THAT
IS.
ENOUGH TO COVER THE PROGRAM THE
PROGRAM COSTS
WHICH THAT TEN FIFTY MATTRESS
RECYCLING CHARGE DEMONSTRATED
THAT IT WOULD HURT THAT.
BUDGET CATEGORIES.
I'D ALSO JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE PRODUCTION BETWEEN.
THE ELEVEN DOLLAR CHARGE AND
TEN FIFTY IS.
DIFFERENCE OF LESS THAN TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ANNA ABOUT A
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
BUDGET.
SO IT WAS NOT ONLY ENOUGH TO
COVER THAT THAT PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES BUT ALSO.
.
MORE IT MORE THAN COVER AND
ALLOW FOR THAT A CONTINUATION OF
A RESERVE.
MISTER I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
WRAP UP SURE I I WAS ACTUALLY
GONNA POP CULTURE AND OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT WE ALSO HAVE
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
MATTRESS OR SIZE RECYCLING
COUNCIL I BELIEVE.
.
NOW.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SIR QUESTIONS FROM THE.
OH YES UP THAT'S MODERATE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MURATSUCHI
AND MEMBERS OF J. LACK.
TOM SHE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
MATTRESS RECYCLING COUNCIL
VERBALLY PLEASED ABBOTT
OPPORTUNISTIC A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA'S INTEREST. I AM
HAVING A FEW PIECES FEW
DOCUMENTS HANDED OUT TO YOU
WHICH ADDRESS SOME OF THE
INFORMATIONAL CONCERNS OF THE
BEEN EXPRESSED.
AND I WILL JUST TELL YOU AT THE
OUTSET THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
RIGHT THAT'S BEEN QUOTED HERE
TODAY. WE DON'T BELIEVE IS
ACCURATE AND THE REASON WHY
THERE'S A LARGE RESERVE IN THE
FUND IS BECAUSE THIS IS A BRAND
NEW PROGRAM IS JUST WRAPPING UP.
WITH THAT SAID.
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MICHAEL DONALD WHO'S THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF MRC HAD A
FAMILY EMERGENCY WHICH PREVENTED
HIM FROM BEING HERE THIS MORNING
SO. I AM HERE IN HIS STEAD
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAKS THE BEGIN TALK A LITTLE
BIT WHAT WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED IN
LAST TWO YEARS.
FOLLOWING ITS FIRST YEAR OF
OPERATIONS OF ITS YOU GUYS KNOW
THE PACKETS AMONG BOTH TO THAT
AND AND FOR THE SECOND TIME.
FOLLOWING ITS FIRST YEAR OF
OPERATIONS MRC CEMENTED ITS
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND A REPORT AND
IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROPOSED
BUDGET THIS WAS IN JULY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO JUST SIX OR
SEVEN MONTHS AGO. COVER CYCLE
DID AFFECT APPROVED IT IN A
REPORT. AND IT ESTABLISHED
PERFORMANCE GOALS SPECIFIC
PERSON FOREMAN'S GOALS FOR THE
MRC IN DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FOR THE YEARS TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTIES WE HAVE
SPECIFIC GOALS OF THE REGULATORS
ASKING FOR. THIS REQUIRES A
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT RECYCLING
RATE ON A WEIGHT BASIS ON A
WEIGHT BASIS.
DURING ITS INITIAL TWO YEARS IN
OPERATION WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED THE
FOLLOWING THINGS AS THE MATTRESS
RECYCLING COUNCIL WE CONTRACTED
WITH A NUMBER MATTRESS REYCLING
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A BROAD
COLLECTION NETWORK OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DROP OFF
POINTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
WE CONTINUED AT THOSE ON A
MONTHLY BASIS.
WE'VE ALSO HELD A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE PUBLIC COLLECTION EVENTS.
OUGHT TO BRING MATTRESS
RECYCLING THE DIRECTLY INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE PEOPLE AWARE
WHAT'S GOING
.
OR PUBLIC RELATIONS AN AD
CAMPAIGN TO LET PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN DEAL
WITH THEIR VALUES MATTRESSES.
MRCS FIRST YOUR EFFORTS FOCUS ON
CREATING MATCHES COLLECTION
RECYCLING NETWORK AND WE
COLLECTED OVER ONE MILLION
MATTRESSES THOSE ARE ONE MILLION
MATTRESSES ABOUT THINGS WOULD
HAVE GONE INTO LANDFILLS.
THIS TRANSLATES INTO TWENTY NINE
MILLION TONS OF PRODUCTS
THAT OCCUPY ELEVEN MILLION CUBIC
FEET OF SPACE.
WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO NINETEEN
OLYMPIC SIZE SWIMMING POOLS. AND
MERCY IS EXPANDING ITS
COLLECTIONS IN TWENTY SEVEN
EXPAND ITS COLLECTIONS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO ONE POINT
THREE MILLION UNITS. UP THIS EX
THIS EXCEEDED PARA RECYCLES
GOALS THAT THEY SET FOR US IN
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FISCAL YEAR
SO WE BELIEVE THAT WERE NOT ONLY
GETTING THE STATE'S REQUIREMENTS
BUT WE'RE EXCEEDING THEM.
MRC ALSO RAISED A CONSUMER ARE
ALSO RAISE CONSUMER AWARENESS
RECYCLING THROUGH THEIR
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND AS A
RESULT OF THE ONE MILLION
MATTRESSES THAT WERE COLLECTED
THE FIRST YEAR. OVER THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND OF THEM
CAME THROUGH CONSUMER DROP OFFS
AT OUR DIFFERENT POINTS.
MRC HAS FUNDED THE COLLECTION OF
OVER SIXTY THREE THOUSAND
ILLEGALLY DUMPED MATTRESSES
AROUND THE STATE. THERE'S NO
QUESTION BUT THAT THERE'S MORE
WORK TO DO IN THAT AREA BUT WE
MADE A SIGNIFICANT BITE INTO IT
AND WE HAVE A STRATEGY IN PLACE
TO. CONTINUE INCREASING THAT
NUMBER RUMORED THIS IS A BRAND
NEW PROGRAM WE'RE JUST WRAPPING
UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
BRENT I'VE I'VE GOT MY FINAL
PARAGRAPH AND I APOLOGIZE I'M
WRAPPING UP RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE REQUIRED TO RECYCLE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT BY WEIGHT
OF THE MATTRESSES WE RECEIVED.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE RECYCLED
HIT A SIXTY FOUR PERCENTAGE RATE
AND UNFORTUNATELY A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT RIGHT AT DIPPED
SLIGHTLY WE ARE WORKING ON THE
STRATEGY WORKING FOR CONTRACTORS
TO RACE EVERY SO WE CAN HIT THE
ARE REQUIRED GOAL BY THE STATE.
FINALLY MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
DISCUSS MRC IS INITIAL SUCCESS
IN IMPLEMENTING THE REQUIREMENTS
OF S. B. TWO FIFTY FOUR AND
HIGHLIGHTING THE AREAS WHERE WE
DO NEED TO IMPROVE. WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF CAO
RECYCLED WE PURCHASED THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM A
MAKE IT EVEN BETTER THAN IT IS
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE NEED WE ONE MORE SENATOR.
TOM.
MISTER WHAT.
YEAH A JUST A JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
.
ACTUALLY MISTER WOULD I ANSWERED
BEFORE WE GO FORWARD.
STUDYING THAT WE HAVE. BEEN
JOINED BY OUR ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SENATE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. CALLED ROLE TO.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCI CHEAP.
HERE.
ACOSTA.
BAKER.
SANTIAGO.
RUBIO.
WOULD.
SENATOR ROTH HERE.
ALLEN.
BELL.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
LARA.
MENDOZA.
CHILDREN.
SORRY I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
NARRATOR WE HAVE QUORUM META
MADAM SECRETARY.
COR WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT MS GARCIA IF FOR.
IF I MAY GIVEN THAT THE SET THE
SENATE IS GOING TO BE GOING INTO
FLOOR SESSION AT TEN AM.  I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE SIR BUT WE'D LIKE TO
TAKE ON AIR.
SO WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED.
.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
WE'VE A. PROCEDURALLY IN ORDER
TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FIRST WE MUST.
.
SUSPENDED JAIL LIKE RULES
THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN WHICH DEAL
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S
ANALYSES TO BE RELEASED A
PUBLICLY. AND TO ALLOW THE
COMMITTEE TO WAIVE DISCUSSION
AND TAKE ACTION.
.
IS OUR FIRST A MOTION AND A
SECOND A SUSPEND BATHROOMS MODE
BUT MOTION'S BEEN MADE SECOND
SECONDED.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ROLE AS TO
THE MOTION TO SUSPEND THE RULES.
ROLL CALL TO SUSPEND COMMITTEE
RULES THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCI CHANGER.
BY.
MURATSUCHI I ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I SENT IAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OVER*.
OBERNOLTE I RUBIO.
WHEN.
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I BOW.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
LARA AYE MENDOZA.
MOTION PASSED
OKAY AND THE.
SO BUT THAT IS FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DEALING WITH THE AUDIT
REQUEST TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OH TO.
THE TULARE LOCAL HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT AS AMENDED BY CENTER
FULLER. AND I'LL AUDIT REQUEST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE OH
SIX THE PEACE OFFICERS HEALTH
AND SAFETY. AUDIT REQUEST
SUBMITTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ.
YES AND SO THAT IS THAT WITH
THE MOTION FOR THE.
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES.
NOW WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
VOTE ON THE ACTUAL MOTION TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOTIONS BEEN MAIDEN'S
SECOND ED ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCI
JEAN I.
ACOSTA.
BAKER.
SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO.
WHEN I.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN.
BELL.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
LARA.
MENDOZA.
THE MOTIONS PASSED.
HERE IN NEW.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE.
SECOND
BY.
LARA.
JUST HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
.
I HEARD FROM THAT ONE EARLY
WITNESSES THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
GET ABOUT IN THIS IS FOR US.
AS THROUGH JAIL ACT TO PERFORM
AN AUDIT BUT.
COULD CAL RECYCLE NOT PERFORM AN
AUDIT.
I MEAN IT'S A CAL RECYCLE
PROGRAM.
COULD YOU NOT PERFORM AN AUDIT
OF THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM
WITHIN EUROPE WE AREN'T
DEPARTMENT. YES THE DEPARTMENT
HAS A WATER THIRTY TO AUDIT THE
THE MATTRESS RECYCLING COUNCILS
PROGRAM AND.
ACTUALLY INTENDS TO AS PART OF
ITS REGULAR DUTIES.
OKAY.
.
AS FAR AS THE.
THE ISSUE OF DUMPING OBVIOUS
IT'S A HUGE CONCERN.
.
I BIGGER OF A BIG CONCERN FOR ME
AS I AND I KINDA LIKE TED THAT
KNOW MORE ABOUT HOW THE NUMBERS
STACK UP IN MY DISTRICT WHERE I
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE COUNTIES THAT
DON'T HAVE. ANY RECYCLING
CENTERS NOW.
WHICH IS A A MUCH MUCH BIGGER
ISSUE OF FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
BUT.
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE SAM AND
I AND NUMBER ALLUVIAL QUESTIONS
AND DATA ON WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND DISTRICTS THAT DON'T HAVE.
ANY RECYCLING FACILITIES BECAUSE
I THINK THAT CONTINUES TO BE A
HUGE ISSUE.
ILLEGAL DUMPING IS ONE OF THE
THE MAIN.
PURPOSES OF THE PROGRAM IS TO
IS TO ADDRESS ILLEGAL DUMPING
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE FLAT.
AS A A A PRIORITY AS WELL.
THE THE NATURE OF.
THIS PROGRAM WHICH FOLLOWS SOME
EXTENDED PRODUCE RESPONSIBILITY
PRINCIPLES IS. THAT STATUTE LAYS
OUT.
PACIFIC REQUIREMENTS AND THEN
THE.
STORAGE ORGANIZATION HAS SOME
FLEXIBILITY. WITH WHICH HOW THEY
GO ABOUT MEETING THOSE GOALS.
SO WITH THAT I DEPARTMENT IN
ITS.
APPROVAL OF THE FIRST DOWN
REPORT HIGHLIGHTED SOME AREAS
WHERE WE THOUGHT THAT. UP SOME
ADDITIONAL UP WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND I THINK THAT MRC
RECOGNIZES THAT IT AS WELL.
DATA IS.
IS SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S VERY
CHALLENGING TO OBTAIN TO TRY AND
FIGURE OUT WHERE OUR.
THAT THE AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
NEED THE MOST EMPHASIS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THE MRC.
.
TRIED TO DO DURING THE FIRST
PROGRAM YEAR AND WE THINK THAT
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE TO
TRY AND IDENTIFY.
THAT THAT DATA SO THAT
RESOURCES CAN BE TARGETED TO THE
PLACES THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
I DON'T KNOW IF ON.
MRC IS ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD WITH
REGARD TO THAT. MAY I MISTER
CHAIRMAN. BOB THANK YOU MISTER
WHAT UP ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HAVE HANDED OUT TO THE MEMBERS
ON THE DAIS WHEN I START TO MAKE
MY COMMENTS WAS OUR AND A REPORT
WHICH WAS JUST PUBLISHED IN
JULY.
INSIDE THAT ANNUAL REPORT WHICH
YOU CAN SEE ON YEAR ROUND IS
THIS PARTICULAR DOCUMENT. WHICH
IS A AUDIT THAT WAS DONE BY TOP
SHELF INDEPENDENT AUDITING
COMPANY THAT LOOKED AT MANY OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT MISS GARCIA
HAS IN HER COMMITTEE REQUEST
LETTER ON EXPENDITURES AND
REVENUES NOW THE MONEY IS BEING
SPENT. WHAT THE RESERVISTS ON
AND SO FORTH THOSE ARE ALL JUST
WENT THROUGH A THOROUGH REGULAR
ARE RIGOROUS? AUDIT JUST SIX US
SEVEN MONTHS AGO THAT'S IN PART
OF THIS DOCUMENT HERE THAT I
PROVIDED YOU.
IS FAR AS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IN THE FUTURE OUR BUDGET WAS
JUST APPROVED BY COUNTY CYCLE
THEY CERTIFY THAT WE'RE MEETING
ALL THE STATE REQUIREMENTS. WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND ANY
MEMBER ARE IN ANY MEMBER IN THE
LEGISLATURE ANY MEMBER IN THIS
COMMITTEE AS FAR AS. A DEALING
WITH THE MATTRESS WHITE ISSUE
TRYING TO COME UP WITH NEW
STRATEGIES AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH. BUT IT'S FAR AS THE
INFORMATION IS GARCIA'S WORKING
FOR I WOULD I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THAT. MUCH A
BET ALMOST ALL OF IT COULD BE
PROVIDED UNDER SEPARATE COVER.
UP YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
PUTTING THE SOBRE FOR THIRTY
DAYS WE MIGHT HAVE A CHANCE TO
WORK WITH MISS GARCIA. ARE AND
IF SHE STILL NOT SATISFIED YOU
CAN COME BACK OF A FOR THE AUDIT
BUT THE INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED ON. ARE THE FINANCES
ON THE PROGRAM PERFORMANCES
EITHER AVAILABLE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT UNDER CURRENTLY
PUBLISHED DOCUMENTS. OR ALSO
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE MATTRESS
RECYCLING COUNCIL IT'S IT'S BEEN
LOOKED OUT THOROUGHLY THIS IS A
BRAND NEW PROGRAM IT'S ONLY BEEN
RUNNING FOR TWO YEARS IS OUR
FIRST AND A REPORT.
VERY TRANSPARENT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HOW WE'RE DOING IT WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE HOWEVER YOU LIKE BUT
SKIPPED STATE RESOURCES ARE
SCARCE THE AUDITOR CAN'T AUDIT
EVERYTHING A MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEING ASKED
FOR HERE. IS ALREADY PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
CAN I RESPOND YES MS GRANT.
A COUPLE OF THINGS ON THIS AUDIT
THAT THE MRC IS TALKING ABOUT
ARE THE AUDIT DOES NOTE THAT IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE A LEGAL
DETERMINATION OF MRCS
COMPLIANCE.
WITH SPECIFIED REQUIREMENTS OF
THE ACT
THE STATE THAT THIRTY TO
TERMINATE THE MRC SEASON THE
FEES COLLECTED FROM CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. TO FULLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AND I ON AND PERFECT
EFFECTIVELY A COMPLY WITH ALL
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE MATCHES
EXACTLY LA NOT SIMPLY WHETHER
THERE ARE COUNTING IS ACCURATE.
I A SHORT DECIDED AS NECESSARY
ALSO THE AUDITOR WILL BE ABLE TO
COME.
.
YOU A BROADER AND GREATER AND
THAT AUDIT AND CAL RECYCLE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO DO YOU. ARE AND THEN
I WHICH IS ALSO LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION
TO VOTE ON THIS AUDIT A SECOND
AND NOT WITH WHAT EFFORT DID.
NOT TO BOTH ONE EVERY THIRTY
DAYS FOR YOUR REQUEST THE MOTION
ON THE FLOOR ENOUGH WITH. WITH
FORWARD MISTER AL.
OKAY I'VE COUPLE QUESTIONS FROM.
FOR CAL RECYCLED.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF.
AND I'M SURE THIS IS IN ERE
SOMEWHERE BUT HOW MANY USED
MATTRESSES ARE GENERATED
STATEWIDE.
SO THE. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT ALSO DIES
AND ITS EYES SIGNIFICANT EFFORT
IS.
IS RECEIVE COLLECT.
AND.
ANALYZE DATA FROM.
.
MATTRESS RECYCLERS RENOVATORS
AND SOLID WASTE FACILITIES THAT
COLLECTS USED MATTRESSES FROM
THE PUBLIC AND.
IT WE JUST BECAUSE OUT ARE THE
FIRST REPORTING YOUR FOR THAT
AND IT THEIR SIGNIFICANCE OF
THAT ISN'T SETTING. THAT
STATEWIDE BASELINE AND RECYCLING
GOALS FOR THE STATE I'M WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT DID PER STATUTE.
DOT AND BECAME EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR THAT MRC WILL
HAVE TO.
.
DEMONSTRATE A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
TOWARDS MEETING THOSE GOALS FROM
ITS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AND REPORT WHICH DEPARTMENT
RECEIVING TWENTY TWENTY. SO THE
REASON I BRING THIS UP IS
BECAUSE.
IT WAS THE FIRST REPORTING
YOU'RE NOT ONLY FOR THE MRC BUT
ALSO FOR THESE REPORTING
ENTITIES.
AND THE.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT WAS CHALLENGING
IN SOME RESPECTS.
GETTING ALL OF THE ENTITIES
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT TO
ACTUALLY DO SO AND TO TO.
SUBMIT SUFFICIENT AND COMPLETE
DATA. SO THAT APARTMENT.
HAS BEEN TO DOING A LOT OF
EFFORT.
TO TRY AND REACH OUT TO THOSE
RECYCLERS.
AND RENOVATORS TO TRY AND GET
ACCURATE AND COMPLETE DATA.
SO THE. SO THE.
WE BELIEVE BECAUSE THIS SO I.
THIS FORM THAT WAS THE SAID WHEN
PAGES GIVEN US BY THE MRC THEN
SAYS THAT IT'S.
ONE POINT TWO ONE POINT THREE
MILLION IS THAT.
CONFORM WITH YOUR UNDERSTANDING.
AS FAR AS GENERATED.
GENERATING YEAH THAT'S THAT
COLLECTED COLLECTED GUESTS YES
OKAY AYE MEN AND IT.
YOUR YOUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
OUR RECYCLING MATTRESS LIKING
RATE IS A LITTLE IS AROUND.
STEVE.
THE PERCENT IS THAT SEMI THAT
EVERY NOW NOW OKAY NO. THE.
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
REPORTING THAT I JUST DESCRIBED.
.
WELL HELP US TO ESTABLISH A.
BOB WITH TWENTY TWENTY A
DEPARTMENT WAS REQUIRED PER
STATUTE TO SET THE BASELINE AND
RECYCLING GOALS BY A JERRY ONE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE DATA THAT WAS NECESSARY
WHICH DIDN'T HAVE THE DATA
KNOWING WHAT IS.
CURRENTLY BEING RECYCLED AND
RENOVATED.
TO SET A RECYCLING RATE THAT IS
BASED ON ABOUT GENERATED. SO
INSTEAD WE.
WE SET GOALS THAT ARE BASICALLY
YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASES.
.
AND IN THE MEANTIME ARE TAKING
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS TO INCREASE
THAT THE DATA QUALITY SO THAT WE
CAN SET AN ACTUAL RECYCLING RATE
WHICH IS BASED ON. WHAT IS
ACTUALLY COLLECTED?
OVER DIVIDED BY WHAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR RECYCLING CONSUMED
EVERYWHERE WE LOOKING AT JUST
ONE MCADAMS ITEMS ARE THE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA
RECYCLING RATES YEAH IT'S ONLY
SOME LOOKING AT THE THING TRY TO
DO EXACTLY YEAH SO I'M. I'M
STRUCK GOOD HEARING TWENTY FIVE
AND SIXTY AYE AYE THIS IF
REMEMBER IS OF THE ONE POINT TWO
THAT ARE COLLECTED.
THIS IS HOW MUCH OF THAT
MATERIAL IS RECYCLED SO VIBRATES
SO I UNDERSTATEMENT PERCENT UP A
MATTRESS IS RECYCLED THE OTHER
FORTY BECMES WASTE BUT OF ALL
THE MATTRESSES THAT ARE.
THAT LEAVES SOMEONE'S HOUSE.
INTO THE YOU DON'T HAVE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IS IS THE WHOLE
WE ONLY KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
COLLECTED WHICH IS ONE POINT TWO
BUT THERE MIGHT BE ANOTHER
THIRTY FOUR. OR ONE MILLION OUR
BEST GUESS ESTIMATE AS TO WHAT.
NOT NOT YEAH BUT WE WANT TO GET
TO THAT OKAY LEVEL FOR TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN ARM.
HAVE YOU KNOW SO I'M AND HEARING
GOOD I KNOW THIS IS THIS IS.
TYPICAL RIGHT IN THE AUTHOR
WANTS TO MOVE FORWARD IN THE
FOLKS HERE. INFINIBAND ON THE
OTHER SIDE SAY LET'S LET'S LET'S
MEANS MORE TIME TALKING ABOUT IT
I'M CAN I GET A SENSE OF. THE
EXTENT TO WHICH YOU AS A WORKING
TOGETHER AND TALKING TO EACH
OTHER.
.
BUT MAY I MISTER CHAIRMAN YEAH
SENATOR ALLEN WE WE.
WE MET WITH MISS GARCIA STAFF
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON THERE FLOOR
SESSION RENTAL LATE. WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO WORK WITH HER AND
HER STAFF AS WELL AS OTHER STEP
IN THIS COMMITTEE ON ANY THE
ISSUES RAISED IF UP IF YOU GO
FORWARD WITH THE AUDIT A COURSE
WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
AUDITORS WELL. YOU HAVE A MAP
BEFORE YESTERDAY WE WE JUST
WE'VE REACHED OUT AND WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION SINCE
DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH.
ON VARIOUS ITEMS AND I AM FROM A
ARE AS WE SAID AT THE BEGINNING
THE. INITIAL REQUEST CAME
BECAUSE OF A COMPANY AND MY
DISTRICT BUT AS AS
I SAY TO ASK MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT RECYCLING OF THE TERM
NATURAL RESOURCES AND SO FORTH.
I SUDDENLY WAS DISMAYED ENTERS
THE SPEAK ABOUT HOW THIS PROGRAM
IS RUNNING AND HOW EFFECTIVELY
GETS.
IT'S FUNNY I AND THE LACK OF
INFORMATION AT TIMES AND THERE'S
INFORMATION ON TWO DIFFERENT
WEBSITES AND SOME OF IT IS
DUPLICATIVE SOME OF IT'S NOT.
FAMILIAR WILL TELL ME AND I'LL
SEND ME BACK TO COPY CYCLE AND
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING RESEARCH
TRYING TO GET ANSWERS AND IT'S
EVEN WHAT'S AVAILABLE IT'S NOT
ALWAYS CLEAR AND I CAN'T GET ALL
MY ANSWERS AND SO. UP WHILE I
WAS IN PERSON ABLE TO MEET WITH
THAT MARCY S. TODAY BECAUSE I
WAS ON THE FLOOR WE HAVE BEEN
ASKING QUESTIONS FOR AWHILE NOW.
SENATOR ALLEN IF I MAY MY CLIENT
THE MRC RECEIVED A LETTER THE
FIRST COMMUNICATION THEY'VE
RECEIVED FROM. MISS GARCIA IN
LATE DECEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THEY DID SEND A
RESPONSE TO THAT LETTER IN EARLY
JANUARY AND THEN THE NEXT THING
WE HEARD WE WERE BEING CALLED IN
FOR AN AUDIT SO WHAT WE ARE WE
ARE. WE WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
TO APPEAR AS THOUGH WE'RE NOT.
WORKING WITH MS GARCIA'S OFFICE
OUR RESPONSE TO THE LETTER SHE
SENT. UP. BY BY BELIEVE COULD
HAVE BEEN DONE BETTER.
PROBABLY WASN'T AS GOOD OF A
RESPONSE SHE WAS LOOKING FOR SO
WE ARE SORRY FOR THAT MISS
GARCIA OKAY MISTER AS SHE LET ME
STEP IN HERE AND WE'RE NOT HERE
TO.
REALLY.
.
YOU KNOW ARGUE ABOUT.
YOU KNOW.
WHOSE VERSION OF.
WELL I AND I'M LIKE YES I AGREE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I IT'S
MEANINGFUL TO ME THEY YOU KNOW.
IF WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE
STAGE OF LIKE SPENDING ALL THE
MONEY ASSOCIATE WITH OR NOT IT.
I THAT THERE BE AT LEAST SOME
MEANINGFUL DIALOGUE BETWEEN.
BOTH SIDES BEFORE WE PROCEED TO
MOVE FORWARD NOW YOU KNOW MIGHT
TENDENCIES TO DEFER TO YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
HAVING HAD AN OPPORTUNITY LOOK
AT WHAT'S HAPPENED AND IF YOU'VE
STILL BELIEVE. THIS IS
WORTHWHILE MOVING FORWARD BUT AT
THE SAME TIME.
IF THEY'RE LITERALLY JUST
BEGINNING PRELIMINARY
CONVERSATIONS.
IT DOES IT WOULD IT WOULD.
I'M JUST I HAVE A QUESTION IN MY
MIND AS TO WHETHER AND.
I AND AND I WOULD IT HAS THAT
ANSWERED IT EXCUSE ME I HAS BEEN
ANSWERED YET.
I MEAN I I THINK YOU'RE HERE
HEARING DATES IN TERMS OF.
TEMPS. IT DOES SOUND LIKE IT IT
STARTED IN DECEMBER BETTA.
.
AND IF YOU IF IF WELL A IF A
LAWYER IF WE'VE MET THAT BURDEN
TO YOUR SATISFACTION IS THE
CHAIR I WILL SUPPORT YOU OKAY.
.
YEAH I KNOW WHAT I MEAN TO CUT
OFF I I JUST WANTED TO. AVOID A
BACK AND FORTH THAT.
GOING HERE BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS AS TO. A URGING
THE THE REQUEST YOUR.
.
YOU KNOW TO TO.
SEEK ADDITIONAL.
INFORMATION THROUGH INFORMAL
MEANS THAT YOU'RE CERTAINLY
WELCOME THESE.
YEAH I'VE MADE MY GENERAL
TENDENCIES TO.
YOU KNOW WAS TOO SO YOU KNOW AND
I HAD A I HAD A QUESTION ONE
POINT HEADLONG COMES IS WITH
WITH THAT CENTER ROTH. AND WE
WERE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THAT
THE ISSUE THAT WE HAD WITH. THE
WAY THE PROCESS OF WORKING
THROUGH WITH THAT WITH THE
AGENCY THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO AYE
THAT'S I JUST THINK IN GENERAL.
IT'S BEST PRACTICE FOR US TO TRY
TO WORK THESE THINGS OUT BEFORE
HAND TIGHTLY.
I DON'T COME HERE.
.
I I I UNDERSTAND THAT WE COULD
OUT OF THE MILLION THINGS AYE
ANY GIVEN YEAR AND WE WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF OUR RESOURCES. ON
INSIDE THAT SET OFF BY TRYING TO
DO HOMEWORK I THINK GIVING HER
FROM CUT CYCLE AT SOME OF THE
THING QUESTIONS I HAVE. THEY
HAVE
A ABOUT HOW THEY'RE RUNNING THE
PROGRAM AND SO WE HIT WALTZ WE
GOT SOME ANSWERS AT THE IN THING
ADEQUATE ALONG THE WAY. AYE AND
SUCH A PROGRAM THAT I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE IS WORKING PROPERLY
AT ONE OF OUR FIRST. OUT THERE
TO BECOMES A ROLE MODEL FOR FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL LONG THE
WAYNE SO.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PAINFUL
BUT I DO THINK WE'VE DONE ENOUGH
OF
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION AT
SOME POINT ACCOUNT FOR SOMEONE.
TO GIVE ME UP INFORMATION IF AN
AUDIT SUBTLY THAT WANT TO COME
TO THE TABLE I HAVE TO ALSO
QUESTIONED SOME OF THEIR. A
GENUINE THEY ARE IF THEY FINALLY
NOW. MARKETS WE WE HAVE MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS TRYING TO GET
ANSWERS ACTUALLY WITHIN JUST
MYSELF.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
YES MEDICAL. YEAH I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND I SOME OF
MY SENTIMENT THAT ECHOES.
SENATOR ALLEN'S IN TERMS OF
JUST TIMING IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A
BOZOS QUESTION FOR THE ARE OF
THE REQUESTER. I WITH ALL
RESPECT TO MATURE NATURIST
SOURCES BUT. IT SEEMS LIKE A OF
A BRAND NEW PROGRAM IN TWO YEARS
IS FAIRLY NEW WORKED SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE GETTING THINGS OFF THE
GROUND.
I'M I'M ALL FOR AUDITS ON DISK
WANDERING ABOUT THAT THE TIMING
AND THEN I DO HAVE A A BRIEF
QUESTION FOR THE.
FOR THE FOLKS AT THE MERCY
AS WELL SKINNY TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT THE TIMING.
.
SOME NUMBER GARCIA JUST IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT.
GIVEN THE CENTER ALAN'S YOU KNOW
QUESTION I IN TERMS OF.
YOU KNOW TIMING AYE AYE HERE
DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH AND.
GET OUT THIS BUILDING IS.
YOU KNOW HALF MORE THAN HALF
VACANT DOT IT IT SEEMS LIKE TO
ME THEN YOU RUN THE HOLIDAYS AND
THEN YOU GET BACK AND YOU'VE
GOT.
YOU KNOW.
AUDIT REQUESTS IN SESSION AND
AND AND COMMITTEE STARTING TO
RAMP UP AND IT SEEMS LIKE. IT IT
IT JUST MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT OF
AN AWKWARD TIMING ISSUE.
MORE THAN THAN THAN ANYTHING I
I'M NOT A YOU KNOW CERTAINLYNOT
EXCUSING SOMEONE NOT RESPONDING
RESPONDING INAPPROPRIATE MATTER.
AND I.
ALL RESPECT I I KNOW YOU TAKE
THESE THINGS VERY SERIOUSLY IT
AS WE ALL DO BUT I JUST.
ONE OF AT DISCOUNT CLARIFY THAT
ONE QUERY THERE AND THEN I HAVE
QUESTION FROM OUR SIDE SO WHILE
A LOT OF US ARE HERE.
DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH THROUGH
DECEMBER STAFF MEMBERS SUCH THAT
THIS YEAR COMMITTEES THAT THIS
YEAR LOST A COUNTY CYCLE IS
STILL UP AND RUNNING. ADVOCATES
ARE STILL OUT THERE WORKING MRC
THE FILM WORK ON OUR TIMELINE
AGAIN THEIR INDUSTRY INDIVIDUALS
THAT THEIR BUSINESS RUNS ALL
YEAR LONG AND THEY'RE BASED OUT
OF STATE. SO DEFTLY DOT RUN ON
OUR TIMELINE OF THE LEGISLATURE
HERE AND SO WORK I HAS BEEN
DONE.
AND SO I THINK IT'S NOT
RELEVANT PRESS THAT ALWAYS HAD
TO BE HERE WE'VE WE WILL HAVE
ASKED. A LOT WE HAVE FIVE OTHER
STATE QUALIFY TO GET INFORMATION
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE YELLING IN THIS WASTE
OF ARENA ALSO HAVE TO THINK IN
TERMS AND SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH INCLUDING BACK
AND FORTH. AMONG STAFF BY
VARIOUS LEVELS TO TRY TO GET
INFORMATION AND IT WASN'T UNTIL
THIS POINT THAT THEY SAID HEY
LET ME ANSWER ALL YOUR QUESTIONS
NOW CONVENIENTLY. NOT AND AND
BEFORE IT WAS LET ME DIRECTLY TO
THESE DIFFERENT WEBSITE INTO
COUNTY CYCLE AND WE FOLLOWED THE
SATISFACTION AS FAR AS THAT'S
CONCERNED SO I APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW YOUR DILIGENCE IN THE
MATTER. AND I'M PERFECTLY AWARE
THAT STAFF IS IS WORKING ITS
OUTRIGHT JUST MAKING A POINT
THAT. YOU KNOW IS A LITTLE BIT
YOU KNOW EVERYONE AROUND THE
COUNTRY TAKE SOME TIME OFF
AROUND THE HOLIDAYS IT SEEMS
LIKE BUT BUT YOU ANSWERED THE
QUESTION MY SATISFACTION FOR THE
MERCY. YA I NOTICED ON THIS
AUGUST THIS HANDOUT.
.
THAT YOU HAVE.
THE LAST.
CENTS OR SO IN THE FIRST
PARAGRAPH UPPER LEFT HAND CORNER
IT SAYS.
OF THE FEE ALSO FUNDS AN
INCENTIVE THAT ENCOURAGES
CONSUMERS TO DROP OFF THEIR OLD
MATTRESSES AT A RECYCLER
ETCETERA.
TO HELP IN COMBAT DUMPED
MATCHES CAN YOU CAN YOU EXPAND
ON THAT A LITTLE BIT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE INCENTIVE WHERE DID
THEY GO HOW THEY DO IT. BECAUSE
I DO NOTICE THAT WE DON'T SEE.
A WHOLE LOT OF OF OUR CANS AND
BOTTLES AROUND.
THEY SEEM TO GET YOU KNOW
PICKED UP THE SOMEWHAT OF A
COTTAGE INDUSTRY UNFORTUNATE BY
THE SOME SSID FOR SOME FOLKS.
BUT JUST WONDERING.
HOW DOES THIS FIT IN AND WHAT'S
BEING DONE IN?
CAN I TAKE WHILE MATTRESS IN AND
YOU KNOW GET MY TWENTY BUCKS OR
MY TEN BUCKS BACK OR WHATEVER HE
OF ELEVEN DOLLARS BACK I THINK
YOU UP.
MR ACOSTA.
.
YES SIMILAR TO THE CALIFORNIA
REDEMPTION VALUE WHERE WHEN YOU.
RETURN OF PLAN OF CLASS AND.
ALUMINUM CANS AND BOTTLESAS A
REDEMPTION FEE. THERE'S ALSO
REDEMPTION FEE OF CA CONSUMER
TAKES A MATTRESS TO ONE OF THE
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY DROP OFF SITES
THAT YOU DO GET A REDEMPTION
FEE.
I APOLOGIZE MISTER ACOSTA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I DON'T
KNOW. AND MAYBE THE DEPARTMENT
KNOWS I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ACTUAL RATE IS TODAY IF IT'S TWO
OR THREE DOLLARS.
FOUR DOLLARS IT'S THE DEPARTMENT
IS TELLING ME THAT IT'S THREE
DOLLARS.
SO THAT THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS WHEN THE CONSUMER
TAKES A MATTRESS AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY A THREE DOLLAR REBATE
THAT THEY GET.
THAT'S A MATTER FOR THEM TO DO
THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU AWFULLY LA
AWFULLY LARGE ITEM FOR FOR THREE
DOLLARS BUT THE AYE AYE AYE HE.
I THINK YOU KNOW
I'M NOT GOING TO COLLECT THE
MONEY.
I COLLECT THEM FOR OTHER REASONS
BEEN UP FOR THE THREE DOLLARS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR RESPONSE.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NOT ARE THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THIS THE.
AUDIT REQUESTS.
SEEING NO ONE RUSSIAN FORWARD
THIS REQUEST I I AGREE WITH THE
SENATOR ALLEN AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COSTA THAT YOU
KNOW THE IDEAL SITUATION WE LIKE
TO.
SEE EVERYONE.
IN THE.
BUILDING TO. TRY TO SEEK
INFORMATION THROUGH INFORMAL
MEANS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IT
SOUNDS LIKE. THERE IS SOME
FRUSTRATION ENCOUNTERED BY MS
GARCIA AND HER STAFF IN TERMS OF
GETTING. OF HER INFORMATION.
AND THERE'S A QUESTION AT LEAST
AS TO.
HOW COOPERATIVE MRC WAS AND
TELL THERE ARE FACED WITH THE
PROSPECT OF THE AUDIT BUT I
THINK?
UP FOR FIRST AND FOREMOST SAID
THE REASON WHY I RECOMMEND THIS
AUDIT IS BECAUSE.
INODE AND THIS IS A.
GOT A NEW PROGRAM WHERE WE'RE
DEALING WITH A PRIVATE ENTITY
THAT IS COLLECTING GO OUT FUNDS
ON BEHALF. OF.
OF THEIR OWN THAT THAT THE
STATE MANDATE.
PASSED THROUGH LEGISLATION FOR
THIS MATTRESS RECYCLING PROGRAM
AND I THINK THERE IS VALUE TO
HAVE.
THE INDEPENDENT STATE AUDITOR
TO GIVE A AN OFFICIAL SUSPECT AS
TO.
THE.
STATUS OF OF THE PROGRAM US SO
THAT WE CAN.
EXCISE ARE PROPER OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY.
AND SO WITH THAT I RECOMMEND
AND AYE VOTE FOR THE REQUEST.
.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ONE OF SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MERCI CHAU.
MERCI CHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I RUBIO.
RUBIO I WEIGHED.
WOULD I.
SENATOR ROBB.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I SPELL.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
LARA I.
THE MOTION PASSES.
IF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
SENATOR IS YOU'RE GOING TO BE
STARTING A FLOOR SESSION AT.
SHORTLY.
OKAY.
.
BUT YEAH.
YOUR VICE CHAIR IS AN INDICATOR
THAT THE YOUR PREFERENCE IS. FOR
THE COMMITTED TO KEEP ROLLING
BOARD AND SO.
I WILL RESPECT THAT.
SO ON NEXT IN LINE IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AS THE SOMEONE
WERE LIVING STILL HERE.
I. MISTER LIVING HAVE SIGNED IN
BEFORE MISSED LACKEY BUT GIVEN
THAT HE IS NOT HERE.
WE WILL PROCEED WITH MR LACK.
A LOT.
WELL.
TURNING EQUIPMENT LEFT.
ALRIGHT WELCOME ASSURE LACKEY
THIS IS.
ON THE REGULAR CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER THREE.
I REQUEST TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH
ONE OH FIVE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
CRIME REPORTING STATISTICS
REQUEST SUBMITTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY.
WELCOME SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
PRESENT MY PROPOSED AUDIT FOR
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT CRIME REPORTING
STATISTICS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS AUDIT WOULD
REVIEW AND ASSESS
A SAMPLE OF VIOLENT CRIME
REPORTS.
STORED IN THE LAPD DATABASE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF IDENTIFYING
CASES.
BUT A BEEN MISCLASSIFIED AS LESS
SERIOUS OFFENSES OR HAVE BEEN
UNDER COUNTED.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN LA.
CHIEF.
CHARLIE BACK PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE PROBLEMS WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS PROCESS.
FOR RECORDING CRIMES AND
LAUNCHED A SERIES OF.
CHANGED.
I'M SORRY CHANGES AIMED AT.
IMPROVING INTERNAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRAINING
OFFICERS.
AND THE TRAINING OPTIONS RECEIVE
ON HOW TO CLASSIFY CRIMES.
FOLLOWING THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
INVESTIGATION A TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN NOT A BY THE OFFICE.
BUT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND
THAT'S A QUOTE UNQUOTE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER.
OF CRIMES WERE CATEGORIZED A
SIMPLE ASSAULT FROM TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
AND THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED AS PART OF
THE VIOLENT CRIME STATISTICS
THAT ARE SUBMITTED TO THE FBI
AND DISCLOSE TO THE PUBLIC.
AT THE CRIMES HAVE BEEN
CLASSIFIED CORRECTLY DURING
THOSE SEVEN YEARS THE RATE OF
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS WOULD HAVE
BEEN AN AVERAGE OF THIRTY SIX
PERCENT HIGHER EACH YEAR.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AN ADDITIONAL CLAIM OF
ERRORS IN THE LAPD'S CRIME
STATISTICS WAS REPORTED IN BOTH
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES AND THE
DAILY NEWS.
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
PROTECTIVELY EVEN RELEASED A
STATEMENT ARGUING THAT THESE
ALLEGATIONS SHOULD BE TAKING.
TAKEN I'M SORRY VERY SERIOUSLY.
LOS ANGELES IS THE MOST POPULOUS
CITY IN THE STATE.
ANY ERRORS MADE AND THE
REPORTING CRIME STATISTICS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT THE STATE'S
CRIME CALIFORNIA REPORT.
AND THEREFORE IS NOT JUST A
LOCAL PROBLEM.
THE CITIZENS OF LOS ANGELES IN
THE REST OF THE STATE NEED TO
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE ACCURACY
OF REPORTED CRIME DATA.
WITH THE RECENT PASSAGE OF
REALIGNMENT AND VOTER APPROVAL
OF PROP 47-57 THE PUBLIC
DESERVES AN ACCURATE PORTRAYAL
OF THE RESULTS WE'RE
EXPERIENCING WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IF YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH MUCH LACKEY.
.
MICHELLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY INDICATED
THIS WOULD BE AN AUDIT OF LA UP
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND LOOKING AT
THEIR CRIME REPORTING. STARTING
WITH LOOKING AT POLICIES
PROCEDURES WHAT TYPE OF
STANDARDS HAVE THEY ESTABLISHED
WHAT TYPE OF TRAINING DO THEY
PROVIDE NOT ONLY FOR THEIR
OFFICERS FOR INDIVIDUAL OR FOR
INDIVIDUALS. ARE IN PUTTING THE
INFORMATION INTO THE DATABASE
HE'S ASKED US TO LOOK AT A
SAMPLE OR A SELECTION OF.
OFFICER REPORTS AND DETERMINING
ESSENTIALLY THE ACCURACY OF THE
ANNUAL REPORTING OF THAT'S
OCCURRING IDENTIFYING ANY
SIGNIFICANT VARIANCE IS OP
PERHAPS BY TYPE OF CRIME HE'S
ASKING US TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE ARE CERTAIN CRIMES. THAT
MAY HAVE A HIGHER. INCIDENCE OF
BEING MIS REPORTED ARE UNDER
REPORTED A PARTICULARLY AS HE
INDICATED I LOOKED AT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT FOR
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I
LOOKED AT SOME OTHER
INFORMATION.
AND IT YEAH MUCH OF THE UNDER
REPORTING THAT HAS. BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS RELATED TO ASSAULT
WHETHER IT'S A SIMPLE ASSAULT
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS WE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OUR CRIMES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER CERTAIN CRIMES
THAT ARE. UNDER REPORTED MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN OTHERS OUT ONE
BIG OBJECTIVE HE'S ASKING US TO
ACCOMPLISH IS LOOKING AT A
SELECTION OF CRIMES BUT OVER A
TEN YEAR WINDOW. OUGHT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY CRIMES
WERE MISCLASSIFIED AGAIN HAS
THERE BEEN AN INCREASE HAS THERE
BEEN A DECREASE AGAIN WHAT TYPES
OF CRIMES ARE BEING MISREPORTED.
AND THEN FINALLY LOOKING UP THE
STEPS THAT THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
HAS TAKEN TO TRY TO MITIGATE OR
MINIMIZE THE NUMBER OF CRIMES
THAT ARE. MISCLASSIFIED OR MIS
REPORTED UP AGAIN LOOKING AT
SOME THE BACKGROUND INFORMATION
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS ESTABLISHED A
DATA INTEGRITY UNIT WE CERTAINLY
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT UNIT
DOES. ARE AND HOW THEY CAPTURE
THE INFORMATION IF NECESSARY
WOULD USE OUR IT FOLKS TO ASSIST
WITH THAT. THIS AUDIT THE BUDGET
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED HOURS THE
REASON EVEN THOUGH IT'S ONLY ONE
ENTITY WERE VISITING. HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK AT
POLICIES PROCEDURES BUT LOOKING
AT A TEN YEAR WINDOW AND MAKING
SURE WE TAKE? A SIGNIFICANT OUR
SAMPLE SIZE TO BE ABLE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND UP THE TRENDS OVER
THAT TEN YEAR WINDOW WHETHER OR
NOT CRIMES HAVE BEEN MISSED
PORTED WHAT TYPES OF CRIMES IT
CETERA. AN AUDIT OF THAT SIZE
WILL TAKE US ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS
TO COMPLETE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
LACKEY DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
SO DO TO TEST FUND SUPPORT OF
YOUR REQUEST I DO NOT
MORE.
GOOD MORNING. FORTY MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS R. F. ALI
KHAN I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING POLICY
FOR THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SEATED WITH ME IS
COMMANDER JEFFREY BURKE WHO THE
COMMANDING OFFICER OF RISK
MANAGEMENT LEGAL AFFAIRS GROUP.
ON BEHALF WHICH
CHARLIE BACK IN THE AND MEHRGARH
CITY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
RESPOND TO THE REQUEST FOR AN
AUDIT THAT WAS. THAT THERE WAS
SENT TO US LAST WEEK ODD.
ONE OF MY RESPONSIBILITIES AS
THE DIRECTOR CONSTITUTIONAL
POLICING POLICY IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE. OF REFORMS THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED DURING OUR CONSENT
DECREE WHICH INCLUDE COMPLIANCE
AND INTERNAL ADITING AND ALSO
COORDINATING EXTERNAL AUDITS IN
REVIEWS ARE FULLY COMPLIED WITH.
BASED ON THE REQUEST THAT WE'VE
SEEN.
AND.
OUR UNIQUE ROLE AND A IN AMONG
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHEN IT
COMES TO YOU SEE ARE REPORTING.
A IT'S THE CHIEF IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S POSITION AND THE
MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES POSITION TO
OPPOSE THE AUDIT REQUEST.
I AS I MENTIONED WE HAVE A
UNIQUE ROLE IN LEADERSHIP WHICH
IS ALSO BEEN RECOGNISED BY THE
FBI IN THE LETTER THAT I THINK
WAS REACHED JUST CIRCULATED TO
YOU. ARE ON OUR.
CLASSIFICATION OF USE YOUR
CRIME REPORTS OUR DATA
TRANSPARENCY IN THE ROBUST
SYSTEMS FOR ACCURATELY
CLASSIFYING OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CRIME REPORTS A YEAR. A
IS SECOND TO NONE AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN DEALING WITH THE COMPLEX AN
OUTDATED SYSTEM SUCH AS THE FBI
UNIFORM CRIME REPORTS IT WAS
INDICATED THAT THE AUDITOR WOULD
LOOK OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD.
THAT WOULD CONSIST OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE MILLION OF
REPORTABLE CRIMES.
ENDED IN ADDITION IT WOULD BE
HALF A MILLION AGGRAVATED
ASSAULTS ALONE OBVIOUSLY THAT
WOULD BE A SAMPLING OF THOSE BUT
IN ORDER TO HAVE. A RANDOMIZED
STRATIFIED SAMPLING AND ALSO THE
EXPERTISE TO REVIEW THAT WOULD
TAKE A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME.
I UNDERSTAND THIS AUDIT REQUEST
WAS PROMPTED BY A NOVEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN DAILY TIMES
ARTICLE REGARDING THE LAWSUIT
FILED BY DIVISION COMMANDER. AND
REFERENCING A TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN STORY ABOUT A REVIEW OF
LAPD DATA AND REPORTS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE LA TIMES OUT
THROUGH PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST. AND SEVERAL MEETINGS
THAT I PARTICIPATED IN IN THEIR
REVIEW AND ANALYSIS OF OUR
REPORTS AND WHAT THEY DISCOVERED
IS THERE WAS AN ERROR RATE. THAT
IS NOT SURPRISING.
THEIR ERRORS IN THIS INHERENTLY.
VAGUE SYSTEM WHICH IS WHY THE
FBI IS TRANSITIONING TO AN
ENTIRELY NEW SYSTEM IN THREE
YEARS.
BUT MUCH HAS CHANGED E. EVEN
THOUGH OF THESE ERRORS WERE
FOUND.
SINCE THEN THE LAST THREE AND A
HALF YEARS UP WE HAVE DEDICATED
FIFTEEN FULL THAI POLICE OFFICER
DETECTIVE AND CIVILIANS WHOSE
SOLE JOB IS TO ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR DATA. IN CRIME
REPORTING HOBBIES ARE FIFTEEN
PERSONNEL WHO ARE NOT ON THE
STREETS INVESTIGATING CRIMES
THEY'RE NOT DOING ANY CRIMINAL
RELATED MATTERS BECAUSE WE COULD
THE CHIEF OF POLICE IS DEDICATED
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING THE SPECIALIZED
TRAINING OF WHICH WE HAVE DONE A
FIVE HOUR COURSE FOR TWO
THOUSAND OFFICERS. SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN DEVELOP UNIQUE TOOL
SUCH AS DECISION TREES CHECK
WITH THE HELP DESK BULLETINS AND
NOTICES AND THEN ALSO
IMPLEMENTED INTERNAL QUALITY
CONTROL MEASURES INCLUDING
INTERNAL INSPECTIONS. WHICH
INCLUDED REVIEWING FIVE THOUSAND
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT REPORTS LAST
YEAR MISTER ALCOTT I I KNOW YOU
YOU PROBABLY HAVE A LOT TO SAY
BETTER JUST TO BE FAIR TO ALL
WITNESSES IF YOU. TRY TO WRAP UP
AND WE CAN BRING OUT MORE
INFORMATION THROUGH THE QUESTION
PERIOD ABSOLUTELY UP TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S ANY CONCERN
ABOUT IT EXTERNAL REVIEW I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT IS ALSO UNIQUE ABOUT THE
LAPD IS WE HAVE A FIVE PERSON
CIVILIAN. OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
KNOWN AS THE BOARD POLICE
COMMISSIONERS THAT HIRES THE
FULL TIME.
INSPECTOR GENERAL WITH A FULLY
US STAFF.
THEY HAVE AUDITED AND THEY
REVIEW ALL OF OUR AUDITS AND
THEY HAVE FOUND THAT THE THAT
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED HAD AN IMMEDIATE
EFFECT ON REDUCING OUR ERROR
RATES IN THIS VERY COMPLICATED
AREA.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU COMMANDER IS YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL JUST TO ADD UP
WHEN WE DISCUSS ERROR RATE. ADDS
THE LA TIMES A NOTED IN NOVEMBER
THAT THEY WERE CONCERNED.
THAT SOMETIMES OUR AIR RATE IS
TEN PERCENT THIS IS THE.
SAME REFERENCE THAT WE SAID IN
OUR REPORT TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL OWN INTERNAL AUDITORS
AND MARCH.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WHERE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
HAVE OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS AN
ERROR RATE OF ABOUT TEN PERCENT.
INTERNING SPECTER GENERAL'S
REPORT IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
NOTED THAT AFTER LOOKING AT
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED A
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS NOTED AN
ERROR RATE AND THEY LOOK AT A
SEVEN YEAR PERIOD. OF
APPROXIMATELY NINE PERCENT OF
OUR MOST RECENT AUDIT HAS SHOWN
US THAT WE HAVE CHANGED OUR AIR
RAID A THAT TO US SIX PERCENT IN
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT AERATE AND
SIMPLE SOFTWARE PERCENT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE. QUESTIONS FROM THE
OUT OF IN THE COMMITTEE MISS
ETCETERA.
EXCUSE ME.
SO.
IN TERMS OF WHAT LEAD UP TO THIS
AUDIT REQUEST HEAD.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY EVIDENCE OR
HAVE YOU UNCOVERED ANY EVIDENCE
OR IS ANYONE PRESENTED YOU WITH
ANY EVIDENCE TO INDICATE THAT
THIS MISS CLASSIFICATION WAS THE
RESULT.
OF INTENTIONAL CONDUCT OR
MISCONDUCT ON THE PART OF
ANYONE.
INSIDE THE.
LAPD ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT THE
ALLEGATION THAT I'M TRYING TO TO
PRESENT FORWARD IS THAT THERE'S
ANY INTENTIONAL. MISCONDUCT OR
MANIPULATION HOWEVER I THINK WE
LIVE IN AN ENVIRONMENT RIGHT NOW
WITH THE PUBLIC TRUST WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS ERODED
SIGNIFICANTLY. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO BUILD THAT BACK IF THERE ARE.
A SUSTAINABLE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THERE IS AN ERROR RATE THAT CAN
BE EXPLAINED THAT IT SHOULD BE
DONE SO THROUGH AN INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S MY GOAL
IS TO TRY TO BUILD PUBLIC TRUST
BACK IT'S NOT TO LA.
TWO ALLEGED THERE'S MISTRUST.
WELL IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT MEAN THIS IS A AN
ERROR RATE IT'S.
BARELY BEEN ESTABLISHED ON
SEVERAL DIFFERENT OCCASIONS BY
SEVERAL DIFFERENT METHODS NOT.
YET BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT RECOGNIZES IT AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE FEDERAL BUREAU
OF INVESTIGATION IS DEVELOPING A
NEW SYSTEM THAT LAPD WILL
UTILIZE WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL
REDUCE THEM NUMBER OF MISS
CLASSIFICATIONS.
AND IF IN FACT THAT'S THE CASE
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
CASE BUT THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED.
THEN I'M CONCERNED OF FOR GOING
TO SPEND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST TO HAVE
OUR STATE OUGHT TO GO AND VERIFY
THAT THE OTHER RATE IN FACT IS
NINE OR TEN PERCENT.
FOR MISS CLASSIFICATIONS.
AND IT'S NOT THE RESULT OF ANY
INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT OR OR
INTENTIONAL ACT ON THE PART OF
LAPD OR THE MAYOR ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO.
TO ARTIFICIALLY LOWER.
IT COULD A CRIME RATE IN THE
CITY THEN I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE
ARE AT THE END OF THE AUDIT ARE
WE WHERE WE ARE TODAY WHICH IS
WE KNOW THERE'S A NINE OR TEN
PERCENT.
MISS CLASSIFICATION RATE AND
DEPARTMENT AND FBI FIGURED OUT
TRY TO GET LOWER BUT THAT
PROPOSAL.
ASSUMES A LOT OF ASSUMPTIONS
THAT.
MAY NOT BE FACTUAL AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE LIKE THE OUTSIDE
AUDITOR TO COME INTO VERIFY.
THEIR THERE VERY WELL MAY BE
SUBMITS AND SOME ACTUAL
INTENTIONAL AND MANIPULATION OF
NUMBERS BECAUSE THAT'S THE
SUSPICION OF MANY IN THE PUBLIC.
AND THE PUBLIC POLICY THAT WE
CRAFT.
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND AS LEGISLATURE
CULTURALLY STATISTICS AND SO THE
STATISTICS ARE VERY VERY
IMPACTFUL ON THIS ENTIRE STATE.
SO WE HAVE MISREPRESENTATION OF
FACTS TO THE DEGREE I MEAN THEY
INDICATE A THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THAT'S A LOT LOT OF
SALADA CRIMES AND WHEN WE HAVE
EVEN AT A TEMPER SENT RATE. OF
THAT'S THAT COULD BE A CRAFTED
DOWN TO FIVE OR FOUR PERCENT.
THEN WE NEED TO BE DOING THAT
VERY THING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MAKING HONEST DECISIONS
BASED ON HONEST INFORMATION WE
DON'T GO TO MY QUESTIONS IS
BEING CRITICAL I MEAN I I THINK.
SORT OF A.
OF A BIPARTISAN QUESTIONER WHEN
IT COMES TO BEING IN HERE
WHETHER IT'S AN AUDIT COMING
FROM THE LEFT OR NOT COMING FROM
THE RIGHT AYE I TEND TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND I USE THE TERM FISHING
EXPEDITION AND THAT SHOULDN'T
BE.
CONSIDER TO BE A CRITICISM IT'S
NOT BUT I TEND TO BE A LITTLE
CONCERNED WHEN WE SEND OUR STATE
AUDITOR OUT ON A.
ON A MISSION WHERE THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE TO INDICATE.
A PROBABLE CAUSE FOR EXAMPLE FOR
THOSE YOU IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT SOMETHING MAY HAVE
OCCURRED.
THAT'S THE REASON FOR MY
QUESTIONING BUT I WON'T BELABOR
IT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
INDULGING ME THANK YOU SIR FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR. THE BANK
ABOUT IT SURE OBERNOLTE AND THEN
MS BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
QUITE OFTEN IN THE LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE WILL RUN INTO
SITUATIONS WHERE. THE REQUEST
FOR AN AUDIT IS PERCEIVED AS
ADVERSARIAL. AND A DOESN'T SEEM
TO ME THAT IN THIS CASE IT IS I
THINK THAT WE'RE ALL THE SAME
TEAM HERE WERE TRY TO REDUCE THE
ERROR RATES OF THE
CLASSIFICATION OF THESE CRIMES.
ARE BUT IN READING THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESPONSE IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S A PERCEPTION THAT
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S BEING CALLED INTO
QUESTION AND I CERTAINLY DON'T.
DON'T ENTER PREDICT THAT WAY.
MY QUESTION IS THIS IF.
THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE STATE AUDITOR
WOULD PA WOULD BE HELPFUL IN
ESTABLISHING PROCEDURES THAT
REDUCE THE AIR RAID I THINK THAT
EVERYONE WOULD BENEFIT.
ANSWER MY QUESTION USE IS WOULD.
THE AUDITOR BE OF ASSISTANCE IN
THAT RESPECT AND IF NOT THEN WHY
NOT.
IT'S OUR POSITION THAT THE ART
IT WOULD BE OF LITTLE OR NO
VALUE TO US IN THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
EXTERNAL AUDITS THAT ARE
CONDUCTED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. OLIVER
INTERNAL AUDITS ARE PUBLICLY
PRESENTED AND HAVE BEEN FOR MANY
YEARS SO IT'S BEEN NO SECRET
THAT WE'VE HAD PREVIOUS ERROR
RATES.
OLIVER PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES
THAT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED PUBLICLY TO OUR
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION MULTIPLE
TIMES.
WE HAVE ASKED THE FBI UP FOR
MORE GUIDANCE ON WHAT IS AN
ACCEPTABLE ERROR RATE THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS AND WE'VE BEEN
FULLY OPEN AND TRANSPARENT WITH
OUR PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES.
I'M I THINK OF WHAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER UP BY THE VICE
CHAIR IS TRUE WE EXPECT THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE FOUND AN
ERROR RATE. TO THE EXTENT
THERE'S ANY AN ALLEGATION OF ANY
INTENTIONAL MANIPULATION WHICH
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY BUT WHEN
THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP IN THE PAST THE DEPARTMENT
CONDUCTED A VERY THOROUGH.
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION MARIE HAD
THE A POWER AND ABILITY TO
COMPEL.
OFFICERS TO SPEAK AND
DETECTIVES AND THERE WAS NOTHING
FAILED TO SHOW INTENTIONAL
MANIPULATION OR THE ANY
PARTICULAR ALLEGATIONS TO THAT
THAT ARE PENDING THAT I'M AWARE
OF.
SO SOMEBODY COMING IN AND AND IF
EXPENDING THAT THOSE RESOURCES
CERTAINLY THERE MIGHT BE
SOMETHING BUT. GIVEN OUR
OPENNESS OR TRANSPARENCY THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THAT WE
SPEND CURRENTLY I I WOULD NOT
EXPECT TO FIND ANYTHING THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY BE. LIKELY TO
REDUCE OUR RATE FROM.
SIX PERCENT TO TWO OF WE'RE
CONSTANTLY DRIVING TO DO THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING IS VERY
PORTANT.
THERE HAVE NOT BEEN ANY
MISREPRESENTATIONS OF OUR CRIME
STATISTICS
WE HAVE ALWAYS INDICATED THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN ERROR
RATE AND WHAT WE'RE REPRESENT
WHICH IS. FAIRLY KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY I THINK
WHAT WE WOULD WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO DO IS IF THERE IS AN
INTEREST IN LOOKING AT OUR. UP
PROCESSES ARE PROCEDURES ALL OF
OUR INTERNAL THE EXTERNAL AUDITS
AND UNDERSTANDING OF OF THAT.
WERE MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO THAT
AS WE DO IT FREQUENTLY WE WERE
ONLY TOLD OF THIS INTEREST IN
DOING AN AUDIT LAST WEEK.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN SORT OF IN A
POSITION WHERE WE'RE NOW.
TRYING TO SHOW THE MANY MANY
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
SINCE THE ORIGINAL REPORT. WAS
PUBLISHED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WELL JUST TO BE CLEAR EYED
NOTHING IN REQUEST I READ
SUGGESTS THAT ANY OF THE. ERRORS
IN REPORTING ARE INTENTIONAL.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT. WE AT
THE STATE LEVEL CAN BE OF
ASSISTANCE TO YOU AND FINDING
OUT PATHWAYS FOR REDUCING THE
ERROR RATE I'M I'M I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE ALL MOTIVATED GIVE YOU
THAT ASSISTANCE.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THE QUESTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER THAN MR
ACOSTA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I I THINK I AM.
MR OF THE NINETIES COMMENT JUST
CORRECT FOR SURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T APPEAR TO ME TO BE AN
ADVERSARIAL WINE OR WHINE WHERE.
THE AUTHOR IS.
JUST LOOKING FOR SOMETHING TO
AUDIT I THINK
I WENT WHEN I LEARNED OF THIS
AUDIT REQUEST AND SAW SOME OF
THE BACK WHEN I THOUGHT AS A
STATE LEGISLATOR I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO HAVE THIS INFORMATION%
BECAUSE. LA IS THIS LARGEST CITY
AND CALIFORNIA AND WEIGHS IN ON
LEGISLATION THAT WE ARE VOTING
ON LAST SESSION THE SESSION AND
OTHERWISE.
I DO WANT TO ASK OUR AUDITOR.
THINK TWO QUESTIONS.
IF IF THE THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDITED AS AS YOU UNDERSTAND IT
WILL ALLOW YOU TO FIND OUT.
INCLUDE BY LOOKING EVER TENURE
PERIOD WHAT OF THE ITEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN CHANGED HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE
I LIKE A CAUSAL LINK BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL
WHEN I'M READING IN THE
RESPONSES AND OTHERWISE IF
CHANGING THINGS AND OUR ERROR
RATE IS BETTER. WE HEAR A LOT IS
OF LEGISLATORS THAT THERE'S
PROGRAMS OUT THERE AND THERE FOR
THE ENTIRE ENTITY HAS IMPROVED
SOME RATE OF.
RETURN OR SOME RATE OF
EFFECTIVENESS BUT THEY CAN'T
DRAW A LINE BETWEEN HERE'S WHAT
WE DID HERE AND THIS IS WHY IT
WAS EFFECTIVE. I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THAT DOES THIS AUDIT GIVE
YOU THE CAPABILITY OF DOING
THAT.
YES IT DOES THERE ARE SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVES THAT.
MISTER LACKEY HAS ASKED US TO
LOOK AT STEPS THAT LAPD HAS
TAKEN TO REDUCE OR MITIGATE AND
AS I MENTIONED IN LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE BACKGROUND MATERIAL
OVER THE WEEKEND THEY. THE LAPD
SHERIFF I MEAN I'M.
CHECK CHIEF BACK I APOLOGIZE
CHIEF BACK ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED
A DATA INTEGRITY UNIT I THINK
IT'S REFERRED TO SO WE WOULD
WANT TO LOOK AT THAT AS PERHAPS.
A BEST PRACTICE THAT LAPD IS
USING WHEN DID THAT UNIT ONE WAS
AT UNICREDIT AND WHAT'S THE DISK
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW MUCH WAS
MIS REPORTED ARE UNDER REPORTED
PRIOR TO. AND NOW SUBSEQUENT AS
AS A GENTLEMAN INDICATED THERE
ARE SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WORKING ON REVIEWING REPORTS TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE. APPROPRIATELY
CLASSIFIED AND ENTERED INTO THE
SYSTEM SO I THINK. IF THEY'RE
DEPENDING ON WHEN SOME OF THOSE
MEASURES WERE TAKEN WE CAN LOOK
AT THE BEFORE AND AFTER AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY MISTER LACKEY.
ASKED US TO LOOK AT A TEN YEAR
WINDOW I THINK THAT'S GOOD
BECAUSE THAT THAT TO ME.
IS WHAT WE GET AT THE END OF THE
LINE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE EITHER
KOZOL. AYE CONNECTION OR SO THAT
WE CAN BE MAKING BETTER
DECISIONS THAT WILL AFFECT THE
STATE BECAUSE AT THE STATE LEVEL
WE'RE HEARING FROM LOS ANGELES
THE POLICIES THAT. ARE
IMPLEMENTED AT THE STATE LEVEL
ARE FACT IN THE AREA AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND AND I ALSO WANT TO.
ASK THE OTHER AUDITS THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL OTHERWISE YOU WILL HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF THOSE AS PART OF
YOUR. WORK I THINK IN YOUR
OPENING TESTIMONY YOU MENTIONED
THAT I'VE LOOKED AT SOME OF THEM
AND AND SO I'M.
IT THAT BECOMES NOT DUPLICATIVE
BUT THAT CAN BE USEFUL TO YOU
AND HAVING THAT INFORMATION
ALREADY OUT THERE.
ABSOLUTELY AND IN PREPARATION
FOR THE HEARING I ALWAYS I HAVE
MULTIPLE BACKGROUND BINDERS THAT
STAFF PREPARE FOR ME SO I CAN BE
OKAY A LITTLE BETTER UP TO
SPEED.
FOR THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
LIKE THAT SO YES ABSOLUTELY WE
WOULD LOOK AT INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORTS ANY INTERNAL AUDITS THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE AND UNDER OUR
AUDIT STANDARDS THAT MY OFFICE
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR FOLLOWING
OBVIOUS STATUTE. A GENERALLY
ACCEPTED AUDITING STANDARDS WE
ARE REQUIRED TO LOOK AT OTHER
WORK IT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE SO
THAT WE CAN BENEFIT FROM THAT
DETERMINE WHETHER WE CAN RELY ON
IT AND NOT DUPLICATE WORK THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE. I WAS VERY
INTERESTED IN SEEING THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT THAT
WAS DONE ON THE LA SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT HOW THEY WENT ABOUT
SELECTING THEIR SAMPLE WHAT THE
SIZE WAS WHAT KINDS OF QUESTIONS
THEY ASKED.
BY THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AS
FAR AS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SO
I THINK WE WOULD WE WOULD START
BY LOOKING AT WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DONE LEARN FROM THAT AND
DETERMINE HOW THAT WILL AFFECT
OUR APPROACH. IN CONDUCTING THIS
AUDIT IF THE COMMITTEE DECIDES
TO PROVE IT WAS GOOD TO HEAR AYE
I DO YOU SEE AN END PRODUCT THAT
CAN BE HELPFUL TO US.
STATE LEGISLATORS AND HOPEFULLY
HELP HELPFUL ADDED TO THE LA
BROADER AREA AND IT BRINGS AND
AN ADDITIONAL ELEMENT OF
INDEPENDENCE THAT GIVEN THE
ALLEGATIONS WHETHER IT WAS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN OR. LAST YEAR
I'M IS REALLY REALLY NEEDED AND
AND CAN BE VERY BENEFICIAL SO
I'M LOOK FOR TO SUPPORT THE I
THINK YOU MISTER LACKEY FOR
BRINGING FORWARD.
MR BECAUSE IT WOULD.
THANK YOU A LOT OF MY COMMENTS A
VERY BEEN ECHOED BY MY BY MY.
THE FELLOW MEMBERS HERE.
I DID ONE I I GUESS AT THIS
POINT SINCE THEY HAVE BEEN I
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT AYE AYE.
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS LOS
ANGELES.
AND AS A LOT OF.
ADMIRATION FOR YOU KNOW FOR THE
LAPD. I LOOK AT THIS AS
AGAIN NOT ADVERSARIAL I LOOK AT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT CAN
SUPPLEMENT THE RESOURCES THAT
THE LAPD IN INTERNAL AUDITS
HAVE.
I LOOK AT THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO BE
ON THE SAME PAGE IN TERMS OF
THEIR. YOU KNOW POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES BUT ALSO TO JUST YA
CAN'T HAVE A BACKSTOP.
IT IT CERTAINLY A TIME GOING TO
SPEND.
THE STATE RESOURCES HE SHOULD
HAVE A A THE POSITIVE OUTCOME IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT WERE WERE
SEEKING AND ONE WHAT THE END
GOAL AS. A BUT I LOOK AT THE
BACKDROP OF WHAT I HEAR IN THE
DISTRICT IN FROM MY CONSTITUENTS
OF. YOU KNOW THAT JUST THAT THE
OVERALL CRIME RATE AS SOME OF
THAT VIOLENT CRIMES AND THEY'RE
VERY CONCERNED A WITHOUT NOT
ONLY THE.
THE REPORTING BUT ALSO JUST THE
RESOURCES AND I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT COULD BE.
POSITIVE A POSITIVE OUTCOME I
LOOK AT THAT FABULOUS WORKED AT
THE.
THE OFFICERS ARE DOING ON THE
STREETS AND AND FRANKLY I THINK
A COMMAND STAFF IS IS DOING.
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO WORK AND
IN AND FRANKLY IT TOUGH
SITUATION THIS LEGISLATURE'S
MADE IT VERY VERY CHALLENGING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
ACROSS THE STATE WITH A PROP
FORTY SEVEN AND EIGHT ENDEAVOR
TO MAYBE ONE A NINE AND OF
COURSE PROP 47-57 THAT THE. THAT
THE ARM VOTERS HAVE APPROVED
IT'S MADE IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THESE POLICE AGENCIES AND SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED IN
THIS IS ANOTHER WAY FOR US TO
GET THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
IS A LEGISLATURE.
TO TO HAVE THAT THE PROPER ON.
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND AND I I HOPE IT'S NOT EVER
CONSTRUED AS ANY KIND OF OUR.
OF AN INDICTMENT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING YA INTERNALLY A
CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT OF THE RANK
AND FILE OFFICERS ON THE STREET
THEY'RE DOING A FABULOUS JOB I
WORK WITH THEM YOU KNOW ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AND FRANKLY ANNA A WHOLE LOT OF
LIVE IN MY DISTRICT AND I AYE
INTERACT WITH THEM REGULARLY AND
AYE HERE ISSUES THAT I THINK.
WE YOU KNOW WE CAN WE CAN HELP
ADDRESS A NOT NECESSARILY
THROUGH THIS AUDIT PROCESS
BECAUSE THIS IS A KIND OF A
SEPARATE ISSUE.
BUT CERTAINLY.
THE AUDIT WILL GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A BASELINE
THAT EVERYONE IN THE STATE CAN
NOW TAKE A LOOK AT AND SAY WELL
HERE'S SOME BEST PRACTICES HERE
SOME THINGS THAT THAT WERE YOU
KNOW THAT WERE DONE VERY WELL BY
LAPD AND I'M SURE THAT'S GOING
TO BE. THE CASE.
AND AND ALSO IF WE HAVE AN
AFFIRMATION THAT IT'S A FOUR
PERCENT TO SIX PERCENT OR TWENTY
PERCENT.
ERROR RATE WHATEVER IT HAPPENS
TO BE.
WORK ON AND NOW HAVE THE FACTS
AND I I WAS ONE AIR ON THE SIDE
OF HAVING DATA. O. EVERYWHERE I
I SAID IN THIS LEGISLATURE
WHATEVER BODY AND WHATEVER
COMMITTEE IT'S ON I LIKE TO HAVE
THE DATA AND I THINK THIS IS
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO
THAT. BUT CERTAINLY AT A WITH
ALL RESPECT AND ADMIRATION FOR
OF THE LAPD I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR.
YOU KNOW FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE INFORMATION AND I THINK
YOU OFFER YOU KNOW YOU'RE BRING
IT FORWARD THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR'S NAME ONLY BRIEFLY.
CLARIFY A POINT THAT THE HON
THAT WAS JUST MADE UP FIRST WELL
WE DO NOT SEE THIS AS
ADVERSARIAL AS WELL.
I OVERSEE OUR OWN INTERNAL
AUDIT THE VISION I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE AUDITING IS DIFFICULT
AND CHALLENGING SO WE DO NOT I
THINK OUR CONCERN IS THAT THERE
WAS NO DISCUSSION WITH US TO
EXPLAIN WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE. I THINK THERE'S SOME
MISPERCEPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
WAS INDICATED THAT THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE THE RELATIVE CRIME
RATE AN ERROR RATE DOESN'T
AFFECT THE RELATIVE CRIME RATE
IF THE ERROR RATE IS RELATIVELY
CONSISTENT OVER TIME. THE
RELATIVE INCREASE OR DECREASE IN
CRIME DOES NOT MATTER IF YOU
HAVE A FIVE TEN PERCENT ERROR
RATE YEAR TO YEAR AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THE INDEPENDENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS FOUND SO
ARCTIC CRIME RATE REDUCTIONS
THAT INCREASES. ARE NOT AFFECTED
BY THAT ERROR RATE OF THE SECOND
THING IS THAT. WE DO NOT USE FBI
CLASSIFICATIONS TO TO DEPLOY
RESOURCES
SO HOW WE CLASSIFY A CRIME UNDER
THE UC OUR SYSTEM HAS NO IMPACT
ON HOW WE ALLOCATE RESOURCES TO
SHOOTINGS AND OTHER THINGS
BECAUSE. THE FBI SYSTEM OF
REPORTING DOES NOT MARY OUR
MATCH UP
THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE IN ANY
WAY. SO THIS IS A WHOLE
DIFFERENT REPORTING SYSTEM
THAT'S THERE AND I THINK OUR
CONCERN IS COULD WE GET SOME
VALUE OF THIS CERTAINLY. BUT
GIVEN THE EXPENSE THAT WILL BE.
EXPENDED BY THE STATE WE JUST
FEEL WILL BE HIGHLY DUPLICATIVE
OF WHAT WE DO IN A VERY OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER WITH THE.
AUDIT DIVISION THAT'S KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
DOES EVERYTHING BY THE
GENERALLY ACCEPTED GOVERNMENT
AUDITING STANDARDS AND THEN THE
INDEPENDENT INSPECTOR GENERAL
THAT COMES IN AND WE DO AUDITS
ANNUALLY A CRIME STATISTICS. THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL VIEWS THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL CONDUCT ITS
OWN AUDITS THAT ARE ARE
COMPLETELY SEPARATE FROM US. AS
WELL AS ALL OF OUR DATA ALL OF
OUR REPORTS A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
AND UNDER INTENSE SCRUTINY BY
RESEARCHERS AND THE MEDIA
EXTERNALLY. SO OUR CONCERN IS
THAT THIS IS SIMPLY GOING TO BE
DUPLICATIVE OF A LOT OF THOSE
EFFORTS AND WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO TAKE THE TIME.
IF GIVEN THE TIME TO PRESENT
ALL OF THE MANY THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE AND IMPROVED OVER THE
LAST OF SEVERAL YEARS.
RIGHT.
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE.
SEEING NONE.
.
IT'S LACKEY WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
YEAH I JUST REAL QUICKLY I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT I AM
SYMPATHETIC TO THE HESITATION
FOR.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT TO A
WELCOME AN AUDIT.
AND CERTAINLY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE
CONSENT DECREES TO COMPLY WITH
AND THEY HAVE A LOT OF.
OVERSIGHT CIRCUMSTANCES TO
YOU THAT. THERE IS A PROTECT THE
REASON WHY WE BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AT BECAUSE THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT.
LEVEL OF DOUBT THAT HAS BEEN A
PERMEATED IN THE MINDS OF MANY
POLICY MAKERS AND MANY PEOPLE
WHO RELY ON.
ON THE TRUST AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND AND.
BUT TYPICALLY LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND AS A OF THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WE
RELY. ON GOOD STATISTICAL
INFORMATION TO MAKE GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY.
AND THERE IS CLEARLY A RESERVE
WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER A
REASONABLE DOUBT OTHERWISE I
WOULDN'T BE HERE. I'M I GET NO
SATISFACTION OUT OF BRINGING.
THIS KIND OF CHALLENGE FORWARD
TO IT AT A DEPARTMENT THAT I
HAVE GREAT ADMIRATION FOR HAVING
SERVED TWENTY YEARS A LOT FOR
SOME MYSELF.
SO THERE IN MY OPINION AND THE
REASON WHY WE'RE.
DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE TODAY IS
THERE IS A REASONABLE DOUBT. IN
THAT IN THE MINDS OF MANY THAT I
THINK THAT THIS AUDIT WOULD BE
ABLE.
TO BRING FORWARD AND TO
ELIMINATE AND I THINK IT'S VERY
CRITICAL THAT WE ELIMINATE THAT.
THAT LEVEL OF DOUBT THAT'S BEEN
PERMEATING FOR A LONG TIME QUITE
HONESTLY. AND I I DON'T A.
WANT TO TO CREATE IT DID
A CIRCUMSTANCE THAT I HAVE
ANYTHING TO GAIN FROM THIS OTHER
THAN GOOD INFORMATION THAT THE
PUBLIC.
DESERVES AND WE TRULY NEED RIGHT
NOW WHERE WHEN THE LEVEL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS.
THE A DISTRUST OF THEY DO AND
THAT'S IN ARGUABLE THAT WE NEED
TO BUILD OUR OUR PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE NOT LEAVE IT THIS.
PARTICULAR A PROPOSAL AND THIS
AUDIT WOULD BUILDUP PUBLIC TRUST
NO MATTER WHAT THE FLIGHT.
SO THEREFORE I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU A FAVORABLY CONSIDER THIS
AUDIT.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE TO AND.
BY MISTER OBERNOLTE AND
SECONDED BY MS BAKER.
SO ARM I I DID HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO.
STUDY THIS REQUEST.
AND A LITTLE MORE DETAIL AND I
ALSO HAD A CHANCE TO.
AND FOR THE RECORD DISCUSS.
THIS WITH THE LAPD CHIEF A BACK.
YESTERDAY EVENING WHO.
.
THIS THAT THE POINT I FOCUSED ON
WAS WHETHER THERE ARE TO ANY
INDEPENDENT AND AND RECENT.
REVIEW OF.
THE CRIME STATISTICS AND.
.
THE CHIEF.
APPOINTED ME TO THE ARE OF
COURSE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT WHICH HAVE A COPY HERE.
.
ALL OF US IN LOS ANGELES KNOW
THE THE IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND HOW.
.
THAT OFFICE AND THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS MADE TREMENDOUS
STRIDES IN ADDRESSING A MISTER
LACKEY YOUR.
YOUR YOUR PRIMARY CONCERN
RESTORING TRUST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SPECIFIC ON THE
AT A LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
.
THIS REPORT COMBINED WITH.
THE THE THE RECENT EFFORTS THIS
IS A REPORT FROM DECEMBER TWENTY
FIFTEEN FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
.
WHICH CONFIRMS WHAT.
MISTER ALI KHAN.
.
TESTIFIED TO.
AS WELL AS THE RECENT.
EFFORTS OF THE LAPD AND CREATED
CREATING THIS DATA INTEGRITY YOU
AND IT.
.
I FEEL THAT.
THAT THAT I I SHARE YOUR YOUR
YOUR CONCERNED WITH THAT MAY
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE.
.
DATA WITH INTEGRITY AS TO.
CRIME STATISTICS AND AND AND
CRIME TRENDS.
BUT I FEEL AT THIS POINT AND
THAT THIS IS.
PERHAPS.
PREMATURE THAT THAT PERHAPS WE
SHOULD ALLOW THE RECENT REFORMS.
TO TO GO FORWARD.
.
THE EFFORTS OF THE LAPD ARE
SUPPORTED BY.
THE FBI WE HAVE.
A LETTER HERE.
CHIEF BACK REQUESTING TO A
JAMES COMEY OF THE F. B. I. THEN
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
IT WITH A RESPONSE.
FROM.
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INFORMATION
SERVICES DIVISION OF THE FBI. A
COMMANDING THE LAPD AS A.
LEADER AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
TOOLS.
TO ADDRESS
THESE.
CHALLENGES OF RECONCILING THIS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PENAL CODE
WITH THE FEDERAL UNIFORM CRIME
REPORTING.
.
DATA AND SO.
AGAIN.
SIR I YOU KNOW YOU YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN RESPECT IN THIS HOUSE
AS A CAREER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER AND I KNOW THAT YOU ONLY
BRING THIS REQUEST FORWARD WITH.
.
NOTHING MORE THAN A TWO.
A WANTS TO ENSURE THE INTEGRITY
OF.
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE DATA
AT THAT PRODUCES AS TO CRIME
STATISTICS.
ARE HOWEVER BASED ON.
THE ALL THE INFORMATION THAT I
RECEIVED.
I.
THEM RECOMMENDING.
DATA.
THAT WE DENY THIS REQUEST.
SEEING GUY.
MADAM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO PROVE AUDIT NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
ZERO FIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCI CHICO.
MERCI CHINO ACOSTA.
I.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I.
RUBIO.
RUBIO NOT VOTING WOULD.
WOULD.
NO.
SENATOR ROTH.
THUNDER.
ALLEN.
BELL.
CANNELLA.
MENDOZA
IT'S JUST.
THE MOTIONS ON CALL.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
DO WE HAVE A CENTER BELL HERE.
WE DO NOT.
DO WE HAVE THE MOST LIVING HERE
.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
CENTER BELL IS ON ITS WAY SO.
WE WILL BE TAKEN UP.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY ON
A REQUEST SHORTLY
THINGS HAVE CHANGED. IT.
PREVIOUS GROUP HOMES TOPIC. COME
SEEKING ANSWERS.
IN.
I HAVE TO KEEP ASKING.
KEEP GOING.
I THINK.
THE CRITICAL. CRITICAL MINE
.
S. ABOUT MISTER PATTERSON.
IN WESTERN.
OKAY.
THAT'S WHEN A TRAIN COMES.
SURE. YOU
YOU'VE SENATOR IS COMING DOWN.
WHEREVER YOU
YES THANK YOU.
SENATOR WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU ARE JUGGLING YEAR.
SENATE SESSION.
WELCOME EVERYONE.
LET'S RESUME OUR.
HEARING WE ARE BACK ON THE
RECORD REGULAR CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE OH EIGHT HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY. POLICIES AND
PRACTICES.
I JOINTLY SUBMITTED BY CENTER
BELL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARRIVAL.
CENTRE BELL WHICH LIKE STIRRED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M A MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS TODAY.
AS I STATED IN OUR AUDIT
REQUEST LETTER I'M HERE TODAY
REQUESTED JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE. TO APPROVE AN
AUDIT TO EXAMINE.
THE EFFICIENCY IN OF A FAT DE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CURRENT POLICIES AND
PRACTICES IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE PROJECT.
NOT WITHOUT A QUESTION THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROGRAM IS THE
LARGEST MOST COMPLEX AND.
SOME WAYS FAR REACHING PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT WE HAVE
NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE
NATION.
THIS MEGA PROJECT PUTS
CALIFORNIA AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THE TRANSPORTATION INNOVATION.
HOWEVER PROJECT THIS LARGEST NOT
COME WITHOUT CHALLENGES.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
PROJECT CONSTANTLY FACES A
MAIREAD OF REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC POLICY
POLITICAL FUNDING AND OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT MUST BE
ANTICIPATED.
AND EFFECTIVELY MANAGED AND IN
ORDER TO OF HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
SUCCESSFULLY IS DELIVERED ON
TIME AND ON BUDGET.
THE AUDIT RICK THIS AUDIT
REQUESTS AM SAID TO PROVIDE THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW. OF THE
AUTHORITIES EXISTING PRACTICES
AND PROCEDURES.
THE RESULT FROM THE AUDIT WILL
PROVIDE THAT MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WITH THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO ALLOW US TO
PROVIDE STRONG OVERSIGHT AND
GUIDANCE TO ENSURE THE PROJECT
IS ON TRACK TO BE SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED.
FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS REQUEST WE
ARE REQUESTING THE STATE OUGHT
TO REVIEW THE CONTRACT
MANAGEMENT POLICIES.
AND PRACTICES INCLUDING THE
PROCESS
FOR APPROVING CONTRACTOR CHANGE
ORDERS.
WHEN I WAS BOARD OF A CHAIR. OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY TRAFFIC
AUTHORITY. WHICH IS THEIR FIRST
HALF CENT SALES TAX IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR AND WE BUILT.
MANY MILES OF FREEWAYS.
I CONSTANTLY CHALLENGED
CONTRACTORS IN JUSTIFYING THEIR
CHANGE ORDER REQUEST AS THEY
COULD LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT COST
OVERRUNS.
THIS IS WHY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE LOOK AT BOTH THE HIGH SPEED
RAILS CONTRACT MANAGEMENT
POLICIES AND. ALSO HOLD THE
CONTRACTORS.
ACCOUNTABLE IN ENOUGH TO
EFFECTIVELY USE THE TAXPAYERS'
MONEY BY MINIMIZING CHANGE
ORDERS INTERN. KEEPING PROJECT
COSTS INCREASE TO MINIMUM.
BOTH HOUSES ARE AWARE THAT THIS
IS A VERY CRITICAL YEAR FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
TODAY I'M HERE REPRESENTING AN
AUDIT REQUESTS UNDERSTAND THE
ASSEMBLY HAS ALSO EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS.
ON THE AUTHORITIES REQUEST TO
DELAY THE RELEASED OF THIS
YEAR'S BUSINESS PLAN AS SET A
LETTER TO THE AUTHORITY.
NOW AUTUMN I IT'S MY GOAL AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING COMMITTEE OF THE SENATE.
TO PROVIDE A STRONG OVERSIGHT
OVER THE AUTHORITY AND PROJECT
AT THE SAME TIME.
INSURER THE AUTHORITY HAS THE
PROPER POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
IN PLACE.
TO ALLOW THE PROJECT TO
SUCCESSFULLY MOVED FORWARD.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE MY COSTA
RESULT TURN IT OVER TO MICHAEL
OFFERS A SEMI MEMBERS.
SENATE TOP.
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN PRESENTING OUT.
THE MORE WE LEARN ABOUT.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT THE
MORE WE ARE FACED WITHOUT THE
NECESSITY AND THE NEED FOR OF A
FORENSIC THOROUGH. A AT AN
INDEPENDENT AUDIT WE'VE WE'VE
LEARNED FOR EXAMPLE THAT.
WE'RE ON EIGHT YEAR ALMOST AN
EIGHT YEAR DELAY.
WE HAVE SEEN EXECUTIVES
DEPARTING.
AND IT'S TAKEN A PERIOD OF TIME
TO FILL THOSE.
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS IN A IN A
TIME WHEN THE PROJECT IS IN A
VERY CRITICAL PERIOD OF TIME.
NOW WE'VE LEARNED ALSO THAT THE
AUTHORITY HAS MADE EMERGENCY
INTERNAL FUND TRANSFERS FROM MY
UTILITY ACCOUNTS TO THE
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS. IN ORDER
TO KEEP OUR ARE THE HARD HATS
ARE WORKING IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO WE FOUND OUT THAT THE
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT.
HAS JUMPED FROM SIX BILLION
DOLLARS TO EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
NOW TO ALMOST ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS THESE ARE. FACTS AND
TRAJECTORIES DATA CALL HOME.
BECAUSE ALL OF US TO HAVE SOME
REAL. CONCERNS.
MANY OF YOU COME FROM UP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EITHER AS MAYOR OR
CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND IF YOU WERE TO SEE THESE
KINDS OF SCIENCE AND AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IN YOUR
BACKYARD WERE YOU RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSIGHT.
YOU REALLY WOULD SEE THESE AS
REAL RED MARK SIGNALS THAT AND
ARE INDEPENDENT NONPARTISAN
AUDIT. THE AT TO FIND OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
AND MEMBERS WHIT WE'RE REALLY
WAY PAST THE POLITICS OF ALL OF
THIS. REALLY DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU THINK THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY IS DOING A GOOD JOB
WITH THE THE.
RARE HIGH SPIRITS GOOD IDEA BAD
IDEA OR IF YOU'RE CAUGHT MIDDLE.
AND UNDECIDED THE SET OF FACTS
AND CONCERNS THAT WE ARE RAISING
THAT COME OUT RECENTLY POINT
SQUARELY TO THE NEED TO APPROVE
THIS AUDIT TODAY. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
APPROVE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
MISTER OPERABLE.
SO FIRST THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING ME IN
THIS AUDIT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
AUDIT REQUEST OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
AS ONE OF THE TWO MEMBERS
APPOINTED AS AN EX OFFICIO
MEMBER OF THE BOARD I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
AUDIT.
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
FINANCIAL OVERRUNS HAVE BEEN
CAUSED BY DELAYS IN ACCESSING
LAND AND DELAYS FROM LITIGATION.
THIS AUDIT SHED SOME LIGHT ON
HOW WE IMPROVE DELIVERY OF THE
PROJECT MOVING FORWARD MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
IN MY DISTRICT
THE POSITIVE EFFECTS THAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS ALREADY CREATING
IS BEING FELT COUNTY WIDE.
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS HAVING THE
LARGEST IMPACT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH ONE POINT TWO
BILLION OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
AND SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED JOB
YEARS OF EMPLOYMENT VALLEY ONE.
HIGH SPEED RAIL HAS HAD THE
LARGEST IMPACT IN FRESNO COUNTY.
BETWEEN JULY FIFTEENTH AND JUNE
TWENTY SIXTEEN HIGH SPEED RAIL
RESULTED IN OVER THREE THOUSAND
JOB YEARS OF EMPLOYMENT. AND
ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL JOBS THAT FRESNO COUNTY
ECONOMY ADDED DURING THAT TIME.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN FRESNO'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE DIPPED BELOW
TEN PERCENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AND ONLY THE FOURTH TIME IN THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE COUNTY HAS EXPERIENCE THREE
CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF ANNUAL
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH OVER THREE
PERCENT.
PRIOR TO TWENTY FOURTEEN FRESNO
COUNTY HAD JUST ONE YEAR OF
THREE PERCENT EMPLOYMENT GROWTH
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY.
WITH ANY LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT THERE ARE BOUND TO
BE OVERRUNS.
BUT TAXPAYER DOLLARS MUST BE
SPENT RESPONSIBLY AND THIS AUDIT
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT PROJECTS
ARE BEING DELIVERED MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
THESE POSITIVE IMPACTS WILL BE
FELT BY ALL COMMUNITIES ALONG
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL ROUTE.
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY WILL
ENSURE PUBLIC TRUST IN
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO BUILD
THE FIRST HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
NORTH AMERICA.
AS THE FRESNO BEE SAID THIS
MORNING THE MORE INFORMATION WE
GET THE BETTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MS HAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
MEMBERS INDICATED A OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS NOT OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
REALLY FOCUSING ON. CONTRACT
MANAGEMENT FIRST OBJECTIVE IS
LOOKING AT POT THE THIRTIES
POLICIES PROCEDURES AND
PROCESSES FOR MANAGING CONTRACTS
AWARDING CONTRACTS MANAGING
THOSE CONTRACTS AND DOING THINGS
TO CONTAIN COSTS.
BOB BY TRACKING OUR CONTRACTS
REVIEWING INVOICES AND
ULTIMATELY PAYING THOSE INVOICES
AS SENATOR BELL INDICATED ONE
KEY ISSUE HE IS ASKING US
MEMBERS OF ARE ASKING US TO LOOK
AT IS THE CHANGE ORDER PROCESS.
THE FREQUENCY OF CHANGE ORDERS
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THOSE CHANGE
ORDERS WHAT KIND OF PROCESS HAS
THE AUTHORITY ESTABLISHED. OUGHT
TO ADDRESS CHANGE ORDERS
THROUGHOUT THE PROJECT.
IN LOOKING AT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN POSSIBLY DO THIS
AND CERTAINLY WE WILL WE WILL
LOOK TO SEE WHAT THE AUTHORITY
HAS DONE AS FAR AS. EVALUATING
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
EFFORTS OF FOR CONSTRUCTING A
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHAT THE IMPACT HAS BEEN ON
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY THOSE
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW IN CENTRAL
VALLEY. WHERE THIS FIRST SEGMENT
OUR FIRST PHASE OF THE PROJECT
IS IS UNDER CONSTRUCTION? ALSO
DETERMINING.
CONTRACTING WITH SMALL AND
DISADVANTAGED OR MICRO
BUSINESSES THERE'S A THERE'S A
PROVISION OF THAT THE AUTHORITY
THEIR GOAL IS TO HAVE THIRTY
PERCENT OF THEIR CONTRACTS TO BE
WITH SMALL. DISADVANTAGED
DISABLED VETERAN MICRO
BUSINESSES SO WE WOULD ASSESS
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
AUTHORITIES BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL. AND THEN
THE LAST COUPLE OF OBJECTIVES
ARE RELATED TO A SUSTAINABILITY
POLICY LOOKING AT BOTH. ECONOMIC
OUT OUR OUTCOMES BUT ALSO
ENVIRONMENTAL WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE EXPECTED AYE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OF HAVING HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN CALIFORNIA. AND HOW IS
THE AUTHORITY ASSESSING THOSE
BENEFITS AND COMMUNICATING THOSE
BENEFITS AND THEN THE LAST
OBJECTIVE. DIDN'T TO THE EXTENT
WE CAN AGAIN WE WILL CERTAINLY
LOOK TO SEE WHAT THE AUTHORITY
IS DOING AS FAR AS THEIR
EFFORTS.
TO TRY TO PARTNER WITH OTHER
TRANSPORTATION.
I'M ENTITIES ARE TRANSIT OR RAIL
LINES TO TRY TO EXPEDITE A
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA THEIR BUDGET FOR THE
PROJECT OR FOR THE AUDIT IS
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED HOURS THAT
THAT WOULD TAKE US. BETWEEN SIX
AND SEVEN MONTHS PUBLIC CLOSER
TO SEVEN MONTHS I'M WE MAY NEED
TO HIRE A CONSULTANT WITH
RESPECT TO THIS ADMIN ECONOMIST
PERHAPS A MAYBE SOME
CONSTRUCTION EXPERTISE WE
HAVEN'T MADE THAT DETERMINATION
BUT I WANT TO LET THE COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT AS WELL. OUT WE
ALWAYS.
LOOKED TO FOR ASSISTANCE IN THE
EVENT PARTICULARLY A HIGH
PROFILE VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT
LIKE HIGH SPEED RAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS REQUEST.
SEEING NONE.
DO WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIPHATE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY.
WELL I'M SORRY IN A VERY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE I I AM I REPRESENT
IN A SMALL BUSINESS. OPAC
MATERIALS WILL BE WERE AWARDED
THE HAVE PURCHASE ORDER FOR THE
READY MIX CONCRETE ON THE
PROJECT.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN
THROUGH TUTOR PERINI ZACHRY
PARSONS WHO WAS AWARDED THE
CONTRACT.
TRACTOR I CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE
ONE.
AND.
AT THE TIME WE HAD.
FIVE OPERATIONS IN THE IN THE
AN EASTER SIERRA'S MARIPOSA
HARBURY SOME SMALL TOWNS. IN
ASSEMBLY BIGELOW'S AREA. AND.
HAD BEEN THERE FOR JUST OVER
FORTY YEARS.
AND WHEN WE HEARD THE NEWS ABOUT
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IT
WAS SOMETHING WE WANTED TO GET
INVOLVED IN. AT THE TIME WE AT
THIRTY TWO EMPLOYEES AND
FAMILIES AND OUR PAYROLL WAS
ABOUT A MILLION TO.
THINK THE END OF THIS YEAR OUR
PAYROLL WAS OVER SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR EMPLOYEE AND
COUNTLESS NINETY TWO PEOPLE. IN
FAMILY SO THE EMPLOYMENT BROUGHT
AS A RESULT OF THIS PROJECT TO
TO OUR BUSINESS AND OTHER SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT. FRANKLY I.
SOME SORT OF OF MATERNAL THAT
HAVE REPRESENT THEM OFFICIALLY
BUT THERE IS A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT I WORK WITH
EVERY DAY THAT COULDN'T BE HERE.
BECAUSE THEY DRIVE THEIR OWN
TRUCKS ARE THERE ONE OR TWO MEN.
OPERATIONS SO HOME.
WE'VE HAD A HUGE IMPACT WE'VE
INVESTED SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN. IN.
NEW TRUCKS AND.
AND A NEW CONCRETE PLANT WITH
ALL THE NEW ENVIRONMENTAL.
TECHNOLOGIES TO GO ALONG WITH
THOSE THINGS HANDA A RECYCLING A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF OUR WATER IN
ALL OF OUR. CONCRETE FOR THE
PROJECT KNOWN AS WELL WERE
IMPLEMENTING A CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
WERE REPLACING CEMENT WITH
LIQUID CARBON DIOXIDE. INTO OUR
MIXES THAT ALLOWS US TO USE
CO TWO WASTIN PUT IT BACK INTO
CONCRETE WHERE THE MATERIAL IS
SEQUESTERED. ANDA ABLE TO REDUCE
OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT AS A
RESULT.
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY AND BECAUSE
WERE ABLE TO BUILD A NEW PLANT.
A AS A RESULT THIS PROJECT WE
PROVIDE CLEANER CONCRETE TEN
LOWER CARBON EMISSIONS. TO. TO
FRESNO. PLAYWRIGHT AND YOU MAY
HAVE DONE THIS BUT GOOD YOU
WERE.
RESTATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION FOR THE RECORD US
LOVE IT IS MY NAME ON THE OWNER
ABOUT BACK MATERIALS READY MIX
CONCRETE COMPANY. PARA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WELCOME SIR.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN MARTUCCI.
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DAN RICHARD I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR HERE TODAY. OB I JUST
A MISTER CHAIRMAN I WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE MAKE JUST A VERY FEW
REMARKS AND CERTAINLY BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM YOU
OR THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
ON A SENATOR BELL SAID JOB THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROGRAM IS.
IS THE NATION'S LARGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM OUT WE
ARE VERY AWARE EVERY DAY THAT WE
WERE THE STEWARDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
THIS INCLUDES NOT ONLY THE.
FEDERAL MONIES THAT CAME TO US
THROUGH THE THE RIPPED THROUGH
THE STIMULUS ACT BUT AT THIS
POINT.
WE'VE DRAWN DOWN SOME OF THE
STATE BOND MONIES UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE A. A AND.
BECAUSE OF ACTIONS OF.
THIS LEGISLATURE AT THE REQUEST
OF THE GOVERNOR OUT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO FUNDS UNDER THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AND WORK
SPENDING THOSE SO THERE ARE.
PUBLIC DOLLARS INVOLVED HERE OF
VERY LARGE MAGNITUDE AND WE
RECOGNIZE OF THE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY. OF THIS BODY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE
SPENT IN THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY
TO ACCOMPLISH SHAUNA THE
OBJECTIVES. AND AND SO I'M HERE
TO SAY THAT A WE WILL BE FULLY
COOPERATIVE.
AS WE HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST WE
WILL BE FULLY COOPERATIVE WITH
THIS AUDIT REQUEST WE WILL NOT
WORK WITH THE AUDITOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE A. A AS OPENLY AND AS.
AS EFFECTIVELY AS WE CAN.
AND I'D LIKE TO JUST STEP OUT
FOR A MOMENT JAM UNDERSCORE THAT
POINT BY EMPHASIZING THREE
THINGS.
OP I WAS APPOINTED TO THIS
POSITION IN TWENTY ELEVEN AND IN
EARLY TWENTY TWELVE I BECAME.
THE BOARD CHAIR ARE ABOUT TWO
DAYS BEFORE I BECAME THE BOARD
CHAIR. THOUGHT IT WAS REPORTED
THAT.
THE AUDITOR GENERAL WAS HIGHLY
CRITICAL OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY BECAUSE.
TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
BY THE STATE AUDITOR HAD BID
IGNORED COMPLETELY BY THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY FOR TWO
YEARS.
AND I I PLEDGE THAT AS SOON AS
WE ARE TOOK OVER MY VERY FIRST
ACT UPON IT A ASSUMING THE GAVEL
WAS TO CREATE A FINANCE AND
AUDIT COMMITTEE OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL GOVERNING BOARD. ARE
IN CHARGE OF THAT COMMITTEE IS
THE RETIRED VICE CHAIRMAN OF
BANK OF AMERICA.
IT'S A VERY SERIOUS COMMITTEE
OF THEIR WORK IS UP OPEN AND
PUBLIC THEIR MEETINGS ARE OPEN
IN PUBLIC AND THEIR DOCUMENTS
ARE ON OUR WEBSITE. ARE I
pOR FIVE MONTHS THAT ALL BUT ONE
OF THOSE AUDITOR OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN FULLY
IMPLEMENTED BY THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY IN THE ONE THAT
WAS AND IT WAS AGREED. WAS
OUTSIDE OUR PURVIEW BECAUSE IT
RELATED TO THE PEER REVIEW
GROUP.
A WE WERE VERY SERIOUS.
IN HOW WE ADDRESS THAT.
AND. TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
AUDIT.
.
THE BOOK KILL WE WOULD HOPE THAT
IT SHOWS THAT THERE PROCESSES
AND PROCEDURES THAT WE'VE PUT IN
PLACE ARE STRONG AND PROTECTIVE
OF THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
BUT WERE HUMAN BEINGS AND IF WE
HAVE NOT BEEN PERFECT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE ARE.
DEFICIENCIES THAT ARE FOUND
WEAKNESSES ARE AREAS THAT NEED
IMPROVEMENT WE WILL IMMEDIATELY
AN AGGRESSIVELY MOVE TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE THAT IS MY
PLEDGE TO YOU MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND HER COLLEAGUES.
ACROSS THE LEGISLATURE.
I DO WANT TO TELL YOU THAT.
WE HAVE AN INTERNAL AUDIT
FUNCTION.
WE VERY ACTIVELY EVERY YEAR OUR
AUDIT.
ACROSS OUR ORGANIZATION UNDER
OUR STRUCTURE WHICH I TRIED TO
SET UP TO MIMIC ESSENTIALLY A
CORPORATE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
ABOUT AUDIT FUNCTION REPORTS NOT
THROUGH OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
BUT DIRECTLY TO THE BOARD. WHICH
IS APPROPRIATE
SO ARM.
I'M.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT TIME ARE
THERE BEEN OTHER AUDITS HAVE
BEEN DONE EXTERNAL IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE CONGRESS THE UNITED
STATES DIRECTED AN AUDIT.
THROUGH THE GOVERNMENTAL
ACCOUNTABILITY OF OFFICE.
THAT WAS AN EXTENSIVE AUDIT OF
OUR COST ESTIMATION OF PRACTICES
AND PROCEDURES AT THAT TIME. ARE
AND I THINK I'M FAIRLY
CHARACTERIZING IT TO SAY THAT OF
THE GAO AUDIT AT THAT POINT AT
THAT POINT.
FOUND THAT ARE COST ESTIMATION
PROCEDURES AND OTHER PROCEDURES
WERE REASONABLE AND CONSISTENT
WITH OUR FEDERAL BEST PRACTICES.
HOWEVER.
STARTING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE'VE
BEEN AN EXTENSIVE CONSTRUCTION
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY. ARE
THERE ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF CONTRACTS
UNDERWAY RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES INVOLVED
THERE ARE MAJOR CONTRACTORS
THERE HAVE BEEN CHANGE ORDERS.
THERE HAS BEEN COST GROWTH AND
I'D AND I SAY SITTING HERE TODAY
THAT I THINK THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE TIME. OFF OR THIS
BODY TO OUGHT TAKE A SNAPSHOT
LOOK AT.
OUT HOW WE'RE DOING ON AND AS I
SAID TO THE EXTENT WE'RE DOING
WELL WILL BE PLEASED OUGHT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE IMPROVEMENT. ARE YOU HAVE OUR
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT.
AS QUICKLY AND THOROUGHLY AS
POSSIBLE. THINKING VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
STARTING WITH MISTER OBERNOLTE.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
A QUESTION FOR MISS HOW.
SO.
WHEREIN THE VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION ONE AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT ONE OF THE ASSURANCES THAT
WAS GIVEN TO THEM WAS THAT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY WOULD
BE CAPABLE OF OPERATING LARGELY
WITHOUT SUBSIDY ONCE IT HAD BEEN
CONSTRUCTED.
SO.
A IN THE OUTLINE OF YOUR AUDIT
YOU MENTIONED.
EVALUATING DIFFERENT ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES WITH THE AUTHORITY AND
I'M WONDERING IF THE EVALUATION
YOU KNOW WITH THE COST GROWTH
THAT HAS OCCURRED IF IF
EVALUATING WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
A REASONABLE ASSURANCE STILL IN
OTHER WORDS IF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY. WILL BE ABLE TO
OPERATE WITHOUT OP TAXPAYER
SUBSIDY WHENIT'S COMPLETE IF
THAT'S PART OF THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDIT THAT IS BEING PROPOSED.
R. MISTER OBERNOLTE I WOULDN'T
SEE THAT IN THE CURRENT SCOPE OF
THE AUDIT WHEN WORK WHEN WERE
CONSIDERING ECONOMIC IMPACT IT'S
MORE AT MY PERSPECTIVE ARE END
DOING THE ANALYSIS WOULD STAFF
IS. LOOKING AT THE ECONOMIC THE
POSITIVE HOPEFULLY IN MOST CASES
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE IT'S
CURRENTLY BEING CONSTRUCTED AND
AND CERTAINLY AND FUTURE PHASES
OF ON HIGH SPEED RAIL SO WE
WEREN'T NECESSARILY LOOKING AT
WE HAVE LOOKED AT THAT IN THE
PAST WHEN WE'VE LOOKED AT. THE
BUSINESS PLAN FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY THE FIRST AUDIT
THAT WE DID OPT SEVERAL YEARS
AGO NOW LOOKED AT THE BUSINESS
PLAN AND LOOKED AT. FINANCING
WHAT WERE THE EXPECTATIONS AS
FAR AS FEDERAL MONEY COMING AND
THE RIDERSHIP ARE HOW MUCH.
THE FUNDING THAT WOULD BE
GENERATED REVENUE GENERATED FROM
RIDERSHIP WOULD HELP PAY FOR THE
SYSTEM PARTICULAR MAINTENANCE
OPERATIONS ONGOING I DON'T SEE
THAT IN THE. CURRENT SCOPE AND
OBJECTIVES THIS IS MORE ABOUT
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT CHANGE
ORDERS AND THEN. CONTRACTING
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES THE
BENEFITS THAT HAVE BEEN DERIVED
FROM THAT NOT NECESSARILY
WHETHER OR NOT.
AND THE SYSTEM WILL BE.
WILL NOT NEED SUBSIDIES FROM
EITHER STATER OR FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT.
OKAY FAULT BUT I'M NOT TRYING TO
BE CYNICAL BUT IF IT SEEMS LIKE
A SELF FULFILLING PROPHECY FOR
ACT ASKING WHETHER OR NOT. A
LARGE MATTER CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES CAN HAVE A POSITIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL GOES
THROUGHOUT THAT THE ANSWER IS
CLEARLY YES AND MAYBE QUITE
QUANTIFY. HOW MUCH
SO KNOW EVER I DON'T THINK I
WOULD BE ALONE IN OPINING THAT
IF WE'RE GOING TO UNDERTAKEN
AUDIT? THEN LET'S BE THOROUGH
AND LET'S AUDIT THE OVERALL
IMPACT ECONOMICALLY ON
CALIFORNIA AND I'D BE VERY
ENTRUSTED IN.
AN EVALUATION OF THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT HIGH SPEED RAIL
WILL BE CAPABLE OF OPERATING
WITHOUT TAXPAYER SUBSIDY WHEN
IT'S COMPLETE. GIVEN THE RECENT
COST OVERRUNS SO I COMEY SHIP
THAT TO MISTER RICHARD.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THE THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS AND THOSE ASSURANCES
THAT WERE GIVEN AND WHETHER OR
NOT THAT CONTINUES TO BE THE
CASE HARM YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I AM HAPPY TO DO THAT.
A FIRST JOB.
AS YOU NOTED THE BOND ACT A
REQUIRES THAT.
AND AND WE HAVE THIS CLEARLY IN
MIND EVERY DAY THAT THE SYSTEM
MUST BE SELF SUSTAINING AND
OPERATE WITHOUT AN OPERATING
SUBSIDY.
AYE WILL POINT OUT.
THAT DUMB OUT WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW OF DEVELOPING
OUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN WHICH IS TO BE DELIVERED TO
THIS BODY THIS SPRING. ARE AND
WE HAVE JUST WORKED WITH THE OUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS HOUSE OUGHT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TIMING IN
WHICH WE DELIVER THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
THAT BUSINESS PLAN MUST BY
STATUTE ADDRESS THIS QUESTION
THAT YOU'RE RAISING AND SO ON.
WHETHER.
THIS BODY DECIDES TO INCLUDE
THAT IN THE AUDIT OR NOT.
IS UP TO YOU BUT TO IT WILL BE
BEFORE YOU IN THE FORM OF OUR
BUSINESS PLAN AND ARE THERE ARE
OUTSIDE PEER REVIEW EXPERTS TO
LOOK AT THAT A QUESTION. AS PART
OF THEIR ANALYSIS OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN THEY'LL BE MAKING
THEIR FINDINGS THAT THEY REPORT
TO YOU BASICALLY UNDER THE
STATUTE. AND SO ARE THERE WILL
BE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS I'M I'M NOT OBJECTING
TO ANY ADDITIONAL PATHWAYS
BECAUSE.
IT GOES TO THE HEART OF THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROGRAM. IS
ULTIMATELY BENEFICIAL FOR THE
STATE IF IT CAN SELF SUSTAIN ITS
OPERATION. THAT'S ALSO THE BASIS
THAT YOU KNOW AS A BUSINESSMAN
AS HOW WE WOULD RAISE PRIVATE
SECTOR REVENUES BASED ON THE.
THAT THE RESULTS OF OPERATIONS
SO IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
AND WE SHOULD BE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH THE BUSINESS
PLANNER THE AUDIT. IT IS UP TO
YOU.
WELL THANK YOU HAVE A VERY
RESPONSIVE ARE.
I WOULD URGE THIS BODY TO
CONSIDER. INCLUDING THAT IN THE
SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT AND I'M NOT
OUT OF ANY DISTRUST NECESSARILY
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
BUT MORE OUT OF A DESIRE TO SEE
AN INDEPENDENT SET OF EYES.
CAST SOME LIGHT ON THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO DO
AN AUDIT LET'S DO A THOROUGH ON
IT AND WHAT'S MAKE SURE THE WE
PUT ALL OF THESE QUESTIONS TO
BED.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
ANSWER.
THANK YOU MS.
IS BAKER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
TWO QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENT SO
IN THE QUESTION FIRST ONE AND
THEY'RE A FOR THE AUDITOR.
IT FOLLOWS UP ON OUR COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW THOROUGH THE
OUT IT COULD BE BECAUSE WE
REALLY. WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
NOT SETTING FORTH AN AUDIT THAT
NOT ONLY HAS A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION BUT JEN'S UP.
ONLY ONE SIDE . AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL CAN HAVE A
LOCAL COMMUNITY WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN TELLING THAT IT'S
IT'S HAVING A REAL IMPACT.
.
DOES DUTY BOUND MODERATE DOES
THE AUDITOR'S WRITTEN GIVE YOU
THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT. NOT JUST
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT IT'S HAVING
BUT THOSE DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
SPENT ARE NOT BEING SPENT
ELSEWHERE.
SO WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SPENDING THE DOLLARS
IN THE ABSOLUTE BEST WAY WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
AND AND GETTING THE BEST RETURN
FOR TAXPAYER DOLLARS NOW. ARE I
IN THAT SPIRIT OF ONE MAKE SURE
IT'S A THOROUGH AUDIT.
WONDER IF YOU HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO NOT JUST LOOK AT
HERE'S HOW MANY JOBS HAVE BEEN
CREATED HERE'S THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY AS A RESULT OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FLEXIBILITY OR
FREEDOM OR.
METHODOLOGY OR YOU COULD SAY
AND HERE'S WHERE COULD HAVE BEEN
SPENT FOR THIS WAS THE BEST WAY
TO SPEND THOSE DOLLARS BECAUSE
THAT'S EVEN MORE VALUABLE TO US
AS A. AS A BODY.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
.
THAT AS I INDICATED. IN THE AND
THE SCOPE IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE CONTEMPLATED IN
THE SCOPE OF THE OUGHT RIGHT
NOW.
CERTAINLY WE COULD LOOK AT THE
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT AND
AS MISTER RICHARDS INDICATED
THERE SOME CAP AND TRADE MONEY.
AND CERTAINLY THERE'S POLICY
DECISIONS AS TO WHAT.
CAPTAIN TRADE MONEY COULD BE
USED FOR I THINK WHAT WE WOULD
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO IN THIS.
AUDIT IS LOOK AT HOW THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IS USING
THE VARIOUS SOURCES OF FUNDING
AND THE BENEFIT THAT'S BEING
DERIVED FROM THAT I DON'T THINK
WE COULD NECESSARILY. APPLYING
OR MAKE A DETERMINATION WELL
THAT MONEY WOULD HAVE BETTER
BEEN BETTER SPENT FIXING ROADS
OUR BRIDGES OR WHATEVER OR
INVESTING IN SOME OTHER.
POLICY AREA ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S CALLED
FOR IN THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT
BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN LOOK AT THE
FUNDING THAT THE AUTHORITY IS
USING AND HOW IS THAT MONEY
BEING INVESTED IN CALIFORNIA AND
IS THERE. AN ECONOMIC BENEFIT
SHORT TERM AND CERTAINLY LONG
TERM OKAY WHAT WOULD WOULD.
A I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT I I
ENCOURAGE US AS A BODY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONSIDER THAT AS
WELL. WHICH IS THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY COST FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT IS SPENT AND YOU
HAVE GOT A VERY LONG LIST OF
OTHER TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THAT WE COULD BE HAVING A GREAT
RETURN ON THE DEPTH OF MOBILITY
AND QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
AND THOSE DOLLARS ARE GONNA GO
TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
SO I THINK THAT'S A LENS
THROUGH WHICH WE NEED TO DO THAT
I WISH THEY OUGHT TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
THAT.
ALSO ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS
BECAUSE WE DO HEAR A LOT ABOUT
HIGH SPEED RAIL HAVING THE
POTENTIAL THESE FROM ITS
ADVOCATES.
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS A TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES AND YOU HAVE A
POSITIVE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
I'D LIKE YOU TO ADDRESS MORE HOW
YOUR GOING TO BE EQUIPPED TO
DETERMINES THAT THOSE.
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ARE REAL
PARTICULAR WITH RESPECT TO
GREENHOUSE GASES AND THAT IT IS
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
I THAT IS HAVING THAT POSITIVE
IMPACT IF THERE IS ONE AND NOT
OTHER.
FACTORS THAT CAN WAY AND BECAUSE
WE ARE AS A STATE RIGHTLY SO
TACKLING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND I THINK
AGGRESSIVELY WE NEED TO CONTINUE
DOING THAT. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T ASCRIBE TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT
MAY HAVE HAD NO CAUSAL
CONNECTION.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT PLEASE
CERTAINLY THERE'S AN OBJECTIVE
IN THE AUDIT.
ANALYSIS THAT TALKS ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY AND CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND THAT
THE WAY TO THE OBJECTIVE RIGHT
NOW IS CRAFTED IS TO START WITH
THE AUTHORITIES EFFORTS TO
EVALUATE TO WE WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT. WE MAY NEED
TO HIRE AN EXPERT TO ASSIST US
IN THE* AND ALSO DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN ISOLATE
THEY ECONOMIC I MEAN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL WILL BRING TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE YOU
ABLE TO AS OR IS THE STATE OR
THE AUTHORITY ABLE TO. ISOLATE
THAT IMPACT AND IF THEY THEY'RE
CLAIMING TO THEN HAVE SOMEONE
ASSIST US IN DOING AN ANALYSIS
THAT TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
EVALUATION IS.
REASONABLE OP I THINK THAT IS
THE APPROACH THAT WE WOULD TAKE
AT THIS POINT TIME.
FOR THAT PARTICULAR OBJECTIVE
OKAY BECAUSE I I I THINK THAT'S
GONNA BE CRITICAL ON THAT FOR IN
ORDER FOR THIS TO HAVE A RESULT
AT THE END THAT IS USEFUL TO US.
AND HERE'S HERE'S WHAT WE NEED
TO DO FOR CALIFORNIA AND HERE'S
THE POSITIVE IMPACT HAS IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT. YOU HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO THAT AND I
ENCOURAGE IT. AND THAT THOSE OF
THE TWO QUESTIONS BUT ALSO JUST
THE COMET.
.
EVERY RED FLAG YOU COULD
POSSIBLY RAISE ABOUT A PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT.
IS REYES WHEN IT COMES TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND IT'S NOT THROUGH.
A BAD ACTORS IT'S IT'S JUST A
FACT WHETHER IT'S COST OVERRUNS
CHANGE ORDERS IN THE COSTS THAT
THEY'VE HAD FOR THE PROJECT.
AND THE LITIGATION IMPACTS AND
OTHERWISE SO I I'M PLEASED TO
SEE A AND AUDIT THAT IS
BEGINNING TO TACKLE THE SOME OF
THAT. AND I JUST WANNA APPLY OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING. A
UNIQUE BIPARTISANSHIP TO THIS
REQUEST THAT WE DON'T OFTEN SEE
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL. IT'S
ALARMING THE RED FLAGS THAT GET
REYES WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
HOW MANY AUDITS HAVE DIED IN
THIS COMMITTEE. AND EFFORTS IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THAT
FAIRLY AND I REALLY APPLAUD OUR
COLLEAGUES IN BRINGING A BI
PARTISANSHIP I TO THIS I WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS. AUDIT AND
HOPE THAT WE WILL MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS BASED ON IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO FORWARD
TO LET ME REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE DO HAVE A.
COMMITTEE ROLE THAT.
AT THE TIME THE HEARING IN
AUDIT REQUEST MAY ONLY BE
AMENDED IF THE AMENDMENT DOES
NOT SUBSTANTIALLY AFFECT THE.
FEASIBILITY SCOPE OR COST OF THE
PROPOSED AUDIT.
UNLESS.
.
THE.
REQUEST YOUR WISHES TO
SUBSTANTIALLY AMANDA REQUEST.
.
THAT REQUEST YOUR MAY ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO HOLD THE REQUEST
UNTIL THE NEXT COMMITTEE HEARING
AND I SEE SANDRA BELL FROWNING
THERE.
CHAIRMAN.
QUICK.
BUT I. THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UP TO RESPOND TO US.
THE BI PARTISANSHIP HERE THE
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
RAISED.
WHAT WE ARE ALL TRYING TO DO?
IS TO GET PAST ALL OF THE NOISE
TO GET PAST ALL OF THE POLITICS.
TO GET DOWN INTO A THOROUGH
AUDIT THAT IS GOING TO GIVE US A
VERY GOOD HEADS UP. AS TO WHAT
IS IT IS THAT'S WHAT IS COMING
AND WHAT HAS.
HAS HAPPENED.
IN A BIPARTISAN WAY WE HAVE MADE
AN UNDERSTANDING WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
AND WE WILL KEEP TO THAT
UNDERSTANDING.
HOWEVER I NEED TO POINT OUT THAT
AS THE CHAIRMAN HAS MENTIONED
AND. NOT TO PUT.
WORDS IN HIS MOUTH AT ALL.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
SERIOUS
PERIOD OF TIME
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THE AUDIT HELPS US GET THERE.
I WILL BE LOOKING.
GENUINELY
FOR THIS BUSINESS PLAN WITH NEW
LEADERSHIP.
BECAUSE FOR ME THE BIG QUESTION
HERE IS.
WITH THE COST.
EXPLODING.
AND THE FINANCES FINITE.
IS THERE ENOUGH MONEY.
A COMPLETE
FROM CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
I INTO THE SILICON VALLEY I I
THINK THERE ARE SOME REAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
AND SO YES THE AUDIT DOES HAVE
SOME OF ADDRESS SOME OF THAT.
BUT I DO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
FACT THAT THERE WILL BE WITH NEW
EXECUTIVES AND WITH NEW.
.
A AT THE END OF A NEW LOOK.
BY THOSE NEW EXECUTIVES.
FOR THIS BUSINESS PLAN.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
REAL OPPORTUNITY.
TO TAKE A GOOD HARD LOOK AT THAT
BUSINESS PLAN.
AND I AM HOPING AND I BELIEVE.
THAT THERE WILL BE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT.
TO DEMONSTRATE WHETHER YOU CAN
OR CANNOT GET INTO SAN JOSE.
THIS IS FOR FOR CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A LOT AT
STAKE HERE.
A. BROTHER YOU'RE FOR IT OR
AGAINST IT A YEAR AGO YOU'RE AT
NONCOMMITTAL THE WORST THING
THAT CAN POSSIBLY HAPPEN IS IF
THE BUT IF WE WITH WE STARTED IN
A FIELD OUTSIDE BAKERSFIELD AND
ENDED. IN A FIELD OUTSIDE MERCED
SO COMPLETION REALLY DOES BRING
THE FULL FRUITS OF.
OF WHAT WE A ARE ARE HEARING
HERE FROM THIS BIPARTISAN
GROUP SO I'M REALLY GOING TO
LOOK FORWARD TO DIGGING IN I'M
GONNA ASK MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL
TO TAKE A GOOD.
THE EFFORT WHEN WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO REVIEW THAT BUSINESS
PLAN TO REALLY ASK THE QUESTION
DOES THIS GET COMPLETED. WITH
THE EXISTING FUNDS
BECAUSE IF IT DOES NOT.
THIS BODY AND.
THE GOVERNOR AND OTHERS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE A GOOD
HARD LOOK.
AT WHETHER OR NOT ADDITIONAL
MONEY IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
REQUESTED FROM THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER.
CENTER BALLOTS THIS IN RESPONSE
TO OKAY I'D LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE TO KEEP THEIR COMMENTS
FOCUSED ON THE REQUEST
A FOREIGN SO THOUSAND.
I THINK THAT DAUM.
THE BUSINESS PLAN.
THE AUDIT ARE ALL INTERRELATED.
THE AUDIT WILL DEAL WITH.
JUST OF THE A QUICK.
LOOK AT.
THE EXISTING COST BENEFIT THE
THE THE COST OF THE PROJECTS
FOCUSING ON A PARTICULAR
PROBLEM.
OF OF EFFICIENCY AND BUILDING
THE PROJECT ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET.
WE HAVE TO FOCUS THE AUTHORED ON
THAT THAT'S WHY THE AUDIT WAS
FOCUSED ON.
BUILDING THE PROJECT ON TIME AND
ON BUDGET.
ONCE WE GET THE AUDIT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN.
THAT SAID. WE HAVE THE BUSINESS
PLAN AND WE CAN SUBSEQUENTLY
ASKED FOR ADDITIONAL RESEARCH
AND AUDITS AND. OTHER STUDIES
THAT.
WILL THEN AFTER WE DO THIS THIS
AUDIT. LOOK AT.
.
A PROCESS THAT WE COULD SET UP
IF WE WANT TO PUT IT THAT WAY.
TO CONTINUOUSLY AUDIT AND GET
RECOMMENDATIONS.
FROM INDEPENDENT SOURCES.
AS WE GO ALONG WITH THE PROJECT
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT TO OF
THE ECONOMICS OF THIS.
.
ATTENTION ALL IS IS IMMENSE.
ARM.
I REPRESENT SILICON VALLEY.
SILICON VALLEY IS WATCHING THIS
PROJECT.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO LOCATE LE. OF
HIGH TECH FACILITIES AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THEY SEE.
HUGE ASSET.
AND NAM AND I HATE TO SAY THIS
BUT DOM. BEEN ASSEMBLY STATE
STUDENT.
OF FRESNO STATE HAS OF WONDERFUL
OF SCHOOL OF ENGINEERING AND
BUSINESS DEPARTMENT.
AND I KNOW THAT WE CAN HAVE A
BULLDOG SPARTAN ALLIANCE.
WITH HIS PROJECT RIGHT.
THE ARE AND WE WE WERE GOOD
FRIENDS WEEK WAIT WE.
WE LOVE THAT.
RED.
TIDE COMING TO SAN JOSE AREA
EVERY OTHER YEAR.
BUT.
THERE IS A A SANERGY IN
ECONOMICS.
AND THE BUSINESS SENSE.
OF CONNECTING SILICON VALLEY.
WITH THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND.
THERE IS A POTENTIAL FOR.
THE GROWTH OF THE ECONOMY THAT'S
IMMENSE.
AND.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT APPLE AND.
INTEL AND.
ALL THE GREAT COMPANIES THAT WE
HAVE IN SILICON VALLEY THERE IN
MY DISTRICT.
.
IT IS IT IS IT IS IT IS A
POSSIBILITY. IT DOESN'T EXIST
UNLESS THERE'S A TRUCK.
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
DOESN'T.
IT HASN'T EXIST IN THE PAST I
WON'T EXIST IN THE FUTURE.
UNLESS WE HAVE IT ADEQUATE.
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
SO I THINK I THINK THE ECONOMY.
ECONOMICS.
OBVIOUSLY DRIVES RIDERSHIP.
AND RIDERSHIP DRIVES THE
OPERATIONAL.
HIM IMPACT IN TERMS OF.
COST PER RIDER AND IN TERMS OF.
.
WHAT ARE NOT A SUBSIDY IS NEEDED
GO? AND SO FORTH AND I THINK.
TILL WE.
SEE THE BUSINESS PLAN
REFLECTING.
SYMBOL SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
.
THEY CAN CERTAINLY AYE I WOULD
ASK THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY.
AS OUR EX OFFICIO MEMBERS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE.
.
THAT THEY FOCUS ON BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE US THAT.
HERE THAT THE BUSINESS PLAN
MAYBE GIVE US SPECIAL ATTENTION
MAYBE HAVE SOME INDEPENDENT
REVIEW VERIFYING.
THE OPERATIONAL ASPECTS AND
SHARE IT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
MEMBERS DURING THE HEARINGS AT
THEIR UP COMING IN A COUPLE
MONTHS.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
CHAU IT'LL PROBABLY BE A RANGE.
NO BECAUSE A PROJECTS NOT TO BE
COMPLETED FOR SEVERAL YEARS WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT. THE FURTHER YOU
GET OUT.
THE IN TERMS OF FINISHING THE
PROJECT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
RANGER GOING HAVE A.
IT HAS NO IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY
AND.
THE BULLDOGS CAN'T COME TO SAN
JOSE AND THE SAN JOSE CAN'T COME
TO THE BULLDOGS. OF THAT COULD
BE THE LOW END OF THE RANGE THE
HIGH AND THE RANGE IS WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
POTENTIAL. FOR THE CONNECTION
WITH SILICON VALLEY AND.
.
THE.
YOU KNOW JUST OF FRESNO CA SO
WONDERFUL SCHOOL AND I GET IT I
THINK THEIR ACADEMIC INSTITUTION
WILL DRIVE THE.
THE ATTRACTION.
AND BAKERSFIELD STATE ALSO.
I THINK THAT I THINK I JUST
MENTIONED VEGAS FEEL SAFER
CENTER FULLER MY FRIEND. BUT.
BUT I THINK I THINK.
I THINK BOTH BOTH SCHOOLS HAVE
EXCELLENT ENGINEERING
DEPARTMENTS.
EXCELLENT THIRD THEIR TOP NOTCH.
AND THEY'RE SUCH A GREAT
POTENTIAL THAT WE ARE THAT WE
ARE THAT WE OUGHT EXAMINED.
IT IT JUST STOOD IT JUST.
IT IT'LL BE A RANGE THOUGH.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR MR
ACOSTA.
WELL THE CENTER LEFT OUT.
THE MATADORS A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE.
WHICH IT WHICH HAS A WONDERFUL
A PROGRAM YOU COULD KEEP GOING
AND THEY'LL WE GOT WE GOT A
GREAT S. C. ISSUE AND UC SYSTEM
AS WE ALL KNOW. AND A AND
APPRECIATE OKAY WHEN WE KNEW. WE
GET POSTER  POSTERS IN HERE
OKAY SO.
.
TO MY COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE STE
POINT I'M I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR AND HAVE A COUPLE OF
OTHER QUICK QUESTIONS AS WELL.
.
MISS HOWELL.
THE CHAIR MENTIONED A ABOUT A
RULE ABOUT AMENDING AUDITS
ETCETERA WITH THE INDULGENCE OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO BROUGHT FORTH
THE AUDIT.
BOB.
YEAH AND OF COURSE ANY WE RULE
CAN BE WAY WE JUST WAVED ONE A
LITTLE LITTLE BIT AGO ANOTHER ON
IT.
A TO A MOVE CONSENT COUNTER.
.
DO YOU SEE THE THE THE ALL THE
STE DOES TALK ABOUT.
THE.
WHETHER NOT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SELF SUSTAINING OUT ABOUT THIS
REPORT THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
INVOLVED GREED THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE REALLY NEED THIS
BUSINESS PLAN. THAT SEEMS TO ME
THAT HAS BEEN AMENDED IN NEEDS
TO BE AMENDED AGAIN.
IT WAS SOLD TO THE PUBLIC IN A
CERTAIN WAY THIS THIS YOU KNOW.
THIS PROPOSITION AND NOW IT
SEEMS LIKE WERE WERE THE OTHER
THAT THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE
AGAIN AND AND WORK GOING
BACKWARD SAYING IS THIS EVEN
VIABLE. DO YOU SEE IT POSSIBLE
UNDER THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT
WITHOUT MATERIALLY CHANGING.
THE COST THE TIME FRAME IT
CETERA.
THIS AUDIT BEING ABLE TO
ENCOMPASS WHETHER OR NOT HIGH
SPEED RAIL. AYE IS SELF
SUSTAINING AND I HAVE A. COMMENT
OR FOLLOW UP AFTER THAT.
FOR ME.
WELL AS I AS I INDICATED.
MR CUSTER WERE WITH MR ARE
OBERNOLTE QUESTION IT IT ISN'T
CONTEMPLATED IN THE CURRENT
SCOPE AND OBJECTIVES.
IT WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
OBJECTIVE BOMB I THINK WHAT WE
WOULD NEED TO DO AND MISTER
RICHARD I THINK INDICATED THE
BUSINESS PLAN WAS COMING OUT IN
APRIL OR MAY PERHAPS. IT WOULD
BE ADDITIONAL WORK THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO DO OVER AND ABOVE WHAT'S
IN HERE. DETERMINING WHETHER OR%
NOT IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE
IT'S IT'S.
A NEW OBJECTIVE.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE YOU. KNOW
WOULD NEED TO DECIDE IF THAT'S
SOMETHING AND MEMBER. WANTED TO
AMEND IT.
.
WE CERTAINLY COULD LOOK AT THE
BUSINESS PLAN BUT IF YOU WANTED
US TO DO YOU ANALYSIS SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DID IN OUR PRIOR AUDIT.
THAT WAS THIS. A FAIR AMOUNT OF
WORK AS FAR AS LOOKING AT THE
BUSINESS PLAN AYE UNDERSTANDING
THE VARIOUS FUNDING SOURCES
BECAUSE THE CONCERN WE HAD IN
THE IN THE FIRST AND IT WAS
THEIR FIRST BUSINESS PLAN WAS.
THE RELIANCE ON PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT AS OPPOSED TO FEDERAL
MONEY COMING AND THERE WAS
FEDERAL MONEY THAT WAS PROPOSED
BUT AT THAT POINT IT REALLY THE
ONLY FEDERAL MONEY THAT WAS
INVESTED THAT POINT TIME WAS.
THROUGH THE RECOVERY ACT WITH I
THINK A COUPLE. MAYBE A COUPLE
BILLION OR I DON'T REMEMBER HOW
WHAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNT WAS BUT
IT WAS LIMITED AS FAR AS FEDERAL
MONEY THERE WAS QUESTIONED AS TO
HOW MUCH. PRIVATE SECTOR MONEY
WOULD BE INVESTED SO THERE
REALLY WAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF RELIANCE AT THAT POINT AND
TIME. ON THE BOND MONEY AND STE
AND STATE FUND SO WE WOULD NEED
TO DO.
TOGETHER AT THAT QUESTION AND
TO DO A FAIR ANALYSIS.
I THINK IT.
A FAIRLY SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
HOURS WOULD NEED TO BE ADDED TO
THE AUDIT TO REALLY TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT THE BUSINESS PLAN AND
ENGAGE WITH. THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY TO UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
CAME UP WITH THEIR NEW. PLAN.
YA PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
FINANCING FOR THE SYSTEM AND
THEN THEIR EVENTUAL.
GOAL OF HAVING IT BE SELF
SUSTAINING. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT.
WELL AGAIN IT'S THE COMMITTEES
YET IT IS THE COMMITTEE'S
PURVIEW AND AND AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THIS SHOULD BE ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS THAT WE
ASK.
IN THIS PROCESS BECAUSE THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY THIS FAR IN A
MINUTE DECADE VIRTUALLY INTO
THIS.
YOU KNOW THE PROPOSITION IN THE
FUNDING STARTING TO ROLL OUT ITS
CETERA THAT WERE. WE LOOKING ITS
MASSIVE COST OVERRUNS AND DELAYS
AND WEARING THEEASIEST PART OF
THE CONSTRUCTION IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION NOT BEING INSTRUCTION
MAGNET HERE.
BUT IT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT ALL
THE REPORTS ALL THE STUDIES
INDICATE THEY SHOULD BE THIS THE
I UNDERSTAND THIS BEEN LAWSUITS
AND THERE'S BEEN DELAYS ETCETERA
I AND THAT'S JUST. PART AND
PARCEL BUT.
WE HAVE AN A EVEN APPROACH THE
TO HATCH BEACH YET TO GET IT TO
LA WHICH IS WHICH IS BY THE WAY
A COMMITMENT OF.
THE PROPOSITION.
AND THAT IS SELF SUSTAINING AND
IT'S GOING TO MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS IN THESE
REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
AND IF YOU LOOK AT FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT. THEY'LL TELL YOU
THEY'RE NOT GONNA DRIVE SOUTH
HALF AN HOUR AND LITERALLY
BYPASS BURBANK AIRPORT AND THE
MULTIPLE AIRLINES THAT ARE
COMPETITIVE THERE.
TO GET ON A TRAIN AND AND GO
NORTH WHEN THEY CAN JUST BE ON A
PLANE IN AN HOUR AND AND THAT'S
THAT'S A THAT'S A SUBJECT FOR
ANOTHER DEBATE BUT IT'S PART AND
PARCEL WITH. THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE'RE HAVING HERE BECAUSE THE
POLICY DECISIONS THE WEATHER
FUTURE. GOT CAP AND TRADE MONEY
IS IT IS IS IS ALLOCATED IS
INFLUENCED.
YOU KNOW.
BY ALL THE ASPECTS OF THE
ECONOMIC DATA AND THAT'S A BIG
THE WITHOUT ONE OF THIS IS IF WE
ALL KNEW IN THIS BODY.
AN ART IRRESPECTIVE CHAMBERS
THAT THIS WAS GOING I'M JUST
PULLING NUMBERS OUT OF THING AIR
THIS IS GOING TO REQUIRE FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR YEAR SUBSIDY OR
ONE BILLION DOLLAR YOUR SUBSIDY
OR. IT'LL MAKE MONEY THOSE WILL
INFLUENCE WHETHER OR NOT WE USE
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS NOW TO GET
THIS CONSTRUCTED FOR A FUTURE
BENEFIT. I THINK IT'S SELF
EVIDENT IS THAT ARE EVEN MENTION
ABOUT THE BUSINESSES BEING IN
THOSE AREAS AND GOD BLESS ON MY
I HAVE FAMILY AND FRIENDS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW THEY IT'S
GREAT THAT THEY'RE GOING WELL.
SORTIR DEAR BUSINESS BUT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A POLICY
DECISION THAT AFFECTS THE ENTIRE
PART OF THE STATE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NOT JUST ONE PIECE
OF IT NOT JUST SILICON VALLEY.
ARE NOT JUST THE SPARTANS THE
BULLDOG SCENE OF MAYBE THE
BOOSTER CLUBS CAN TAKE UP AND BY
A TRAIN HERE BUT.
YOU WORK WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW I
FRANKLY LIKE TO SEE IN AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT THIS THE
SCOPE NEEDS TO BE TWEAKED IF
THEY'RE IF THEY'RE ASO
INDULGENT.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD REALLY.
ENCOURAGE ME TO SUPPORT IT I I
HAVE TO BE SUPPORTIVE ANYWAY
BUT.
THAT I SHOULDN'T TAKE MY HAND.
THIS REALLY SHOULD BE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE.
NOW AUDIT THAN WHAT I SEE NOW
AND I'D BE VERY.
A BILL ALL THE TIME
DISAPPOINTED IF WE DON'T WE
DON'T ADD THAT ELEMENT TO IT
FOUND QUITE FRANKLY.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY OF PUBLIC COMMENTS.
ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THIS MATTER PLEASE
COME FORWARD. SEEING NO ONE
RUSHED FORWARD.
ALRIGHT.
.
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
REQUEST YEARS OF THIS AUDIT TO
TO.
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS AND
AND PERHAPS IF YOU'D LIKE TO.
ADDRESS THE.
.
REQUESTS MADE BY A SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO.
POTENTIALLY.
AS HE AUDIT LARGER CHARACTERIZE
ADDING ANOTHER OBJECTIVE TO THE
AUDIT REQUEST.
.
OR NOT OF PLEASED TO ADDRESS
THAT ALSO.
STARTING WITH THE DELETE REQUEST
FOR CENTER BELL
WELL I THINK OF OF THEM.
AGUILA I URGE SUPPORT FOR THE
AUDIT SO THIS OF BIPARTISAN
REQUEST AND.
DETAILS OF THIS REQUESTED THAT
WORKED OUT IN A BIPARTISAN
FASHION.
WE WILL RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS
ON.
.
BUSINESS PLAN AND.
HAVE.
.
IN ABOUT TWO MONTHS.
QUICKER THAN THE AUDITS.
RESULTS FROM AND.
OF INFORMATION REGARDING THE.
OPERATING OUT FEASIBILITY OF THE
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AFTER THAT OUGHT TO ONE THE
AUDITS COMPLETED IF WE WANT TO
ADD SOMETHING. DOWN THE ROAD WE
CAN DO THAT THAT'S WHERE I WOULD
LIKE TO PROPOSE.
WE HANDLE THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE.
OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
TOM AS I SAID IS STATED.
EARLIER.
OF THE NATURE OF BIPARTISANSHIP
IS THAT. NOBODY GETS THE WHOLE
LOT OF.
AND THAT THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT
IS.
OUR I I WANT TO SAY I THINK
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
WITH THE AUDIT AND THEN AND
ENCOURAGE. THAT OUT OF A SUPPORT
VOTE STUFF FOR IT.
AT AND I THINK ALSO THE.
.
OBVIOUS REALISATION OF EVERYBODY
HERE THAT WE'RE IN A SIGNIFICANT
ERA WITH RESPECT TO THIS
PROJECT.
AND THIS AUDIT AND THE BUSINESS
PLANNING AND OUR. OVERSIGHT
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
GOING FORWARD IN THIS YEAR WILL
HAVE TO BE VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON
A LOT OF THE DEPTH AT. DEEP
QUESTIONS.
MY SUGGESTION IS THAT WE WILL.
OPEN THIS AUDIT ACCORDING TO
THE SCOPE WE HAVE AGREED TO THAT
SCOPE AND THE AUDITOR HAS A
STERLING REPUTATION. OF GETTING
TO THE TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCOPES THAT THAT THAT THAT SHE
AUDITS WE APPRECIATE THAT. WE
HAVE COMMITMENTS HERE FROM THE
HIGH SPEED.
RAIL A LEADERSHIP THAT THIS
BUSINESS PLAN WILL IN FACT
ADDRESS.
AS DEEPLY ANEST THAT COMPLETELY
AS POSSIBLE.
REALLY WHAT I THINK IS THE BIZ
THE BIG
QUESTION IN THE ROOM.
IS THERE FUNDS TO COMPLETE.
EVEN GET VALLEY TO VALLEY.
THAT IS UP IN THE AIR IT SEEMS
TO ME SO THIS GOING IN ONGOING.
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES WE'RE GONNA
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING. THAT
DILIGENTLY WITH RESPECT TO THE.
TO THE BUSINESS PLAN THAT AS.
THE SENATOR SUGGESTED THAT AS
WE GET INTO THE AUDIT AND AS WE
SEE THE BUSINESS PLAN THERE MAY
VERY WELL ME.
TO BE A DEEPER AND MORE A
SIGNIFICANT DIVE BUT RIGHT NOW
THIS IS. WHAT WE HAVE AGREED TO
AND I THINK WE SHOULD BE?
?
THAT CONSISTENT EL BUT WITH OUR
COMMITMENTS ONE TO ANOTHER AND
TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ACTUALLY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY MS
RUBIO AND SECONDED BY MS BAKER.
YOU KNOW I AGAIN WANT TO COMMENT
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE BIPARTISAN
NATURE OF THIS REQUEST.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US SAYS
CALIFORNIANS TO GET TO THE TRUTH
AND THIS AUDIT WILL HELP US TO
DO JUST THAT.
I HOPE AS WE LOOK AT THE AUDIT
ONE OF THE FACTORS WE LOOK AT IS
THE FACT THAT TIME IS MONEY.
AND THAT THE DELAYS AND
LITIGATIONS THEMSELVES ARE
COSTING THE AUTHORITY.
WHAT DO WE DO AS A STATE TO
ENSURE THE VIABILITY TO HELP
CREATE THE EFFICIENCIES WE NEED
WITHIN THE AUTHORITY? AND HOW WE
ARE LOOKING TO BE GOOD STEWARDS
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS MUST ALSO
MEAN THAT WE HELPED TO CREATE
SOME MOMENTUM FOR A PROJECT OF
THIS MAGNITUDE. I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE REST OF THE STATE
REALIZING THE BENEFITS THAT ARE
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW IN MY
COMMUNITY AND I INVITE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WHO ARE HERE. TO
COME AND SEE MY DISTRICT AND SEE
WHERE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS BEING
BUILT.
ALRIGHT.
I WANT TO I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
AND THANKING THE.
.
REQUEST YEARS OF THIS AUDIT.
IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER.
I THINK THIS IS I GREW WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THIS IS A.
.
A WELCOME.
DEVELOPMENT TO HAVE INDEPENDENT
NONPARTISAN AUDIT ON THE BIGGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IN THE
HISTORY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ON THAT BASIS I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES ON A BIPARTISAN.
MATTER TO SUPPORT THIS AUDIT
REQUEST.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE ZERO EIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY I.
MERCI CHEAT AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I WOULD.
WOULD I.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN.
BELL.
WELL I CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
MENDOZA.
LARA AUDITS ON CALL WE ARE SHORT
ONE VOTE AND SO THIS A REQUEST
IS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES WHY DON'T WE DO THAT YES.
SO.
WE ARE.
VETERANS ARE.
THAT'S SECOND PROHIBIT ME FROM
YOU KNOW IT DIDN'T LIKE OKAY.
I LIKE TO LIFT THE CALL ON SOME
OF THE PREVIOUS SELL ITEMS.
.
MADAM SECRETARY PHYSICO IN
ORDER.
I AM ROLL CALL TO PROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE ZERO FIVE THE CHAIR
HAS.
VOTED NO ON THE.
.
REQUESTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
SANTIAGO.
SENATOR RAW.
ALLEN.
BELL.
NO.
CANNELLA ALONE BELT NOT VOTING.
CANNELLA AYE.
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
CONTINUOUS RUN CALLED ON A
RATES.
THAT.
ITEM IS STILL ON CALL.
ANY.
.
LET'S GO THROUGH A.
AND THE ITEMS SO THAT MEMBERS
CAN ADD ON.
ROLL CALL TO SUSPEND COMMITTEE
ROLES THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN.
THIS IS FOR ADOPTING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
SENATOR BELL.
I.
CANNELLA.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENATOR CANNELLA.
I BELL.
AND.
FULLER.
HE EXPLODED FROM.
YOU GUYS ROCK.
YES ON CONSENT.
THAT ITEM.
THAT ITEM PASSED THE CONSENT OF
ONE OF.
SO WE DID THAT WAS THE
CONSECUTIVE FF EVERYTHING.
WE HAVE ONE OF THEM SHOULD.
ALRIGHT.
THAT IT IS HEARING ANYTHING ELSE
THAT.
SENATE CANNELLA IS MEANT.
OKAY ONE MORE ITEM ONE AND YES
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
ZERO SEVEN.
SENATOR.
BELL.
I.
CANNELLA.
NO I.
ALRIGHT.
MR LEVINE.
THIS IS THE LAST ITEM.
FOR HEARING.
ON THE REGULAR CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER TWO. AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE OF FOR
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
REQUESTED AUDIT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I KNOW ITS BEEN A LONG MORNING
FOR THE COMMITTEE SO I'LL KEEP
IT BRIEF ESPECIALLY BECAUSE. I
HAVE SHARED THIS AUDIT REQUEST
WITH THE COMMITTEE UP EARLIER
THIS YEAR EARLIER VERSION OF IT
AND WE HAD A VERY GOOD SUBSTANCE
DEBATE.
I THINK.
THIS WEEK WE HEARD THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS ISSUE RAISED
IN THE GOVERNOR STATE OF STATE
ADDRESS WHERE HE REFERENCE THE
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR COST OVERRUN
ON THE BAY BRIDGE AS A LAUGH
LINE.
ANDI DON'T THINK THAT IS
RESPECTFUL TO THE RATE PAYERS
THAT THE TOLL PAIRS ACROSS THE
BAY AREA BRIDGES.
I'M GLAD DIED TO BRING THIS
BACK TO YOU A IN A TIMELY MANNER
AFTER THAT AND ALSO GRATEFUL
HAVE SENATOR BILL SUPPORT. FOR
THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
ALRIGHT.
MOST MEN BEEN MADE BY SANDRA
BELL SECOND BY MISS BAKER.
MS HOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL
QUICKLY GO THROUGH THE AUDIT
OBJECTIVES ESSENTIALLY WHAT
MISTER LEVINE IS ASKING US TO
LOOK AT IS.
RECORDS RELATED TO THE BAY
BRIDGE CONSTRUCTION OF ANY COST
OVERRUNS WHAT THIS SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THOSE COST OVERRUNS
ARE WERE OR ARE ARE THERE ANY
EXISTING OBLIGATIONS THAT THEY
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PAY
INCLUDING DEBT.
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE COST
OVERRUNS HAVE AFFECTED OTHER
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
OTHER BAY ON PARTICULARLY ON
OTHER BAY AREA BRIDGES.
IS THERE ANY CONTINUED
FINANCIAL RISK AS A RESULT OF
THE CONSTRUCTION.
AND WHAT SORT OF FUNDING WILL
THEY USE TO COVER THAT RISK.
IN ADDITION ASKING US TO LOOK AT
THE DEFECTS AND WHAT THE TOTAL
COST OF THOSE DEFECTS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED BY A METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION BETA
AND CALTRANS AND AGAIN WHAT THE
SOURCE OF FUNDING IS FOR THOSE.
WHAT LESSONS LEARNS WERE DERIVED
FROM THOSE PARTICULAR?
DEFECTS AND THAT PROCESS AND
HAVE HAVE THE. ASSOCIATED
ENTITIES MTC AND CALTRANS IN
PARTICULAR MODIFIED THEIR.
PROJECTS IN THE FUTURE OR THEIR
APPROACHES TO PREVENT DEFECTS
AND CERTAINLY TO MITIGATE ANY
COST OVERRUNS AND THEN THE FINAL
TWO OBJECTIVES RELATED TO RISK
MANAGEMENT AGAIN. LOOKING TO THE
FUTURE WHAT TYPES OF RISK
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES WILL THEY
USE OR MODIFY OUR IN MAKING SURE
THAT FUTURE PROJECTS ARE STAY
WITHIN BUDGET AND THAT THE
FUNDING IS MEANT MANAGED
EFFECTIVELY. AND THEN THE LAST
OBJECTIVE IS RELATED TO THE.
TOLL BRIDGE SEISMIC RETROFIT
PROGRAM LOOKING AT HOW LONG IT
WILL TAKE TO PAY OFF ANY
EXISTING DEBT OBLIGATIONS
RELATED TO THAT PROGRAM THE
BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOURS.
THAT'S ABOUT A SIX MONTH TIME
FRAME FOR MY STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR LIVING
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES ALRIGHT.
IS THERE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE.
RESPONDING AGENCIES PLEASE COME
FOR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MERIT
SUCIA MEMBERS MY NAME IS REBECCA
ON AND I'M THE MANAGER OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR MTC AND
DATA. THEM AS WAS MENTIONED THIS
IS THE SECOND TIME I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE HAS MADE
THIS REQUEST OF MY AGENCY. AND
CALTRANS SINCE LAST YEAR WHEN HE
SUBMITTED THE ORIGINAL REQUEST
WE'VE WORKED DILIGENTLY TO
PROVIDE A DETAILED RESPONSE.
I'M AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO ASK
THE SERGEANT TO PLEASE
DISTRIBUTE THE LETTER WE
PROVIDED ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
AT SEPTEMBER WHICH INCLUDES.
ELEVEN PAGES OF ANSWERS TO THE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT ARE
POSED IN THIS NEW REQUEST.
WE'VE ACTUALLY ASSEMBLED ALL OF
THE REFERENCE REPORTS IN HARD
COPY IS WHILE. OTHER DOCUMENTS
TAKE UP AT LEAST THIRTY BINDERS
ON INSTEAD OF HAULING THAT UP
HERE TODAY WE DECIDE TO KEEP
THINGS SIMPLE AND PROVIDE PHOTO.
I BUT IF DESIRED WE ARE HAPPY TO
BRING ALL OF THAT HARD COPY
MATERIAL TO SOMEONE ABILITY.
MEMBERS THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE IS THAT THERE'S REALLY NO
NEED FOR AN AUDIT COTTINGHAM
COMPEL MY AGENCY TO PROVIDE
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS.
ON IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE'S
REQUEST WE HAVE ALREADY DONE SO.
NONE THE LESS PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ASKS IS
WHAT LESSONS HAVE BEEN LEARNED.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE BAY
BRIDGES COST OVERRUNS THIS IT'S
NO SECRET HAS ALREADY BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF SEVERAL STATE AUDITS.
BUT IT BEARS REPEATING.
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
ANNOUNCEMENT OF AB ONE FORTY
FOUR IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE
TOLL BRIDGE PROJECT OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
BY THAT BILL. AND IS COMPRISED
OF MY AGENCIES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATIONS.
COMMISSIONS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND THE CALTRANS DIRECTOR HAD
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THE BAY BRIDGE
AND THE OTHER TOLL BRIDGE
SEISMIC PROJECTS WITHIN THE
BUDGET AND SCHEDULE SET AT THAT
TIME NOW THIRTEEN YEARS AGO.
HOW?
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE TV POCK AS
IT'S KNOWN CREATED A RISK
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE THAT ENABLE
PROBLEMS TO BE IDENTIFIED EARLY.
AND HOLDS PROJECT MANAGERS
ACCOUNTABLE IN AN OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER.
THE MEETINGS OF COURSE ARE OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC
ARE WE SUBMIT QUARTERLY REPORTS
ON EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. ON
SO THAT ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE COMING UP ON IDENTIFIED
EARLY IN AND IT VERY
TRANSPARENT.
TRANSPARENT MEANT MANNER.
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE
CONTINGENCIES WERE ADDED TO EACH
CONTRACT BECAUSE A SIMPLE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS THAT COMPLEX
CAPITAL PROJECTS OFTEN COST MORE
THAN ORIGINALLY FORECAST AS
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSING
TODAY.
IN FACT THE TV POP HAS BECOME A
MODEL FOR OTHER MAKE PROJECTS
AND IS HERALDED AS A MODEL IN
THE NATIONAL RESEARCH ON THE
SUBJECT.
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
OVERSIGHT ON COST CONTROL THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO HAS
CREATED A SIMILAR OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE FOR THE TRANSBAY
TRANSIT CENTER. AND INVITED OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR STEVE HAMM
ANGER TO SERVE ON IT BECAUSE OF
HIS EXPERIENCE ON THE TV POCK.
IN CONCLUSION THE LESSONS OF THE
BAY BRIDGE ARE BEING APPLIED TO
OTHER PROJECTS IN THE BAY AREA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY. EVERYDAY
ON WITHOUT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE. CALTRANS
DIRECTOR OF MALCOLM DOUGHERTY
THOUGHTS PAVE THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
JUST ECHO US SOME OF THE SAME
POINTS IN ELABORATE SLIGHTLY AND
PUT FIRST FOREMOST.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD.
BE PREPARED TO ASSIST IN ANY.
AUDIT THAT THE STATE AUDITOR
CONDUCTED.
AT THE REQUEST OF THAT THIS
BODY AYE THE NEWLY SPAN AS PART
OF AN OVER ARCHING A TOLL BRIDGE
PROGRAM TO SEISMICALLY UPGRADE
ALL THE TOLL BRIDGES IN THE BAY
AREA. OF COURSE THE BAY BRIDGE
WAS THE ONLY REPLACEMENT THE
OTHERS WERE RETROFITTED.
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY HAVE BEEN MANY
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
CHALLENGES THAT WERE OVERCOME ON
THIS PROJECT.
BUT AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE ONE
SIGNIFICANT POINT TIME WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE WHEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FORTY FOUR WAS WAS
PASSED IN YSTAD WISHED A TIME
FRAME. ANDY BUDGET FORCED TO
CONDUCT THE REMAINDER OF THAT
WORK IN THAT LEGISLATION.
NOT ONLY CREATED THAT SCHEDULE
WHICH CALLED FOR THE BRIDGE TO
BE OPEN AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WHICH IT
WAS BUT IT ALSO ESTABLISHED. UP
A BUDGET.
AND WE ARE STILL ACTIVELY
FIGHTING TO STAY WITHIN THAT
BUDGET THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE. AND I
CHALLENGE YOU TO FIND ANOTHER
MEGA PROJECT ON ITS ORDER TO
STAY WITHIN A BUDGET AND ON
SCHEDULE FOR THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS OF ITS EXISTENCE.
BUT AS JUST AS IMPORTANT CREATED
THE TOLL BRIDGE PROGRAM
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WITH THREE
MEMBER AGENCIES MYSELF. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CDC
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
TO SEE ABOUT IT WHICH WAS
MENTIONED. OF THAT BODY APPROVED
ALL DESIGN CHANGES AND ALSO A
APPROVED OF ALL CHANGE ORDERS
OVER A CERTAIN THRESHOLD THE
BODY DOES MEET IN PUBLIC I WOULD
ALSO. COMMENT THAT.
IT IS IN ACCORDANCE WITH BAG WE
CAN THANK THE LEGISLATION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER. BAKER.
BUT WE ALSO AND I CALLED FOR
QUARTERLY REPORTS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE AND WHEN THE
FOURTH QUARTER OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN IS DISTRIBUTED.
ARE VERY SHORTLY YOU WILL BE THE
FORTY EIGHT SUCH QUARTERLY
REPORT THAT WE DISTRIBUTE.
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT I DO
WANT NOTICES IS IT OUR.
INDICATORS EVERYONE OF THOSE.
REPORTS INDICATED THE ORIGINAL
BUDGET ANY ADJUSTMENTS TO THOSE
BUDGET AND EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE
ON THE COST TO DATE AND THE
PROJECTED COST AT THE
COMPLETION.
OF OF THAT TASK AND WE'VE BEEN
DOING THAT QUARTERLY FOR THE
LACK OF FOR SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE. WE ARE BEING VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN COMING IN ON THE
BUDGET SET IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE AND BE VERY INNOVATIVE AND
UTILIZING DIFFERENT.
A CONTRACTING METHODS TO TRY TO
SAVE TIME AND MONEY THE MOST
RECENT EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE
ACCELERATED TIMEFRAME THAT WE
DID THE AND.
DEMOLITION OF THE MARINE
FOUNDATIONS WHICH WE SHAVED OFF
A YEAR AND SAVE TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. SO WITH THAT SAID I
I THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO DO
LESSONS LEARNED WE HAVE
CONDUCTED SUCH AN EXERCISE AND I
THINK THERE WILL BE A TIME TO DO
SO.
AT ANOTHER TIME.
IN ADDITION TO THE ONE THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN COMPLETED ONE WERE
WRAPPED UP WITH ALL THE
REMAINING ACTIVITIES.
BUT AGAIN WE STAND READY DO PARA
SUPPORT THE STATE AUDITOR IF AT
ALL IT WAS A REQUESTED BY THIS
BODY ON AND WITHOUT I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MS RUBIO.
IT'S JUST A COMMENT I UNDERSTAND
AND I CAN FEEL THE THE TENSION
HERE BUT IT'S REALLY
CONDESCENDING WHEN YOU BRING A
PICTURE OF THIRTEEN BINDERS HAS
THEREFORE NOT KEEP LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIRTEEN
BINDERS IS HARD TO COME UP.
WHATEVER'S GOING ON.
BETWEEN YOU AND MR LEVIN SHOULD
NOT BLEED INTO OUR OUR OUR
POSITION HERE I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON I'M FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
REALLY JUST FEELS VERY
DISRESPECTFUL. TO GET OF A
PICTURE OF A BINDER SO I CAN BE
JUST A SARCASTIC AND ASK YOU
WHEN YOU GONNA PARTICIPATE ARE
GONNA SEND PICTURES TO THE
AUDITOR.
I I JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT
OUT BECAUSE AGAIN IT FEELS VERY
DISRESPECTFUL WHATEVER IS GOING
ON BETWEEN MR LEVINE AND YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS NOT WHAT I'M HERE
TO ASSESS. SO I JUST WANTED TO
POINT THAT OUT.
I WANT TO LISTEN TO THE MERITS
OF THAT THE REQUEST OF THE AUDIT
AND AGAIN I'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE
WHEN THE MEMBERS ARE HAVING
SPATS BETWEEN THE DEPTH OF THEIR
THEIR AGENCIES. AND AND AGAIN I
WOULD CAUTION YOU FOR NEXT TIME
DIED WHEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENED SOMEBODY LIKE ME WOULD
BE COMPELLED JUST TO DO THE
AUDIT JUST BECAUSE. OF THE
SARCASM INVOLVED.
BUT MY APOLOGIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT I THINK
THAT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
REALLY CONVEY IS THAT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK AND
RESPONSIVENESS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY PROVIDED. AND WE THOUGHT
THAT IT WOULD BE LESS KERN.
IN YOUR FACE IF YOU WILL THEN
BRINGING UP THE BINDERS
THEMSELVES WHICH YOU KNOW IS
THAT WOULD TAKE UP AS A HUGE
MASS SPACE THAT WOULD BE A.
SERIOUS INCONVENIENCE ON ITSELF
AYE BUT POINT TAKEN.
ALRIGHT CENTER BAKER THENCE OF
BURRIS.
AND MS BAKER THEN CENTER BELL.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I.
SUPPORT YOUR ORIGINAL AUDIT
MISTER LEVINE I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY WELL WRITTEN SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO I'M ONLY SORRY THAT IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN EARLIER BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE THE BALLOT MEASURE
COMING FORWARDBEFORE BAY AREA
VOTERS WHERE THIS WOULD BE
HELPFUL INFORMATION HOW.
AND I DISAGREE THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARY I UNDERSTAND THERE
HAVE BEEN STUDIES AYE AYE
REPRESENTING EAST BAY DISTRICT I
HAVE THOUSANDS OF NOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONSTITUENTS PAIN
THOSE TOLLS EVERYDAY. GOING
ACROSS THE BRIDGE.
AND WHAT WHAT WHAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED ISN'T JUST THAT WE'VE
LEARNED OUR LESSON.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IN THE REQUEST
WHICH IS HAVE YOU CHANGED YOUR
PRACTICES.
THAT IS PROBABLY THE SINGLE BEST
PART IN MY OPINION OF THIS AUDIT
WITH THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN.
AND AND WHAT YOU DON'T WANT. IS
BINDERS AND STACKS OF REPORTS
INTERNAL.
I REVIEW THAT LISTS ALL THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
DIFFERENTLY STACKED UP AND NOT
ACTUALLY APPLIED IN PRACTICE.
SO. I WAS HOPING THAT THERE
WOULD BE A FULL EMBRACE OF THIS
AUDIT FOR THAT REASON ALONE
WHICH IS.
YEP FOLKS WHEN THEY SEE SUCH A
PROJECT WITH SUCH COST OVERRUNS.
BEYOND WHAT YOU WOULD NORMALLY
EXPECT IN A. IN A PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE FOR ANY
DO ALL THE STUDIES TO FIND OUT
WHAT WENT WRONG THEY'RE GONNA
CHANGE THEY'RE GONNA CHANGE
THEIR PRACTICES.
THIS IS THE ONLY AUDIT I'VE SEEN
THAT THAT.
WILL REALLY LOOK AT HAVE YOU
ACTUALLY DONE IT NUMBER ONE.
SO IT IS NEEDED AND I I HOPE
THERE WILL BE A FULL EMBRACE.
AND IT GETS ME NUMBER TWO
BECAUSE THERE'S TOO LITTLE
INDEPENDENCE
THAT A AND M. T. C. ARE
BASICALLY ONE IN THE SAME.
AND THERE'S ONLY THREE VOICES
AND IN THEM.
AND I BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF NONPARTISAN
INDEPENDENT COMPLETELY OUTSIDE
AUDIT TO LOOK AT. NOT ONLY THE
OTHER AT ELEMENTS OF THE OUT OF
A PARTICULAR NUMBER FOUR.
AND SO I THINK YOU MISTER LEVINE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I I
LIKE TO ASK THE AUDITOR IT'S
UNFORTUNATE I DON'T KNOW THAT
THIS WILL BE.
OUT AND AVAILABLE TO US IN TIME
FOR THE BAY AREA TO DECIDE IF
IT'S GONNA RAISE ITS TOLLS.
AND END TO SEE THAT YOU'VE
EARNED THE AT THESE ENTITIES OF
EARNS THAT ADDITIONAL MONEY IN
TERMS OF THEIR PRACTICES.
DO YOU HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
START WITH ONE PARTICULAR PART
OF THE AUDIT AND REALLY DIVE
INTO THAT FIRST IS THAT.
AT IS THAT PRUDENT WITH THAT
MESS UP THE ABILITY FOR YOU TO
HAVE AN EFFECTIVE OUTCOME
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE WANT IS
EFFECTIVE INFORMATION BUT I'M.
AND I AM NOT LOOKING NEITHER WAS
I BEFORE TO AMEND THE AUDIT I'M
JUST CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO.
GET TO A QUESTION EARLIER.
AND PROVIDE THAT TO US.
WE CERTAINLY CAN'T DO THAT.
WHAT WEEK WE COULD DO ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT AND AS I
NOTED IN MY OPENING COMMENTS
THERE THERE WEREN'T ANY AUDITS
WHERE THERE WAS A SPECIFIC
DEADLINE REQUESTED BY? THE
MEMBER.
BUT WHAT WE WE COULD TAKE TWO
APPROACHES TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT IF IT'S THE DESIRE THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE THIS BE A.
PRIORITY I HAVE TEAMS AS I
INDICATED THAT ALREADY HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING SO. IF THE
COMMITTEE CHOOSES TO APPROVE
THIS AUDIT WE WERE ASSIGNED
STAFF TO IMMEDIATELY. GET THE
AUDIT STARTED WE COULD AGAIN
TAKE TWO APPROACHES.
POTENTIALLY THROW ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AT IT TO TRY TO GET IT
DONE.
BEFORE I THINK THE REGIONAL
MEASURES ON THE BALLOT FOR EARLY
JUNE SO THIS WOULD BE A VERY
TIGHT TIMEFRAME. THE OTHER THING
THAT WE COULD DO IS IF THERE'S A
DESIRE BY THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE
ANSWERS TO CERTAIN OBJECTIVES.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE PAST AS
WE'VE ISSUED TWO REPORTS THERE'S
A POINT ONE THAT ADDRESSES THESE
TWO OBJECTIVES AND HERE'S A
POINT TO THAT ADDRESSES THE
REMAINDER OF?
THE QUESTIONS THAT MR LEVINE AND
CERTAINLY THE COMMITTEE IF THE
COMMITTEE APPROVES THE THE AUDIT
SO THAT'S THAT'S AN OPTION THAT
NAM WE COULD CONSIDER AS WELL.
AND AND AND I WOULD WELCOME AT
IT WITH RESPECT TO OUR.
COLLEAGUES HAVE AUTHORED THE
AUDIT
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
BECAUSE I I DO THINK THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR THE DECISION THAT
WILL BE MADE. PROBABLY JUNE
MAYBE NOVEMBER.
AND.
AND A IN THE INTEREST OF FULL
TRANSPARENCY AND OWNING THAT
BOTH THAT MEASURE AND.%
BAY BRIDGE OPERATIONS HAVING
THIS OUT THERE IF I MAY ASK
MISTER LEVINE DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON EITHER OF THOSE TWO
OPTIONS.
WHICH I MEAN TO SPRING ON YOU I
DIDN'T REALIZE THEY WERE TO
OPTION THAT WE HAD IT'S AN
INTERESTING QUESTION I I
CERTAINLY HAD HOPED WHEN I
PRESENTED THE AUDIT LAST YEAR
THAT THIS WOULD BE SOMETHING
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE COMPLETED.
.
YOU KNOW BY NOW.
I THAT ACTUALLY NTC BATTER
CALTRANS COULD ACTUALLY
DEMONSTRATE GOOD NEWS OR IF
THERE WAS WORK TO DO.
REMEDIATION
TO BURN.
THE TRUST IN SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC
JUST IN GENERAL NOT SPECIFIC TO
ON A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN AROUND
PASSAGE OF ARM THREE WHICH WE
DID NOT KNOW. A DATE AND THAT WE
ACTUALLY I DON'T BELIEVE THEY'VE
ACTUALLY SET A DATE YET WHAT HAS
BEEN SET HAVE.
SO ON I KNEW THAT THAT WAS WHAT
THEY WERE CONTEMPLATING. BUT IT
WAS MY HOPE THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW EVEN IF THEY
GOT A BAD.
SCORE RIGHT OUT OF YOU KNOW ON
THIS TEST SO TO SPEAK
I THINK IT'S A LOOK YOU KNOW
WE'RE GLAD WE GOT THAT SORTED DO
A WHOLE LOT BETTER.
.
SO BY THE TIMING OF THIS IS
DIFFERENT
I THINK.
THE THING THAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
TO ME AND I THINK TO THE MEMBERS
IS THAT THE AUDIT IS.
.
EXHAUSTIVE AND AND INEFFICIENT
AT THE SAME TIME.
AND THAT IT'S USABLE AND USEFUL
BY THE AGENCIES AROUND AS WELL
AS SIDE TO THIS BODY.
ON TO PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT
THAT'S NECESSARY AND I DON'T
WANT TO SIT HERE AND AND.
DICTATE HOW THE AUDITOR USES HER
RESOURCES AND I WOULD TRUST THE
AUDITOR TO USE OUR RESOURCES IN
A WAY THAT HELPS HER UP PURSUE
THAT MISSION.
OF I MEAN I I THINK YOU AND I
THINK WHAT I HEARD.
THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR IN A
FEW HOURS AGO WAS WE'VE WE HAVE
THE PEOPLE WE HAVE TIME WERE
READY.
AND WE DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF A TIME SENSITIVITY. I'M ALSO
HEARING THAT YOU'VE I THINK IT
ORIGIN AMOUNT THAT YOU CAN GET
THIS WORK DONE.
EVEN UNDER AN EXPEDITED I I
PERSONALLY HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
BIFURCATING THERE ARE DOING
DIFFERENT PARTS OF DIFFERENT
TIMES I DON'T KNOW IF THAT NEEDS
AN ADDITIONAL MOTION OR IF THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE AS A
COMMITTEE IF WE AGREE. COULD
COULD DIRECT BUT I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE RESULTS
TO THE OUT IT COULD BE AVAILABLE
BEFORE IT WITHIN SEVERAL MONTHS
ON THE TIME FRAME YOU'VE
INDICATED WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU'VE SAID YOU MAY BE ABLE
TO DEDICATE TO IT. AND THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD MOVE IT IF IT HAS
NEVER BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
NIGHT. SOUNDS LIKE IT MAY BE
AGREEABLE.
I YEAH.
YEAH I THINK IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT NEEDS A
MOTION I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU
BUT I KNOW THAT I'VE HEARD IT
YOU CAN DO THAT.
IS TO PUT YOUR RESOURCES INTO
IT AND I WOULD URGE US TO DO
THAT IF IT TAKES ACTION FROM
THIS COMMITTEE I WOULD URGE THAT
AS WELL.
WELL AS I INDICATED MS BAKER WE
COULD CERTAINLY THROW WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE I'VE GOT
STAFF READY TO START AUDITS AND
HAVE COMPLETED AUDITS AND.
ARE WORKING ON PARTICULAR
PROJECTS IN HOUSE OUR LOCAL HIGH
RISK PROGRAM AND OTHERS SO WE
HAVE THE STAFF TO TO ASSIGNED TO
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT. ON IF
IT'S THE DESIRE OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR US TO GET THIS DONE BY A
APPRECIATE THAT DIRECTION BUT
WHAT WE WOULD DO IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE THAT IF THE
ENTIRE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT THEN
AND SOUND LIKE MISTER LEVINE
WANTS US TO KEEP THIS AS.
COMPREHENSIVE TOGETHER THEN YOU
KNOW WE WE'VE DONE THIS IN THE
PAST WHERE WE'VE HAD A FAST
TRACK AUDIT BUT IT'S PRETTY.
TYPICALLY BEEN A REQUEST OF A
MEMBER OR MOTION BY THE
COMMITTEE TO SAY THAT WE WANT
THE AUDITOR GET THIS AUDIT DONE.
BY THE END OF MAY NAM IF THIS
MEASURE IN FACT IS ON THE
BALLOT.
A FOR JUNE AND I THINK IT'S
EARLY JUNE.
WERE TALKING FOR MONTHS SO WE
CAN DO IT. ARM IT WILL BE A PUSH
BUT WE CAN DO IT.
THAT'S THE DESIRE THE COMMITTEE.
TERRIBLE.
.
YOU THINK THE RULES SUBCOMMITTEE
ARE WOULD MAKE A MOTION ON THE.
I DON'T WHO WANT TO EXPEDITE THE
HAS TO BE A SUBSEQUENT MOTION.
IN THE RULES BUT MY.
EMOTIONAL MAGRIS NEW.
.
APPROVED A AUDIT THAT'S SO.
I THINK IT'S SO FORTHRIGHTLY
GOOD AUTO LIKE TO SEE THE FULL
RESULTS.
.
I MAKE A MOTION SIR.
ASSEMBLYMAN AND I.
HAD LONG DISCUSSIONS AND.
CAN AGREEMENT ON THIS AND.
I THINK IT WILL HELP THE AGENCY.
IF WE DO THERE OUGHT SO THAT'S
MY MOTION WHAT WHAT.
IT DO YOU HAVE ANY OPINION AS
TO A.
EXPEDITING THE THE AUDIT WELL I
HAVE AN OPINION ABOUT WHICH
OUGHT TO BE EXPEDITED AND
CERTAINLY YEAH I WOULD I WOULD
THINK. YEAH I WOULD HAVE THE
HIGHEST REAL.
TO BE HONESTABOUT IT THAT'S THE
ONE THAT HAS THE HIGHEST
FINANCIAL REDUCE.
SHE WANTED TO EXPEDITE ORDER
THAT WOULD BE.
THE ITEM THAT YOU WANNA.
PLANS ARE HERE TO HAVE TO AUDIT
EXPEDITED.
AND IT MAY NOT AND THAT'S TO
MOTIONS.
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION I THOUGHT
THE EXPERTS WERE EXPEDITING BUT
THE RESULTS OF NUMBER FOR. ONLY.
AND YOU'RE GONNA START THE
AUDIT.
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION SO I'M
VERY MUCH I'M NOT I MEAN WE'RE
STARTING THE AUDIT AND THE
REQUEST WOULD BE TO. TO DO
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER FOUR FIRST.
IT'S WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING OKAY
SPIN AND PERHAPS AYE I CONFUSED
THE SITUATION IS RUBIO WHAT I
WAS WHEN I WAS RESPONDING TO MS
BAKER'S QUESTION I SAID THERE
ARE TWO OPTIONS ONE WOULD BE. TO
THROW ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ASK
THIS AUDIT PERHAPS.
STAFF IT. UP MORE ROBUSTLY THAN
WE TYPICALLY WOULD AND LOOK AT
ALL
.
LEVINE.
INTERESTED.
KING IT'S NOT OKAY GO AHEAD.
OKAY THERE WE GO
SO I I THINK IT'S THE DESIRE
MISTER LEVINE THE REQUESTER AND
I THINK THE COMMENTS BY MS BAKER
AS WELL AS TO HAVE US DO THE
ENTIRE AUDIT ALL AT ONCE. BUT.
IF THE COMMITTEE DECIDES TO
DIRECT US TO GET THE AUDIT DONE
BY THE END OF MAY.
THAT'S I THINK WHAT THE
DISCUSSION I AM WISER THE MOTION
THAT I MISSED BAKER WAS
INDICATING SO WOULD BE LOOKING
AT ALL OF THE OBJECTIVES. AS WE
TYPICALLY DO AN AUDIT BUT TRYING
TO GET THE WORK DONE BY THE END
FOR ME ALSO THAT.
OKAY.
SO WHY DON'T WE.
.
FIRST IS.
ADDRESS THE MOTION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT TO APPROVE THIS
AUDIT AND THEN WE CAN. HAVE A
SUBSEQUENT IS.
DISCUSSION TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION
AS TO EXPEDITING.
EITHER THIS OR HIGH SPEED RAIL
OR.
BOTH OR NEITHER AND RIGHT.
I'VE.
SO.
SEE.
ANY OTHER.
LESSONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
ARE THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THIS MATTER.
SEEING NO ONE COMING FORWARD.
MR LEVINE WHICH ELECT CLOSE.
YEAH I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ALSO
MEMBERS FOR THE THE QUALITY OF
THE.
THE CONVERSATION IN THE DEBATE
ALSO ONE EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
OUT TO MISTER DOUGHERTY IN HIS
EXPRESSION OF WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH STATE AUDITOR WITCHES.
A HIGH DEGREE PROFESSIONALISM.
TO BE DEMONSTRATED WITHOUT THE.
THAT THE MOCKING RIDICULE AND
AND DISRESPECT THAT MISS RUBIO
PICKED UP FROM MTC ARE OUT WHICH
I THINK IS A DIFFERENT ISSUE
THAT DOES NEED TO BE RESOLVED BY
THAT AGENCY AND MAYBE THEY CAN
REFLECT ON THAT WHEN THEY DRIVE
HOME THIS AFTERNOON. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THOUGH.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE.
MOTION'S BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
RA.
MADAM SECRETARY
ON THE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OH FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCI
CHOI. MERCI CHI I ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
SANTIAGO.
THIS IS.
A CHAIR RECOMMENDS AYE. AYE.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WHEN.
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
BELL.
FELL AYE CANNELLA.
FULLER.
LARA.
MENDOZA.
THE MOTIONS ON HOLD.
ALRIGHT.
YOU.
THANK YOU THAT.
REQUEST IS ON CALL.
AND SO WHERE IS MY CHEN.
OKAY SO.
.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MS BAKER HAS EMOTION COULD YOU
RESTATE THE MOTION PLEASE.
YES THE MOTION IS TO.
A.
HAVE THE AUDITOR COMPLETE THE
OUT AT THAT WE JUST VOTED ON.
A ISSUE REPORT BY THE END OF
MAY.
ALRIGHT IT'S OUR SECOND.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS.
ANY DISCUSSION SARAH I JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION OF. EXCUSE ME
OF THE STATE AUDITOR IN
EXPEDITING THIS.
AUDIT WHICH I DON'T OBJECT TO
WELL THAT AND ANYWAY DELAY THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUDIT THAT
PRESUMABLY WAS VOTED ON EARLIER
ABSOLUTELY NOT WARY HAVE STAFF
READY TO GO ON HIGH SPEED RAIL
PERFECT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN NONE.
I'M SECTOR PLEASE FILL THE.
ROLL CALL TO EXPLAIN AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE OH FORTS BE COMPLETED
BY THE END OF MAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCI CHI. MERCY
AYE ACOSTA.
WELL I
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WAY.
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
SPELL.
BELL NO CANNELLA.
FULLER.
LARA.
MENDOZA.
ITEMS ALSO ON CALL.
ALRIGHT I BELIEVE THAT.
.
CONCLUDES THE HEARING PORTION.
WE WILL.
I KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR VOTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE ONE.
FOR YOU WILL COME BACK.
WHAT ARE WE HAVEN'T CLOSED SAID
HE HAD?
BUT YES WE DO ANY SENATORS.
I HAVE THOSE.
BOB.
SO.
RAIL.
NO I DON'T.
I MEAN.
OKAY LET ME CALL.
FOR.
ADDITIONAL VOTES.
.
ON THE REGULAR CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER FIVE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OH. EIGHT SENATOR ROTH. ROTH
AYE.
ALLEN.
SENATOR LARA.
I MOTIONS PASS.
RIGHT A.
NEXT ITEM.
FOR THE SENATORS TO ADD ON TO.
ALRIGHT.
NEXT ITEM IS ON THE REGULAR
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER THREE.
THE AUDIT OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT CRIME
REPORTING STATISTICS.
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS NO.
ROLL CALL PLEASE
BROKAW TO PROVIDE IT NUMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE OH
FIVE SENATOR ROTH.
NOT LOADING.
SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATOR LARA.
LARA NELL.
AGAIN MOTION IS
ON CALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO.
AND ALGUNO.
CANCER THAT COUNTS AS A.
WE NEED FOR.
TO
I NEED.
YOU NEED TO WORK MISSION HERE.
NONE OF.
SO REFERENCE NOT.
CONSEQUENCES.
WE GOT THIS CONFLICT. WITH.
WE HAVE A NEED FOR.
SO DOESN'T FAIL A STONE COLD.
IF YOU WANT KEEP THEM CALM.
GOOD EVENING I WOULD KEEP.
BOOKS ARE STILL SURE OKAY ALSO
WHAT.
YEAH.
I CAN OPEN UP TO UPLOAD.
I THINK THAT.
PUNISHMENT ITSELF HOLDS.
BOB.
.
YEAH.
UNTIL.
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK.
WHICH.
IT'S GOING.
SOME OF THEM.
YEAH.
HE HAS.
THE PROGRAM.
AS A MATTER.
AND I GOT ONE THE PLACE.
YEAH.
BUT A LOT.
THAT'S GREAT PARTICULAR HER.
WE.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MORE MINUTES.
BEFORE WE ADJOURN THIS HEARING.
SO TWELVE ALL FIVE.
BUT WOULD IT WOULDN'T WANT ONE
INCH JUST CALLED.
LARGEST CALL THE ITEM SO THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
ENOUGH TO
.
YOU CAN JUST CALL.
YEAH.
YEAH IT SHE MISSES ISSUE MISS.
HARRIS.
YEAH EVERYONE.
WHICH IS NOT.
YEAH.
NO.
YEAH WELL ABOUT.
SO YOU CAN JUST TALK OR.
SOMETHING STATE OUT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOUNDS. OUTSIDE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OF SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ROLL CALL TO PROVE AND THE AUDIT
OF THE LOS ANGELES ELVES LAPD
CRIME REPORTING STATISTICS SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND LACKEY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
AND.
ALLEN SENATOR ALAN.
HE'S NOT LOADING.
SAN.
AND.
OKAY SO A.
THE.
REQUEST FOR THE LAPD. CRIME
REPORTING STATISTICS.
.
IT'S A NIGHT.
WHAT WAS THE VOTE TALLY?
I IT'S A SPLIT EVEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY HOWEVER ON THE SENATE
AT THEIR USE OF IT WE'RE MISSING
ONE MORE VOTE.
I HAD
TWO I AM ON THE SENATE AND ONE
NOW
.
SMOKING
ALRIGHT SO THE LESSER ANY
OBJECTIONS FEE MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION SCRATCHING.
ROLL CALL TO CONSIDERED TO
RECONSIDER THE AUDIT OF LAPD.
YES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION YEAH.
THERE WERE.
CLICK ON.
ROLL CALL TO PROVIDE A NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
I'LL A CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY BY SENATOR PELL.
SENT A SIMILAR SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN I.
THE MOTION PASSES MOTION PASSES.
BROKAW NCSU APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OF FOUR OF THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION BY
SUMMER REMEMBER LIVING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAYNE.
WOULD I.
ALAN.
ALLEN. I.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
SENATOR LARA.
LARA I.
THE MOTION PASSES.
OF
FOR SENATE'S I.
AND.
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL.
ALRIGHT.
AND ROLL CALL TO AN EX BY
EXPEDITE THE AUDIT A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASHED WHEN NO
FOUR OF METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO BE
COMPLETED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
BY END OF ME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAYNE.
SENATOR ALLEN.
NOT VOTING.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
SENATOR LARA.
SENATE CANNELLA.
THE VOTING TO AND EXPEDITE THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
OH FOR.
BAY BRIDGE.
THE OWNER. CANNELLA AYE.
OKAY.
.
UNIBOMBER SEMICONDUCTOR.
ROTH YEAH.
NO. I DON'T.
THREE.
MEDICAL TEN AND.
YOU KNOW PASSED.
ALRIGHT SO YOU'RE SHORT ONE VOTE
ON ONE SENATOR VOTE.
WE KNOW THIS THE MOTION TO
EXPEDITE THE.
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSIT AND TO
SEE AUDIT REQUEST YOU GO IN THE
REVIEW.
AND. WITH THAT SYSTEM EXPLODED
MY DIFFERENT THOUGH. YEAH.
BUT VOTE FOR THAT VERY.
OKAY WENT WATCHES THE WATCHES
COME UP HERE AND ADD ONS. OF
CANADA.
IF. OUR CUSTOMER.
IF YOU WANTED TO GO IN THERE
WITH THEM.
I I. IT IS MAKE SURE THAT
CANNELLA VOTE ON EVERYTHING YEAH
I JUST GO THROUGH ALL YOUR
SHEETS.
THEN.
THE WORK.
HARPER SESSION BACK OR SERGEI
AND NOW IT'S THE WHO SHOULDNT
ADEQUATE GREAT THANK YOU PARENTS
THINK.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU CENTRALIS FOR
THEM.
NO.
REALLY BY MORE.
YES.
AND.
.
YEAH THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
THEY MIGHT AYE AYE SIR MICHAEL I
SAID FIVE MINUTES